WE STAY ON THE SENATE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE WILL
COME TO ORDER. WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HERE IN THE SWING
SPACE. 1021 Ó STREET, ROOM
1200, WE CURRENTLY, ARE CLOSE TO
A QUORUM, BUT LACK OF QUORUM.
I'M GOING TO ASK MEMBERS OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE TO PROCEED TO
ROOM 1200 AT YOUR EARLIEST
CONVENIENCE. PUBLIC COMMENT WILL
BE HEARD AFTER ALL. DISCUSSION
ITEMS HAVE BEEN PRESENTED. SO
WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO SEPARATE
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR THE THREE
ITEMS. AND SO WE'RE HEARING
THREE BILLS TODAY RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. AB 107, WHICH IS THE
BUDGET ACT OF 2024, AB 154,
AROUND EDUCATION FINANCE AND
PROP 98 SUSPENSION AND AB 167
REGARDING TAXATION UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION, WE'RE
REQUIRED TO PASS A BALANCED
BUDGET NO LATER THAN JUNE 15TH,
AND WE WILL DO SO VIA THE BUDGET
THAT WE ARE CONSIDERING TODAY,
THE BUDGET BUILDS ON, THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROPOSAL AND
MAY REVISION PROPOSAL, AND, THE
BUDGET INCLUDES SIGNIFICANT
INPUT FROM THE SENATE, WE HAD 54
SENATE SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS AND
THREE FULL COMMITTEE HEARINGS
BEFORE TODAY, AND THE PACKAGE
BEFORE US REPRESENTS THE
COMBINED ACTIONS OF EACH OF OUR
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEES. I WANT TO
PUBLICLY THANK OUR FIVE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS WHO WORKED
INCREDIBLY HARD OVER THE COURSE
OF THIS PROCESS. AB 107
REPRESENTS A BUDGET PLAN THAT
INCLUDES APPROXIMATELY $293
BILLION IN TOTAL SPENDING, 211.3
BILLION OF WHICH IS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND, IT'S A BUDGET THAT
IS BALANCED BOTH IN FISCAL YEAR
2024, 25 AND FISCAL YEAR 2025,
26. IT INCLUDES $46.9 BILLION IN
SOLUTIONS AND THE AND THE 20
2425 FISCAL YEAR AND 29.8
BILLION IN SOLUTIONS IN THE 2526
FISCAL YEARS IN ORDER TO CLOSE
THOSE BUDGET GAPS, THE BUDGET
MAINTAINS, $23.2 BILLION IN
COMBINED TOTAL RESERVES, SO THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT
SAFETY NET IN FUTURE UNCERTAIN
TIMES, I WANT TO JUST STRESS,
DESPITE, HAVING TO ADDRESS A
LARGE BUDGET DEFICIT THIS YEAR,
I WANT TO JUST FOR THOSE WHO I
KNOW, REMEMBER, VERY ACUTELY,
WHAT HAPPENED THE LAST TIME WE
HAD LARGE BUDGET DEFICITS DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION, AND WE HAD
NO BUDGET RESERVES, AND THE
STATE WAS PAYING. QUOTE UNQUOTE,
PAYING EMPLOYEES WITH IOUS. AND,
WE WERE FORCED TO MAKE CUTS THAT
WERE TRULY NIGHTMARISH, AND SO I
SAY WE THAT LEGISLATURE WAS, AND
YOU FAST FORWARD TO TODAY WHERE
BECAUSE OF, RESPONSIBLE ACTIONS
OVER THE YEARS BY GOVERNOR
BROWN, GOVERNOR NEWSOM, AND BY
THE LEGISLATURE, WE NOW HAVE A
VERY SIZABLE BUDGET RESERVE, AND
WE HAVE STABILIZED OUR FINANCES
IN A NUMBER OF WAYS. IT'S NOT TO
SAY THAT THERE ARE NO ISSUES. WE
STILL HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO
IN CALIFORNIA, BUT WE'RE IN A
MUCH BETTER PLACE NOW. AND THIS
PROCESS, I THINK, HAS BEEN MUCH
SMOOTHER, BECAUSE OF THE SMART
DECISIONS THAT THE TWO GOVERNORS
AND THE LEGISLATURE HAVE MADE
OVER THE YEARS, THE TWO TRAILER
BILLS BEFORE US, AB 154 AND 167,
ARE ALSO KEY TO OUR BALANCED
BUDGET, THE SUSPENSION THÀNH OF
PROP 98, WILL ALLOW US TO, TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH EDUCATION
FUNDING AND NOT REDUCE K THROUGH
14 FUNDING, WE ARE IT WAS A HUGE
PRIORITY FOR OUR, FOR OUR
SENATORS. AND I KNOW FOR THE
GOVERNOR, I KNOW FOR THE
ASSEMBLY, TO PROTECT PUBLIC
EDUCATION FUNDING, WE'VE MADE
PROGRESS IN RECENT YEARS IN
TERMS OF FUNDING OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS, AND WE NEED TO MAINTAIN
THAT PROGRESS, WE ALSO IN THE
TRAILER BILLS ARE SEEING, A
REVENUE, CHANGES, INCLUDING
ADOPTION OF THE NET OPERATING
LOSS SUSPENSION, THE BUSINESS
CREDIT LIMITATION, BOTH OF WHICH
WILL COMMENCE IN THE 2024 TAX
YEAR, THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR, SHARE MANY PRIORITIES,
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING A
FULL AGREEMENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION SOON. I ALSO WANT
TO THANK, IN ADDITION TO OUR
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS, I
WANT TO THANK OUR BUDGET STAFF,
BOTH THE STAFF ON THIS COMMITTEE
AND IN THE PRO TEM OFFICE WHO
HAVE BEEN WORKING INCREDIBLY
HARD TO GET US TO THIS POINT AND
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
INCREDIBLY HARD, AS WE MOVE
FORWARD, AND WITH THAT, VICE
CHAIR NEAL, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MAKE ANY COMMENTS, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR, AND SORRY
FOR BEING. EXCUSE ME A LITTLE
BIT LATE. I WAS LATE, TOO, SO.
WELL, BIPARTISAN. GREAT
COINCIDENCE, FIRST OF ALL, I
WILL START OUT BY THANKING OUR
OUR BUDGET STAFF AND THE GREAT
WORK THAT THE LÀ DOES AND ALSO
ADVISING US IT DOES TAKE A LOT
OF TIME. AND THEY HAVE TO FOR
TERMS OF OUR STAFF, THEY HAVE TO
WORK OVER THE WEEKENDS
SOMETIMES. AND THAT'S NOT THE
EASIEST THING. AND THEY PROVIDE
VERY VALUABLE INPUT TO MYSELF
AND OUR COLLEAGUES AND OUR
CAUCUS. AND SO RELATIVE TO THIS
BUDGET, I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS THAT THE CHAIR MADE
THAT WE'RE IN A BETTER PLACE. I
WOULD AGREE WITH THAT. WE'RE IN
A BETTER PLACE THAN WE WERE WITH
REGARD TO THE JANUARY PROPOSAL
BY THE GOVERNOR, BUT WE HAVE
LOTS OF CHALLENGES WITH THIS
BUDGET, I WOULD AGREE IT IS
BALANCED NOMINALLY, IT IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE. AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO GETTING INTO DISCUSSION AS TO
WHY I BELIEVE IT IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE. AND I THINK THIS
BUDGET IS SETTING US UP FOR,
VERY SERIOUS BUILT IN DEFICITS
TO BE DEALT WITH WITH THE
JANUARY, THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
25TH, PROPOSAL AND, WITH REGARD
TO TRAILER BILLS, THE
PROPOSITION 98 SUSPENSION IS ONE
THING, BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S MANEUVER
RELATIVE TO THE 2023 2223 BUDGET
ON PROPOSITION 98 IS STILL PART
OF THE BUDGET. CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG, BUT IF IT IS, THAT IS
THAT SETS US UP FOR FURTHER
ISSUES DOWN THE ROAD. ALSO SO
AND AS FAR AS THE TAXATION IS
CONCERNED, JUST ABOUT EVERY ONE
OF THOSE PROPOSALS IS
FUNDAMENTALLY FLAWED, ONE OF
WHICH IS UNQUESTIONABLY AN
ABSOLUTE TAX INCREASE, WHICH THE
GOVERNOR SAID WE WOULD NOT HAVE,
HAVING SAID THAT, AS I SAID, I
LOOK FORWARD, TO THE DISCUSSION
AS WE GET INTO MORE OF THOSE
DETAILS. OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. VICE CHAIR, WE WILL
NOW BEGIN WITH, GAVE PADDOCK
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. I WANT TO ALSO THANK THE
LAO FOR ITS WORK, HE WILL
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF AB
107, AB 154 AND AB 167. GREAT
WELL, GOOD MORNING, MISTER CHAIR
WIENER AND MISTER VICE CHAIR
NHIÀU AND MEMBERS, GABE PADDOCK,
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST, YES. THE
COMMITTEE STAFF ASKED OUR OFFICE
. I'M SORRY. CAN WE CAN WE
INCREASE THE VOLUME A LITTLE
BIT? A LITTLE? IS IT A LITTLE? Þ
I CAN MOVE CLOSER. OKAY. THANK
YOU. SORRY. YES COMMITTEE STAFF
ASKED OUR OFFICE TO BRIEFLY
DESCRIBE THE ITEMS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. AND SO AS I DO THAT, I
WILL TRY IN PARTICULAR TO
HIGHLIGHT HOW THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PLAN DIFFERS
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL,
I'LL START ACTUALLY WITH AB 167,
WHICH IS THE WHICH IS THE BILL
THAT ALLOWS FOR THE MAIN
STRUCTURAL DIFFERENCE IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE BY PROVIDING
FOR AN ESTIMATED $5 BILLION IN
ADDITIONAL REVENUE ACROSS THE
BUDGET WINDOW. THIS, ADDITIONAL
CAPACITY ENABLES THE LEGISLATIVE
PLAN TO SPEND MORE ON SCHOOLS
AND TO REJECT SOME OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED REDUCTIONS
TO VARIOUS HUMAN SERVICE, HEALTH
AND HOUSING PROGRAMS. THE MAIN
WAY THAT THE BILL DOES THIS IS
BY STARTING THE LIMITATIONS ON
THE BUSINESSES USE OF NET
OPERATING LOSS DEDUCTIONS AND
TAX CREDITS IN THE 2024 TAX
YEAR, WHICH IS ONE YEAR EARLIER
THAN WHAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED. AB 167 ALSO INCLUDES
SOME OF THE GOVERNOR'S,
PROPOSALS, SUCH AS THE
ELIMINATION OF TAX EXPENDITURES
AVAILABLE TO CERTAIN LENDERS AND
OIL COMPANIES, AND PROVIDES FOR
AN EXPANSION OF THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCES AUTHORITY TO POSTPONE
STATE TAX DEADLINES. IN RESPONSE
TO DISASTER DECLARATIONS. MOVING
TO AB 107. THIS IS THE BILL THAT
AUTHORIZES GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES IN THE OVERALL
BUDGET PACKAGE. SOME OF THE
MAIN, OR MAJOR, I SHOULD SAY,
SPENDING DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE AND THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDE, THAT IT
PROVIDES 1 BILLION IN ROUND SIX
FUNDING FOR THE HOMELESS,
HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND
PREVENTION PROGRAM, IT PROVIDES
ABOUT 800 MILLION TO UNDO
REDUCTIONS TO THE MIDDLE CLASS.
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM AND THEN
ALSO 600 MILLION TO UNDO A DELAY
IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE,
DDS SERVICE PROVIDER RATE REFORM
. AND THERE ARE NUMEROUS OTHER
SMALLER CHANGES ACROSS A VARIETY
OF PROGRAMS. ALSO INCLUDED
TURNING TO, BUDGET RESERVES. AS
THE CHAIR ALREADY SAID, THE
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PACKAGE WOULD
END WITH ABOUT $23 BILLION IN
TOTAL RESERVES, WHICH IS 317
MILLION MORE THAN THE MAY
REVISION. HOWEVER, THERE ARE
SOME DIFFERENCES WITHIN THE
CATEGORIES OF RESERVES,
SPECIFICALLY, THE LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE HAS 22 BILLION IN
GENERAL PURPOSE RESERVES, OR 815
MILLION LESS THAN THE MAY
REVISION. THIS IS BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE USES A BIT
MORE FROM THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT, ALTHOUGH
IT USES 450 MILLION LESS FROM
THE SAFETY NET RESERVE. HOWEVER,
THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE ALSO
WOULD MAINTAIN ABOUT 1 BILLION
IN THE PROPOSITION 98 RESERVE,
WHEREAS THE MAY REVISION WOULD
DEPLETE THIS RESERVE BY 20 2425,
OR THE END OF THAT FISCAL YEAR,
AND THEN JUST CONTINUING WITH
EDUCATION IN BROAD STROKES, THE
LEGISLATIVE PLAN FOR SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES DOES ADOPT
THE PROPOSITION 98 CHANGES
ANNOUNCED IN THE. THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY 28TH AGREEMENT WITH THE
EDUCATION GROUPS, AND THIS
INCLUDES THE SUSPENSION OF THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE, WHICH IS THE
ACT IN EFFECTUATED IN AB 154 ON
TODAY'S HEARING AGENDA. THE PLAN
ALSO FUNDS MANY SPECIFIC
SPENDING PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN
THE MAY REVISION, INCLUDING THE
1.07% COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT.
THAT SAID, IT DOES DIFFER FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S FRAMEWORK IN TWO
NOTABLE WAYS, FIRST, THE
LEGISLATIVE PLAN HAS $3 BILLION
MORE IN PROPOSITION 98 FUNDING
AVAILABLE, FROM TWO TO REASONS.
THE FIRST IS THAT BY ADOPTING
THE HIGHER REVENUES IS PROVIDED
BY THE EARLIER START TO THE NOL
AND TAX CREDIT LIMITATIONS, THAT
ADDS REVENUE. AND THEN SECONDLY,
THE LEGISLATIVE PLAN REJECTS A
FEW SPECIFIC SPENDING PROPOSALS,
THE LARGEST OF WHICH IS ABOUT
815 MILLION IN GRANTS FOR
ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUSSES, AND SO
WITH THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING,
THE LEGISLATIVE PLAN USES, THAT
THOSE RESOURCES TO REDUCE THE
STATE'S RELIANCE ON PAYMENT
DEFERRALS. AND THEN, AS I
MENTIONED, IT DOES SAVE NEARLY
1.1 BILLION IN THE PROPOSITION
98 RESERVE. SO THAT I'LL STOP
THERE AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ALONG WITH SOME OF MY
STAFF THAT ARE HERE WITH US.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH, NEXT,
WE'LL HEAR FROM ERIKA LEE FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND I
WANT TO THANK DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR ALWAYS WORKING
CLOSELY WITH US ON THE BUDGET.
THANK YOU. ERIKA LEE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR WIENER. VICE
CHAIR NILO. MEMBERS OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE, I'LL KEEP MY
COMMENTS BRIEF. I JUST WANTED TO
NOTE THAT THE BILLS, THE TWO
BILLS BEFORE US ARE LARGELY
CONSISTENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS, BOTH
AT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND AT
THE MAY REVISION, AND AT THIS
TIME, WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE FOR, TOWARD A
THREE PARTY PLAN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MISS LEE,
OKAY, WE WILL NOW OPEN UP TO
DISCUSSION AND QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I
KNOW, SENATOR LAIRD, DID YOU
EXPRESS YOU WANTED TO SAY
SOMETHING? SENATOR LAIRD? YEAH
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND I KNOW
OTHERS MIGHT TALK ABOUT THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND
REDUCTION, AND I'M NOT EXCITED
ABOUT THAT REDUCTION AND LET
OTHERS TALK ABOUT IT. BUT I
WANTED TO, TO TALK ABOUT THE
EDUCATION PART OF THIS AS THE
CHAIR OF THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
. AND, AND GLOBALLY, WE STARTED
OUT THIS WHOLE BUDGET DISCUSSION
WITH A DEBATE ABOUT WHETHER THE
DEFICIT WAS 58 BILLION OR 73
BILLION. AND WE HAVE IN FRONT OF
US A BALANCED BUDGET THAT
RESTORES MANY OF THE PROPOSED
CUTS IN THE MAY REVISE. THAT IS
VERY SIGNIFICANT. I THINK IT IS
ONE OF THE BIGGER CHANGES FROM A
MAY REVISE IN A POSITIVE WAY.
SINCE I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS
OVER 20 YEARS AND IN EDUCATION,
THE SIGNIFICANT THING AND IT WAS
ALLUDED TO BY THE CHAIR, THE
SIGNIFICANT THING IS, IS THAT
ALL ALONG THE WAY, THERE WERE
POTENTIAL CUTS TO K THROUGH 14
EDUCATION THÀNH AND THIS BUDGET
DOES NOT DO THAT. AND IT IS VERY
SIGNIFICANT IN A DOWN TIME THAT
WE CONTINUE TO MOVE AHEAD. SINCE
2017, OAN THERE'S BEEN A 40%
INCREASE IN IN THE BASIC
PROPOSITION 98 K THROUGH 14
FUNDING, AND IT HAS MOVED US WAY
OUT OF THE BOTTOM OF POOR
STUDENT FUNDING IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS BUDGET AVOIDS STEPPING
BACK FROM THAT. THAT'S VERY
SIGNIFICANT. BUT I THINK ONE OF
THE OTHER SIGNIFICANT THINGS IS
THE DEBATE. UNTIL THIS BUDGET
ABOUT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IS DO WE
GIVE A ZERO INCREASE AND DEFER
THE MAY REVISE ACTUALLY PROPOSED
A SUBSTANTIAL CUT TO BOTH. AND
THIS BUDGET FIGURES OUT A WAY
THAT WE STICK WITH THE AMOUNTS
IN THE COMPACTS, AND WE DO THE
INCREASES MOVING AHEAD. AND
WE'RE AWARE THAT THE FISCAL
CHALLENGES TO THE TWO HIGHER
EDUCATION SEGMENTS ARE ACTUALLY
GREATER THAN EVEN WHAT WE CAN DO
WITH THE RESTORATION, GIVEN
INFLATION DEFERRED MAINTENANCE,
SALARY CONTRACTS, IT IS A
CHALLENGE. BUT THIS REALLY IS AN
EXCELLENT STEP FORWARD IN A
TOUGH BUDGET TO MOVE THEM AHEAD
OF ANY PLACE THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN. AND ANY PROPOSAL THAT'S
BEEN UP TO THE BUDGET THAT IS IN
FRONT OF US TODAY. AND SO, WHILE
I THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE THE
DEBATES THAT THAT HAPPENED IN
THE OPENING STATEMENT, IT'S THIS
IS REMARKABLE GIVEN EVERYTHING
THAT HAS BEEN TO THIS POINT. AND
THERE WERE SOME STATEMENTS ABOUT
HOW THIS BUDGET WAS AIRED. LET
ME JUST TELL YOU, IN THE
EXTENSIVE HEARINGS OF THE
EDUCATION BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE,
WE HAD A DISCUSSION ABOUT
ANYTHING THAT'S ON THE TABLE FOR
EDUCATION IN THIS BUDGET,
WHETHER IT WAS UC, CSU, PROPERTY
IN 98, THE SCHOLARSHIPS AND THIS
SIGNIFICANTLY BRINGS BACK THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP RIGHT
AT THE TIME THAT PARENTS AND
STUDENTS ARE MAKING DECISIONS
ABOUT WHAT COLLEGES TO GO TO AND
WHETHER THEY HAVE THE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES TO GO TO CERTAIN
PUBLIC EDUCATION, HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA, THIS REALLY HELPS.
AND SO, AS DEPRESSED AS I WAS IN
JANUARY AND AS BAD AS SOME OF
THE CUTS STILL ARE THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THIS BUDGET IN
EDUCATION, I THINK WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO STEP AHEAD WITH THIS
BUDGET. AND I'M GOING TO BE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE EDUCATION
PIECES OF THIS, AS WELL AS THE
ENTIRE BUDGET. THANK YOU,
SENATOR SARDO. AND THEN SENATOR
BLAKE, FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I WANT TO PREFACE THIS BY
SAYING TO THIS THE FINANCE STAFF
AND EVERYBODY YOU GUYS DO A
TERRIFIC JOB OF TRYING TO TRYING
TO MELD TOGETHER WHAT IT IS THAT
WE GIVE YOU AND UNDERSTAND ANY
CRITICISMS OR SOUNDS LIKE
CRITICISM IS NOT DIRECTED AT YOU
AT ALL. IT'S DIRECTED AT AT US
AS LEGISLATORS OR THE
ADMINISTRATION ITSELF, IN THE
DIRECTIONS THAT WE GIVE YOU. AND
SO PLEASE DON'T DON'T EVER THINK
THAT I DON'T APPRECIATE WHAT YOU
DO, I WANT TO START WITH, YEAH.
THE, PRISON SYSTEM HERE, THE
CDCR, WE HAVE AN UNALLOCATED,
CUT OF ABOUT $500 MILLION IN, TO
CDCR'S BUDGET. AND THE LANGUAGE
EXEMPTS, SPECIFICALLY EXEMPTS
REENTRY AND REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS, WHICH IS WHERE THERE'S
A LOT OF SPENDING, WHICH MAKES
ME A LITTLE CONCERNED. ARE WE
KIND OF SETTING OURSELVES UP FOR
MORE EARLY RELEASE? IN OTHER
WORDS, IS THAT THE ONLY PLACE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO CUT,
HAVE YOU HAD THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WITH CDCR ABOUT WHERE THEY'RE
GOING TO MAKE THESE $500 MILLION
OF UNALLOCATED CUTS? ERIKA LEE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND I WOULD DEFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON THAT PLAN. THAT WAS
NOT PART OF OUR, MAY REVISION.
OKAY. WELL, I'M I'M HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO THAT THEN. YEAH. IF
YOU COULD. YEAH. NO, ABSOLUTELY,
SO, YEAH, I THINK, YOU KNOW,
REENTRY AND REHABILITATION ARE
INCREDIBLY, IMPORTANT AND WE
DON'T. AND WHEN WE DON'T INVEST
IN REHABILITATION AND WE AND WE
DON'T HELP PEOPLE TRANSITION
FROM PRISON INTO THE COMMUNITY,
WE, THEN WHAT WE SEE IS HIGHER
RATES OF RECIDIVISM AND OUR
BLOATED, OVERLY LARGE PRISON
SYSTEM THEN GETS EVEN BIGGER,
AND FOR SO MANY YEARS, WE'VE
SPENT MORE ON OUR PRISON SYSTEM
THAN ON UC AND CSU, WHICH IS A
STATEMENT OF VALUES. AND IT GOT
TO THE POINT WHERE OUR PRISON
SYSTEM WAS SO BLOATED THAT THAT
THE FEDERAL COURTS DECIDED THAT
OUR PRISON SYSTEM WAS LIKE LIKE
A WALKING, RAMBLING VIOLATION OF
THE US CONSTITUTION BECAUSE WE
COULDN'T PROVIDE EFFECTIVE
HEALTH CARE WITH THAT LEVEL OF
OVERCROWDING IN OUR PRISONS. SO
YEAH, WE'VE DEFINITELY HAVE A
REAL FOCUS ON REENTRY AND
REHABILITATION. THÀNH. AND WE
ARE SPENDING WAY, WAY, WAY TOO
MUCH ON OUR PRISON SYSTEM. AND
I, I CAN'T SAY I SPEAK FOR ALL
OF MY DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES, BUT
I THINK I SPEAK FOR, FOR MANY OF
THEM THAT WE SPEND TOO MUCH ON
OUR PRISON SYSTEM AND WE NEED TO
BE SMARTER ABOUT THE WAY WE RUN
OUR PRISON SYSTEM AND NOT JUST
KEEP THROWING MONEY AT IT, WHICH
IS WHAT WE HAVE HISTORICALLY
DONE IN AN ESCALATING WAY. I
REALLY WANT US TO SPEND MORE ON
ON UCS2 THAN ON PRISONS, SO
THAT'S THAT'S THE CHAIR. THANK
YOU FOR THAT. I KIND OF,
DISAGREE A LITTLE BIT WITH, THE,
ASSERTION THAT THE PRISONS ARE
ESSENTIALLY A NOT NEEDED. I
DIDN'T I DIDN'T SAY THAT. OKAY.
BUT I SAID THEY WERE TOO BIG AND
THEY WERE TOO BIG MONEY ON THEM.
SO WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO DIVEST
IN OUR PRISON SYSTEM INSTEAD OF
FIXING IT AND CREATING A SYSTEM
THAT WORKS FOR ALL OF US. WE'RE
GOING TO DIVEST AND DIVEST AND
RIGHT NOW, WE JUST YOU GUYS JUST
WE ROLLED OUT A CRIME BILL
PACKAGE TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
TOO MANY PEOPLE RUNNING OUT
THERE AND RISING CRIME AND, AND
SO, MY CONCERN IS THIS IS JUST
GOING TO EXACERBATE THAT WHILE
NOW WE FINALLY RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE'S A CRIME ISSUE AND THAT
WE GOT TO GO THE OTHER WAY, I
THIS IS GOING TO CLASH. IN OTHER
WORDS, THIS IS GOING TO CREATE
CREATE PROBLEMS IN THE FUTURE.
AND IT'S GOING TO BE, MORE COSTS
FOR ALL OF US. SO, MY NEXT
QUESTION, THE MINIMUM HEALTH
CARE, OR THE MINIMUM WAGE FOR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS, WE PASSED
THAT LAST YEAR AND, IT'S GOT A
$2 BILLION PRICE TAG TO IT. AND
AND YET WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD,
JULY 1ST WITH THAT, BUT THIS
BUDGET ONLY ADDS $100 MILLION IN
STATE FUNDS TO PAY FOR THIS
BILLS, IMPLEMENTATION COSTS. IS
THAT CORRECT? I'M SORRY. COULD
YOU REPEAT THAT QUESTION? SO
THERE'S A $2 BILLION PRICE TAG
FOR THE MINIMUM WAGE, HEALTH
CARE THAT'S GOING INTO EFFECT ON
JULY 1ST, BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT
DEFERRED THAT. AND, SO THERE'S
NO TRAILER BILL COMING THAT
SAYS, YOU KNOW, THAT ADDRESSES
THIS, BUT THE BUDGET ADDS ONLY
$100 MILLION TO COVER THIS
IMPLEMENTATION, DO WE ANTICIPATE
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE A LARGE
BILL AT THE END OF THIS WHEN IT
DOES GET IMPLEMENTED, THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION. AGAIN. THIS
TWO PARTY PLAN DOES INCLUDE
FUNDING FOR SB 5 TO 5. THE $25
MINIMUM WAGE, AND WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH BOTH THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDER AS
WE MARCH TOWARDS THAT DEADLINE.
SO AT THIS POINT, I WOULD SAY
THAT THE THING FOR THAT FIRST
YEAR AND WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THAT, IS THAT
THE 100, $100 MILLION THAT
YOU'VE INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET, I
BELIEVE THERE IS, IT'S IT IS 100
MILLION GOING TO 300 OR 350
MILLION, OVER MULTIPLE YEARS.
BUT YES, THAT IS THAT IS THE
AMOUNT. OKAY. SO IT HAS A BIGGER
PRICE TAG THAN THAT, THAT I
THINK THAT'S WHAT THE CONCERN IS
ON THAT, THE MCO TAX, LAST YEAR
WHEN WE PASSED THIS MCO TAX, I
REMEMBER, NOT GETTING
NECESSARILY RIDICULED, BUT THAT
I DID NOT UNDERSTAND HOW THIS
TAX WOULD BE USED, BECAUSE MY
CONCERN WAS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
PASS A TAX, WE'RE GOING TO WIND
UP IN THE GENERAL FUND AND THE
MEDI-CAL REIMBURSEMENT. PART OF
IT WOULD NOT HAPPEN IN THE
MANNER THAT WE WERE STAYING. AND
THAT APPEARS TO BE WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THIS BUDGET IS,
THERE'S $2.7 MILLION THAT'S
SUPPOSED TO GO TO MEDICAL
MEDI-CAL REIMBURSEMENT, WHICH IS
SUPPOSED TO HELP SERVE THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE BEING ADDED ON
TO THE PROGRAM, IF WE'RE NOT
DOING THAT, HOW ARE WE GOING TO
CONTINUE ADDING PEOPLE TO A
PROGRAM WHERE THERE'S GOING TO
BE LESS PEOPLE TO SERVE THEM
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GET THE
REIMBURSEMENT THEY NEED TO STAY
AFLOAT, AND JUST TO CLARIFY, THE
MAY REVISION RECOGNIZED THAT THE
COST OF THE MCO PACKAGE, WAS NOT
SUSTAINABLE. SO THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISION WITHDREW THE MCO
PROPOSAL. THE TWO PARTY PLAN
INCLUDES THE MCO PROPOSAL. AND
IT JUST THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN
THE TWO PLANS. AND I WOULD SAY
THAT IN REGARDS TO THE USE OF
THE MEDI-CAL REVENUE IN THE
PAST, WE HAVE THE STATE HAS USED
THOSE REVENUES TO BACKFILL
GENERAL FUND. AND THIS PACKAGE
WAS THE FIRST TIME IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN USED TOWARDS INCREASING
PROVIDER RATES, AND SO THE TWO
PARTY PLAN BEFORE YOU, UNDER
DISCUSSION TODAY DOES INCLUDE
THOSE MCO DOLLARS, THE MCO
DOLLARS THAT ARE GOING TO
REIMBURSE THE MEDI-CAL RATE, ARE
TO RAISE THE MEDI-CAL RATE SO
THAT WE CAN GET THERE ARE THERE
ARE FUNDS IN THERE, AND I DEFER
TO THE LAO FOR PARTICULARS.
YEAH. MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THE LEGISLATIVE PLAN DOES
PROVIDE THOSE INCREASES FOR THE
RATE FOR RATES, BUT STARTING
LATER THAN ORIGINALLY ENVISIONED
IN 2026. BUT IN THE BUDGET YEAR,
IT'S MOSTLY TO OFFSET THE BUDGET
PROBLEM, ALL RIGHT. SO BETWEEN
NOW AND THEN, WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE PROVIDERS THAT ARE TRYING
TO PROVIDE TO MORE CUSTOMERS
WITHOUT THE MCO TAX. THAT WAS
SPECIFICALLY GIVEN TO US TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES IN THE
HOSPITAL CARE SYSTEM. OKAY.
SENATOR, WE HAVE A WE HAVE A
QUORUM. SO I'D LIKE TO ESTABLISH
GO RIGHT AHEAD BEFORE WE BEFORE
WE LOSE IT. SO AND THEN YOU CAN
PROCEED. LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. SENATORS WIENER PRESENT
NILO HERE. BECKER BLAKE. SPEER
HERE. CORTEZ. DALY HERE. DURAZZO
EGGMAN. GROVE. LAIRD HERE.
MENGIBAR. HERE. NEWMAN PADILLA.
HERE. ROTH. HERE SATO. HERE.
SKINNER. HERE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WAHAB. HERE WILK. WE HAVE A
QUORUM. SENATOR SOTO, YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU. I'M JUST
GOING TO ASK ONE MORE AND THEN
LET OTHER PEOPLE ASK QUESTIONS.
THIS ONE'S KIND OF AN
INTERESTING ONE. WE HAVE THE
OFFICE OF TAX APPEALS AND PART
OF THE $18 BILLION OF TAX HIKES
FOR BUSINESSES, INCLUDES. 1.9
MILLION OR $1.9 BILLION OF. THAT
THERE WAS A JUDGMENT THAT THE
OFFICE OF TAX APPEALS MADE IN
FAVOR OF A COMPANY THAT WAS
CHALLENGING WHAT A PORTION OF
THEIR TAXABLE INCOME AND THE
RULING BY BOTH THIS THIS BODY
AND A SUBSEQUENT APPEAL WAS THAT
THE COMPANY WAS RIGHT. BUT IN
THIS BUDGET, WE'RE JUST
DECLARING THAT THE RULING WAS,
WAS IS THAT WHAT THE ARGUMENTS
WERE THAT THE RULED AGAINST OR,
OR WE'RE NOT REALLY VALID AND
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND JUST USE THE $1.9 BILLION TO
TAKE IT FROM THE COMPANY IS DID
THAT HAPPEN? ARE WE TAKING $1.9
BILLION FROM A FROM A COMPANY
THAT SHOULD NOT BE PAYING THIS
TAX BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO
LISTEN TO THE BOARD THAT WE SET
UP TO DO A SPECIFICALLY THIS JOB
, THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION.
I'LL START AT A HIGH LEVEL, AND
THEN I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE FOR DETAILS. BUT THIS
BILL DOES NOT OVERTURN IN, ANY
PRIOR O-TAY DECISIONS. AND THOSE
CASES ARE FINAL. AND REFUNDS
WERE, ISSUED. WE BELIEVE IT'S
SIMPLY CLARIFYING, THE INTENT OF
EXISTING LAW. SO I'LL PUT THAT
OUT THERE AND I WILL TURN TO MY
COLLEAGUE FOR ANY ADDITIONS,
THANK YOU. COLBY. WHITE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO WITH
REGARD TO YOUR QUESTION, THERE
HAVE BEEN TWO RULINGS THAT OTA
HAS MADE ON THESE CASES, ONE WAS
MINNESOTA SUGARBEET FOR A SMALL
COUPLE MILLION DOLLARS. AND THEN
THERE WAS THE MICROSOFT CASE,
WHICH WAS $91 MILLION IN
REFUNDS. AND THAT REFUND HAS
GONE OUT. SO THERE'S NO, AS MY
COLLEAGUE SAID, THERE'S NO
THERE'S NO OVERTURNING OF THOSE
EXISTING DECISIONS. AS FAR AS
THE PROPOSAL HERE, THAT'S IN
PART OF THE TWO PARTY AGREEMENT
AND WAS ALSO PROPOSED AS PART OF
THE MAY REVISION, THIS IS WE ARE
DECLARATORY OF EXISTING LAW.
THIS HAS BEEN A LONG STANDING
PRINCIPLE, AS TO THAT FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD AS TO HOW THEY HAVE
ADMINISTERED THE TAX. AND THIS
IS WITH REGARD TO HOW HOW
COMPANIES APPORTION THEIR, THEIR
PROFITS TO CALIFORNIA FOR
TAXATION. THIS IS FOR
MULTINATIONAL AND MULTI-STATE
CORPORATIONS. SO, SO THE
QUESTION IN PLAY HERE IS REALLY
HOW DO THEY APPORTION THAT
BUSINESS ACTIVITY AND, AND WHAT
WE'RE PROVIDING HERE OR WHAT THE
TWO PARTY AGREEMENT HAS IS IT'S
A CLARIFICATION OF EXISTING LAW
THAT WHEN YOU, WHEN YOU CREATE
THAT OR CALCULATE THAT
APPORTIONMENT FACTOR THAT YOU
DON'T INCLUDE NON TAXABLE INCOME
IN THE DENOMINATOR HERE. AND
THAT PRINCIPLE IS CONSISTENT
WITH LONG STANDING PRACTICE,
LONG STANDING CONSTITUTIONAL
PRINCIPLES AS FAR AS
ESTABLISHING EQUITABLE TAXATION
FOR MULTI MULTI-STATE AND
MULTINATIONAL CORPORATIONS. BUT
AGAIN THIS THE OTA DECISION IS
FINAL. THERE'S NO THERE'S NO
OVERTURNING THAT DECISION.
FUTURE CASES THAT GO BEFORE THE
OTA THEY CAN TAKE. THEY CAN TAKE
THIS INTO CONSIDERATION IF IT
BECOMES PART OF THE BUDGET. SO
THERE IS NOT $1.9 BILLION AS
PART OF THAT $18 BILLION THAT
WE'RE GETTING FROM ADDITIONAL
TAXES. SO IT'S SO WHAT I THINK
YOU'RE REFERRING TO IS IF IS THE
POTENTIAL IS THE POTENTIAL FOR
REFUNDS TO GO OUT FOR OTHER
COMPANIES THAT WERE POTENTIALLY
IN SIMILAR SITUATIONS THAT HAD
REPATRIATED FOREIGN DIVIDENDS
AND, AND SO THE BUDGET ASSUMES,
AS I'M SORRY, THE TWO PARTY
AGREEMENT ASSUMES THAT THOSE
REFUNDS WILL NOT WILL NOT, WILL
NOT GO OUT. YEAH. OKAY SO MY,
ONE OF MY CONCERNS WITH THE,
WITH OUR, OUR APPROACH, WITH
TAXATION IS AFTER SAYING WE'RE
NOT GOING TO RAISE TAXES, WE
HAVE RAISED TAXES. WE'RE RAISING
TAXES ON BUSINESSES THAT AREN'T
AS VISIBLE. AND, AND, AND THOSE
IN, IN TURN WIND UP. WE PAY MORE
. SO WE ARE GETTING OUR TAXES
RAISED TO THE TUNE OF SOME $18
BILLION TO HELP TAKE CARE OF THE
DEFICIT THAT WE'VE BEEN TOLD IS
45. BUT THEN WE ALSO ARE HEARING
THAT IT COULD BE AS MUCH AS 62,
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 62 AND $70
BILLION. AND AND SO AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT, HEY, WE HAVE TO
GET REVENUE FROM SOMEWHERE, THAT
SOMEWHERE SHOULD BE ON BUILDING
AN ECONOMY THAT SUPPORTS ALL THE
SPENDING THAT PEOPLE WANT TO DO
WITHOUT TAXING THE HECK OUT OF
EVERYBODY. AND WE'RE NOT DOING
THAT VERY WELL. AND SO, YOU
KNOW, THIS BUDGET KIND OF
REFLECTS THAT. AND THE ONE
COMMENT I WOULD PIGGYBACK ON
THE, THE CHAIR'S COMMENT ABOUT
THE RECESSION, THE GREAT
RECESSION, THÀNH, AND HOW THEY
HAVEN'T HAD TO DEAL WITH A
BUDGET LIKE THIS SINCE THEN,
WE'RE NOT IN A GREAT RECESSION.
WE'RE NOT EVEN IN A RECESSION.
AND IF WE'RE DEALING WITH THIS,
THIS A BUDGET LIKE THIS AND IS,
YOU KNOW, I'M, I'M GLAD YOU GUYS
WERE ABLE TO COBBLE SOMETHING
TOGETHER FOR US, BUT THERE'S
SOMETHING DRASTICALLY WRONG WITH
OUR APPROACH TO STATE SPENDING
AND BUDGETING, AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO GET
TOGETHER AS A LEGISLATURE HERE
AND MAYBE LISTEN A LITTLE
HARDER. WHEN OTHER PEOPLE BRING
UP, LIKE, TWO YEARS AGO, THAT
MAYBE WE SHOULDN'T BE SPENDING
ALL THIS AND MAYBE WE SHOULD BE
PAYING OFF OUR, OUR OUR UI DEBT,
OUR UNEMPLOYMENT DEBT. SO WE
DON'T HAVE A HALF $1 BILLION
INTEREST PAYMENT TO MAKE BECAUSE
WE COULD MAKE, WE COULD. THERE'S
A LOT OF THINGS BEING CUT THAT
WE COULD HAVE. WE COULD HAVE
USED THAT MONEY FOR. AND SO WITH
THAT, I WILL TURN IT BACK TO THE
CHAIR AND, AND HAVE OTHERS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO ASK QUESTIONS, MR.
CHAIR, SPECIFICALLY TO, SENATOR
SATO'S POINT, COULD WE HAVE THE
LAOS PERSPECTIVE ON THE
APPORTIONMENT FACTOR PROPOSAL,
SURE. I'M GOING TO TURN TO MY
COLLEAGUE WHO, CAN SPEAK TO THIS
BRIAN MUELLER. YES. THANK YOU,
SENATOR BRIAN. BRIAN MUELLER,
SORRY. EXCUSE ME. YOU'VE GOT MY
HAPPENS TO ME ALL THE TIME,
SORRY. SORRY. I'M JUST A LITTLE
EMOTIONAL. NO, I'M JUST KIDDING.
SENATOR, SO THERE'S A COUPLE OF
SORT OF DISCUSSION POINTS ON
THIS ITEM, RIGHT. ONE IS,
WHETHER OR NOT THIS ACTION
POTENTIALLY BE, IN SOME WAY
JEOPARDIZES THE INDEPENDENCE OF
OR REVERSES THE RULINGS THERE.
AND I THINK, YOU KNOW, THE JOB
OF IS TO ENFORCE THE RULES THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CREATES ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, THE ADMINISTRATION OF
TAXES IN THE STATE AND TO
INTERPRET THE STATUTES AS THEY
EXIST. AND SO WHAT THOSE RULINGS
WERE ABOUT WERE ABOUT THE THEIR
INTERPRETATION OF THE EXISTING
STATUTES, AND IF THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION THANK
YOU, FEEL THAT THAT THAT THAT
INTERPRETATION WAS NOT
CONSISTENT WITH THE POLICY THAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE PUT IN
PLACE. IT'S YOU KNOW, FULLY
WITHIN THE LEGISLATURE'S
PREROGATIVE TO MAKE A CHANGE OR
CLARIFY, THOSE POLICIES GOING
FORWARD. SO THAT'S ON THAT
POINT. I THINK ON THE GENERAL
POLICY QUESTION, I THINK WE ARE
ALSO GENERALLY IN AGREEMENT WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION, THAT THE
PURPOSE OF APPORTIONMENT IS TO,
TO DETERMINE WHAT SHARE OF A
BUSINESS'S SORT OF TAXABLE
ACTIVITIES ARE WITHIN THE ARE
WITHIN THE STATE, AND THEREFORE,
WHAT PORTION OF THEIR PROFITS
SHOULD BE, YOU KNOW, TAXED FOR
CALIFORNIA PURPOSES, AND SO SORT
OF CONSISTENT WITH THAT GENERAL
PRINCIPLE WOULD BE, EXCLUDING
NONTAXABLE SOURCES OF INCOME
FROM THAT APPORTIONMENT
CALCULATION, WHICH IS WHAT THIS
PROPOSAL IS GENERALLY SUGGESTING
TO DO. OKAY. THANK YOU, SO WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF MEMBERS WHO,
HAVE INDICATED THEY WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK, WE'LL START WITH
SENATOR BLAKE SPEER. THANK YOU,
SO I SPOKE ABOUT THIS IN BUDGET
SUB TWO, BUT BECAUSE IT REMAINS
AS AN ISSUE, I WANTED TO RAISE
IT AGAIN TODAY. I REMAIN VERY
CONCERNED THAT AB 107 REVERTS 45
MILLION OF ALREADY APPROPRIATED
GENERAL FUNDS FROM THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND, WHICH VOTERS
PASSED IN 1990. SO THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND IS WHAT
PROTECTS OUR RAPIDLY
DISAPPEARING WILDLIFE HABITAT
OUT. AND WE HAVE 40 CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS THAT RELY ON THIS
MONEY, AND IT IS THE ONLY
CONSISTENT, ONGOING, FLEXIBLE
FUNDING THAT IS SPECIFICALLY FOR
HABITAT CONSERVATION. WE'VE
ALREADY PROTECTED A MILLION
ACRES WITH THIS MONEY, AND AS
SENATOR DONNELLY SAID IN OUR
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE, WHICH I
THOUGHT WAS AN EXCELLENT POINT,
THERE ARE 3 TO 4 TIMES AS MUCH
IN PRIVATE MONEY THAT IS DRAWN
INTO HABITAT CONSERVATION.
BECAUSE OF THIS, PUBLIC MONEY,
THE HABITAT CONSERVATION IS
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR SPECIES
PROTECTION AND ALSO FOR MANY OF
OUR EFFORTS AT THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS TO CLIMATE CHANGE. AND
I THINK THERE'S AN INCREASING
RECOGNITION THAT THAT IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT PART OF
REDUCING OUR CARBON EMISSIONS
AND SUCKING CARBON THAT ALREADY
EXISTS OUT OF OUR ATMOSPHERE. SO
I STRONGLY URGE US TO FIX THIS
IN THE BUDGET THAT WILL BE
ADOPTED AT THE END OF JUNE. IF
THERE IS A NEED FOR A REFERENCE
TO THE SECTION, IT IS 3.640498.
THAT'S WHERE YOU CAN FIND THE
SPECIFIC PART. BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT IN 1990,
WHEN THE VOTERS PASSED THIS,
PROP 117 EXPLICITLY PROHIBITED
REAPPROPRIATING ALREADY
APPROPRIATED FUNDS AND SO I DO
EXPECT AND IT HAS BEEN
SUGGESTED, THAT THIS WILL LEAD
TO LITIGATION, WHICH THE STATE
COULD AVOID. AND BY NOT MAKING
THIS MOVE IN OUR BUDGET. SO
THANK YOU, CHAIR, FOR GIVING ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR, NEXT WE
HAVE SENATOR PADILLA. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIRMAN. PRIMARILY I HAVE
COMMENTS, SO I'LL RESERVE UNTIL
POST PUBLIC TESTIMONY. OKAY.
THANK YOU. NEXT, WE HAVE SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
APPRECIATE IT. AND APPRECIATE,
OUR LÀ COMMENTS, AS ALWAYS. AND,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, YOUR
COMMENTS ADDITIONALLY, I JUST
WANTED TO SPEAK TO SOME OF THE
PARTICULARS IN THIS BUDGET,
BEING VERY COGNIZANT THAT WE ARE
IN A REAL DEFICIT, SO WE ARE NOT
IN THE LUXURY THAT I WAS VERY
FORTUNATE TO BE ABLE TO BE
BUDGET CHAIR DURING WHEN WE WERE
NOT FACING, SUCH, DEFICIT S. SO
WE NEED TO BE VERY WISE IN, IN
HOW WE CONSTRUCT THE BUDGET. AND
I KNOW THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
WAS AND WHAT THEY PUT FORWARD
AND CLEARLY THE I FEEL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S RESPONSE IS, AND
THERE AND THAT IS THE NATURAL,
IT IS THE GOVERNOR, OF COURSE,
HAS THE 100% RIGHT AS, AS IS
MANDATED IN THE CONSTITUTION TO
PRESENT US A BUDGET IN JANUARY
AND THEN TO IN THE MAY REVISE,
MAKE THOSE ADJUSTMENTS AND
PRESENT IT TO US JUST AS WE HAVE
THE LEGITIMATE ROLE TO THEN,
MAKE AS WE ARE DOING TODAY OUR
RECOMMENDED ADJUSTMENTS TO THAT
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US. AND I WANTED TO SPEAK
TO A COUPLE OF THEM, SO FIRST
AND FOREMOST, THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WAS BUDGET THAT WE
ARE GOING TO BE ASKED TO VOTE ON
TODAY AND THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US
THAT THIS HEARING IS ABOUT IS,
BALANCED. SO THAT IS OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION. IT
DOES NOT, MAKE THE DEFICIT
WORSE. IT ADDRESSES THE DEFICIT
AND IT DOES IT IN A VARIETY OF
CREATIVE WAYS. NOW, OF COURSE,
THE ADMINISTRATION ALSO DID, BUT
THERE WERE CLEARLY A FEW THINGS
THAT AND I WILL SPEAK TO THOSE,
THE ONES I PARTICULARLY, NOT
NECESSARILY CARE ABOUT, BUT JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT I THINK
IS OUR SMART WAYS THAT WE ARE
RESPONDING TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. AND I REALLY WANT TO
THANK OUR CHAIR AND OUR
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS AND ALL THE
HEARINGS FOR, YOU KNOW, COMING
UP WITH THESE THINGS. SO A
COUPLE OF THEM, OUR EDUCATION
CHAIR ALREADY SPOKE TO, I'M
VERY, VERY PLEASED THAT WE IN
THIS BUDGET, WE INCLUDE THE
INCREASES, THEY'RE VERY THEY'RE
MODEST THAT WE HAD PROMISED TO
BOTH èC AND CSU BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT THEY'RE THEIR ACTIONS. YOU
KNOW, THEY THEY TAKE MULTI
RANGE, BUDGETARY ACTIONS JUST AS
WE DO. AND TO, TO PULL BACK ON
THOSE COMMITMENTS THAT WE MADE
WOULD PUT THEM IN A DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCE AND PUT OUR
STUDENTS IN A DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCE. SO I WANTED TO
JUST HIGHLIGHT THAT, IN THE,
ENERGY AND THE UTILITIES AND AIR
QUALITY SECTION OF OUR BUDGET,
WE ARE PROVIDING THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD PULLED BACK
ON SOME OF THE FUNDS FOR DEMAND
SIDE GRID SUPPORT, AND I THINK
WE'RE ALL SUFFERING FROM, MAYBE
WE SOMETIMES HAVE OVER 100
DEGREES IN JUNE, BUT I THINK
MOST OF US REALLY DON'T EXPECT
THE OVER 100 DEGREES TILL JULY
OR AUGUST. AND YET HERE WE HAVE
THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS OVER 100
DEGREES HERE IN SACRAMENTO. AND
WE KNOW THAT THAT INCREASES THE
DEMAND ON OUR ELECTRICAL GRID.
PEOPLE NEED TO USE THEIR AIR
CONDITIONING AND THAT WE ARE WE
ARE TRYING TO NOT TRYING. WE
HAVE A COMMITMENT TO ELECTRIFY
THIS STATE. SO HOW DO WE DO IT?
HOW DO WE DO IT SMARTLY? HOW DO
WE DO IT? MOST COST EFFECTIVELY?
PART OF THAT IS WHAT WE CALL
DEMAND SIDE GRID SUPPORT. SO I
WAS REALLY HAPPY TO SEE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE BUDGET INCLUDES
FUNDING FOR THAT, BECAUSE IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT. WE NEGAWATTS
ARE THE MOST EFFECTIVE FORM OF,
DELIVERY OF ELECTRICITY. THE
LESS WE USE THEN THE LESS IT
COSTS US, AND THE LESS THAN
DEMAND ON THE GRID. AND WE CAN
ACHIEVE NEGAWATTS. AND THAT'S
WHAT DEMAND SIDE IS THROUGH VERY
EFFECTIVE WAYS. AND OUR STATE
HAS PROVEN THAT AGAIN AND AGAIN.
SO I WOULD REALLY WAS
APPRECIATIVE THAT THAT FUNDING
IS REMAINS IN THERE, THE OTHER
ANOTHER SECTION I WANTED TO KIND
OF HIGHLIGHT. THERE'S A LOT TO
SAY IN THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES SIDE. AND OF COURSE,
I'M SURE OTHER OF MY COLLEAGUES
WILL TALK ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
ASPECTS, MEDI-CAL ASPECTS,
VARIOUS THINGS LIKE THAT. BUT I
WANTED TO BRING UP PARTICULARLY
THE INVESTMENTS IN SONG BROWN
AND SONG BROWN. FOR THOSE WHO
MAY NOT BE FAMILIAR, THAT IS THE
FUNDING THAT THE STATE PROVIDES.
IT SUPPORTS RESIDENCY. SO IF YOU
ARE A MED STUDENT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, IF YOU DON'T GET A
RESIDENCY IN CALIFORNIA AND YOU
GO OUT OF STATE, YOU PROBABLY
DON'T COME BACK TO OUR STATE.
AND WE HAVE A PHYSICIAN
SHORTAGE. SO SONG BROWN FUNDING
THAT. AND WE NOW ALSO HAVE A
SONG BROWN NURSING PROGRAM. SO
IN OTHER WORDS, THE SUPPORTING
FOR NURSES WHO'VE GONE TO SCHOOL
HERE TO STAY HERE. AND THOSE ARE
REALLY EFFECTIVE INVESTMENTS
THAT HELP US DEAL WITH OUR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER SHORTAGES
IN A VERY EFFECTIVE WAY. SO I
WANTED TO, IT'S SMALL AMOUNT IN
THE BUDGET, BUT I JUST WANTED TO
GIVE KUDOS FOR THE LEGISLATURE,
INCLUDING IT, AND THEN OF
COURSE, CHAIR, I AM CHAIR OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS. WE HAVE MADE THE
INVESTMENTS IN CHILD CARE OUR
PRIORITY FOR OVER A DECADE. AND
I WAS HAPPY TO SEE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET INCLUDES
THAT COMMITMENT TO THE SLOTS.
SLOTS BEING YOU KNOW, PEOPLE ARE
LIKE, WHAT ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT? SLOTS? AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THERE IS
THAT WE IN WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
DO AS A STATE WITH CHILD CARE IS
MAKE IT ACCESSIBLE AND
AFFORDABLE. AND WE DO THAT BY A
COUPLE OF WAYS. NUMBER ONE, BY
ADDRESSING THE WORKFORCE, IF YOU
DON'T PAY THE WORKFORCE WELL
ENOUGH, THEN YOU DON'T HAVE
CHILD CARE WORKERS, WHICH MEANS
THEN YOU DON'T HAVE CHILD CARE.
AND THEN FOR THE FAMILIES WHO
NEED IT, FOR THOSE WHO REALLY
CAN'T AFFORD IT. AND YOU KNOW,
IF YOU TRIED TO MAKE CHILD CARE
FREE UNLESS YOU COMPLETELY
SUBSIDIZED IT, YOU WOULDN'T HAVE
ANY MONEY TO PAY THE WORKERS. SO
WHAT WE DO IS WE TRY TO CREATE
THAT HAPPY BALANCE WHERE THERE'S
THERE ARE LEGITIMATE RATES FOR
CHILD CARE. BUT THOSE FAMILIES
THAT CAN'T AFFORD IT, WE
SUBSIDIZE THEM. AND THOSE ARE
WHAT IS CALLED THE SLOTS. SO WE
HAD MADE A BIG COMMITMENT LAST
YEAR FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS TO REALLY INCREASE THOSE.
AND, LEGITIMATELY, THE
ADMINISTRATION AND TRYING TO
LOOK AT WHERE, HOW TO DEAL WITH
THIS DEFICIT PULLED BACK ON SOME
. BUT THE, THE LEGISLATURE KIND
OF, YOU KNOW, DID A LITTLE, THIS
BUDGET, DOESN'T QUITE COMMIT TO
ALL THE SLOTS THAT WE HAD HOPED
TO, BUT DOES A LITTLE BETTER
THAN WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
BUDGET, DID. AND THEN ANOTHER
AREA THAT I'VE BEEN, FOLLOWING
FOR A LONG TIME, I WAS A BUDGET
CHAIR IN THE ASSEMBLY. ALSO, IS
THE ISSUE OF THE RATES PAID TO
OUR PROVIDERS FOR THE SERVICES,
FOR OUR DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
. AND NOW, AS WE KNOW, MUCH OF
THIS BUDGET IS PROVIDING SUPPORT
TO THOSE WHO ARE IN THE IN THE
LEAST ABILITY TO REALLY SUPPORT
THEMSELVES, WHETHER THAT'S OUR
BABIES, WHETHER THAT'S OUR
SENIORS, WHETHER THAT'S OUR,
VERY, VERY LOW INCOME PEOPLE.
BUT IF WE TAKE OUR, OUR
POPULATION OF DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED FOLKS, CHILDREN AND
ADULTS, THEY NEED CARE AND FOR
THEM TO GET THAT CARE, WE NEED
TO PAY THE PEOPLE WHO PROVIDE
THEM THAT CARE A DECENT WAGE.
AND BACK IN THE FIRST THE
HORRIBLE RECESSION, IT IS ONE OF
THE PLACES THAT IN ORDER TO GET
A BALANCED BUDGET, WE WHACKED
REALLY HARD. IN OTHER WORDS, THE
STATE WAY CUT BACK ON THAT AND
WE HAVE NOT REALLY ADJUSTED IT
BACK. IF WE JUST TAKE INFLATION
AND THE NUMBER OF YEARS SINCE
THAT TIME AND WE'VE YES, WE'VE
MADE ADJUSTMENTS NOT LIKE WE'VE
IGNORED IT. BUT IF WE COMPARE,
EXCUSE ME, IF WE COMPARE IT TO
THE OTHER THINGS THAT WE HAD TO
CUT BACK IN THAT RECESSION AND
WHAT WE'VE, YOU KNOW, IN EFFECT
DONE MUCH BETTER BY THE RATES
FOR DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED,
STILL NOT GOTTEN THE TYPE OF
PRIORITY. AND SO I WAS REALLY
APPRECIATIVE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET DOES NOT
DELAY THE RATE ADJUSTMENTS FOR
OUR DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
SERVICE PROVIDERS, AND THEN, I
WAS ALSO VERY, VERY APPRECIATIVE
THAT OUR LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
INCLUDES A SIXTH ROUND OF
FUNDING FOR THE HOMELESS HOUSING
ASSISTANCE AND PREVENTION, AND
OF COURSE, EVEN WITH THE EFFORTS
WE'VE MADE. AND THEY ARE THEY
ARE SIGNIFICANT AND THEY HAVE
PREVENTED A, A GOOD DEAL OF
PEOPLE FROM BECOMING HOMELESS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, WE STILL ARE
SEEING THE NUMBERS THAT WE ARE
INCREASING AND WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE AN INCREASE IN THE NUMBERS
OF HOMELESS. WE WOULD HAVE FAR
MORE IF THE STATE HAD NOT MADE
THE INVESTMENTS IN THINGS LIKE,
PROJECT HOME KEY AND OTHERS OF
THESE PROJECTS THAT THE GOVERNOR
INITIATED, WE WOULD HAVE FAR
MORE HOMELESS. BUT WE NEED TO
STEM THE TIDE OF THAT INCREASE.
AND THOSE HAP FUNDS WILL HELP US
DO IT. AND CLEARLY STRENGTHENING
THE OVERSIGHT, WHICH THE BUDGET
ALSO DOES, WILL HELP US THERE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE MONEY IS USED
EFFECTIVELY. AND THEN I WOULD
IMAGINE AND MAYBE MY CHAIR
ALREADY SPOKE TO THIS, THE PARTS
AROUND THE TRANSIT FUNDING,
WHICH, YOU KNOW, TRANSIT REALLY
SUFFERED DURING THE PANDEMIC. IT
HAS NOT FULLY COME BACK. BUT I
THINK ALL OF US, WE HEY, WE
TRUST THAT IT WILL SURE. THE WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE LONG WE HAVE
TO TAKE THE LONG VIEW. WE CANNOT
ALLOW TRANSIT FUNDING TO BE
COMPROMISED, EVEN THOUGH WE
DON'T HAVE THE RIDERSHIP TODAY,
BECAUSE THEN WE ARE DOING A
SELF-FULFILLING NEGATIVE
PROPHECY. AND WE ARE HURTING THE
RIDERSHIP GROWTH. SO WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE THE INVESTMENT AND THE
RIDERS, YOU KNOW, OVER TIME THEY
WILL COME. SO I WAS VERY, VERY
HAPPY TO SEE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET, ADDRESSED
THAT. AND I KNOW THAT I, I KNOW
THAT IT WAS MANY PEOPLE THAT I
CAN REALLY THANK OUR CHAIR FOR
THAT ONE, AND THEN, FINALLY ON
THE, ON OUR CDC, OUR THAT'S OUR
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS. YOU KNOW, MOST OF
OUR, THE BUDGET WE'RE GOING TO
ADOPT TODAY IS NOT DISCRETIONARY
FUNDING. SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
A LOT OF THINGS. BUT MUCH OF
THIS, IS STUFF THAT WE, WE
PRETTY MUCH HAVE TO DO. OKAY. SO
THERE'S ONLY SO MANY AREAS THAT
ARE DISCRETIONARY AND ARE
CORRECTIONS. BUDGET IS ONE OF
THOSE. NOW, IT IS VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT. ABSOLUTELY. PUBLIC
SAFETY MUST COME FIRST. BUT WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE REDUCTION IN THE
NUMBER OF INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS IN OUR STATE
FACILITIES, AND YET WE LOOK AT
THE DOLLAR AMOUNT WE ARE
BUDGETING FOR CDCR, YOU KNOW,
ONE COULD SAY, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
A BIT OF A DISCONNECT THERE.
WE'VE CUT THE PRISON POPULATION
IN MORE THAN HALF IN A COURSE OF
ABOUT MAYBE EIGHT YEARS, MAYBE
TEN YEARS. AND YET THE AMOUNT
THAT THE CORRECTIONS DEPARTMENT
HAS IS MUCH HIGHER, NOW, THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE JUST WILLY
NILLY AND, YOU KNOW, ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY TRIED TO
COMMENT LIKE THAT. WE'RE SOMEHOW
NOW TRYING TO, UNNECESSARILY CUT
CORRECTIONS. BUT I THINK WHAT WE
ARE TRYING TO BE IS SMART ABOUT
IT. SO IF WE HAVE YARDS OPEN,
FOR EXAMPLE, IN OUR PRISON
FACILITIES, IF WE STAFF THOSE
YARDS AND THERE'S TWO PEOPLE
PERHAPS IN THAT YARD, THAT'S NOT
A VERY COST EFFECTIVE
EXPENDITURE OF YOUR FUNDS. WE
ARE BETTER TO CONSOLIDATE YARDS
AND STAFF FULLY HAVE YARDS FULL
AND THEN STAFF THOSE YARDS. SO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE WAYS THAT
WE CAN ACHIEVE ACHIEVE SOME OF
THE REDUCTIONS THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO ACHIEVE IN THE CORRECTIONS
BUDGET AND STILL PUT PUBLIC
SAFETY FIRST ANOTHER WAY. AND
THE LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET HAS,
THIS IS THAT WE HAVE A REALLY
EXCELLENT PROGRAM THAT IS PART
OF THE CORRECTIONS DEPARTMENT
THAT HAS GOT A FUNNY ACRONYM,
MACP. AND IT IS A PROGRAM WHERE
FOLKS WHO ARE CLOSE TO THE TIME
OF THEIR RELEASE WOULD BE PUT IN
A COMMUNITY FACILITY. THEY ARE
STILL UNDER THE CUSTODIAL. THEY
ARE STILL WITHIN THE, WHAT'S THE
WORD, THEY'RE STILL RESIDENTS OF
CDCR, IN EFFECT, BUT THEY ARE IN
THESE COMMUNITY FACILITIES WHERE
THEY ARE ABLE TO GET FAR MORE
TRAINING AND SUPPORTS THAT WILL
ALLOW THEM TO BE SUCCESSFUL AT
HOME AND WHAT OUR OUR BUDGET
TODAY DOES IS, IS ENHANCE SOME
OF THOSE SO THAT WE PROVIDE THE
SUPPORTS, FOR EXAMPLE, MEDICAL
AND OTHER SUPPORTS THAT CAN
CONTINUE AFTER THE PERSON DOES
GO HOME SO THAT THERE ARE THINGS
LIKE THEIR SOBRIETY, IF THEY
WERE ADDICTED AND WE KNOW A GOOD
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN OUR PRISON
FACILITIES HAVE SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER, THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE
THEIR MEDICAL SUPPORTS AND
HOPEFULLY STAY, YOU KNOW, WITHIN
THEIR SOBRIETY, WHICH WILL ALLOW
THEM TO BE SUCCESSFUL AT HOME.
SO THERE ARE SOME INVESTMENTS
HERE THAT I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE HAS MADE THAT ARE
VERY WISE, BUT ALSO GET US SOME
OF THE SAVINGS THAT WE NEED. AND
SO I JUST WANTED TO POINT THOSE
OUT, AND I'M VERY APPRECIATIVE
OF THE WORK THAT THE BUDGET
STAFF AND THE BUDGET MEMBERS AND
OF COURSE, EVERYONE HAS DONE ON
THIS. AND THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR,
FOR ALLOWING ME TO MAKE THOSE
COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
SENATOR, NEXT IS SENATOR
MENGIBAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH. I
MR. CHAIR, I'D LIKE TO LEAVE MY
COMMENTS TOWARDS THE END. IF WE
COULD DO A SECOND ROUND, I WANT
TO SAY THAT I JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION, ACTUALLY, TO WHAT?
SENATOR. SENATOR SATO HAD
BROUGHT UP. SO I DON'T KNOW IF
THE GENTLEMAN WOULD LIKE TO COME
BACK UP ON AB 167, SECTION 41.
AND MAYBE BOTH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND LAO CAN ANSWER THIS.
I JUST WANT TO GET BECAUSE I'M
GETTING A LITTLE PUSHBACK FROM
MY, MY, MY DISTRICT, SO THIS IS
WHERE THE PERSONAL INQUIRY IS
COMING FROM. JUST IF WE CAN
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT TO THE IMPACT
THAT THIS COULD HAVE ON
EMPLOYERS THAT ACTUALLY,
PHYSICALLY ARE IN CALIFORNIA
VERSUS VERSUS THOSE THAT HAVE
NO, WORKFORCE OR FACILITY IN THE
STATE. IS THERE GOING TO BE A
DIFFERENCE IF SOMEONE CAN
EXPLAIN THAT TO ME? COLBY WHITE,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, YOU
REFERENCED SECTION 41. IS THAT
RELATED TO THE APPORTIONMENT?
YES, PLEASE. OKAY SO FOR
COMPANIES THAT ARE LOCATED IN
CALIFORNIA THAT DON'T DO
BUSINESS OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA,
THERE WOULD BE NO IMPACT AT ALL
BECAUSE, STATES THAT ARE LOCATED
IN CALIFORNIA ARE TAXED WITHIN
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL THEIR
ACTIVITIES WITHIN CALIFORNIA. SO
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE IS
APPORTIONMENT FACTORS FOR
MULTI-STATE AND MULTINATIONAL
CORPORATIONS. WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE LOCATED IN CALIFORNIA
GENERALLY DOESN'T AFFECT HOW,
HOW THEIR PROFITS ARE
APPORTIONED TO CALIFORNIA FOR
TAXATION. AND THAT'S BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA, VOTERS PASSED
PROPOSITION 39 IN 2013. AND THE
WAY PROFITS ARE GENERALLY
APPORTIONED TO CALIFORNIA IS BY
SALES, SO IT HAS TO DO WITH A
COMPANY'S SALES IN CALIFORNIA
VERSUS THEIR SALES IN THE US. IF
THEY'RE ELECTING TO PAY ON A, ON
A WATER'S EDGE BASIS. SO, SO
THEY SEE AN INCREASE THEN, SO
THEY WOULDN'T SEE AN INCREASE IF
THEY'RE PHYSICALLY IN, NO. OKAY.
NO AND THE ISSUE AT HAND THAT
DECIDED ON WAS FOR MULTINATIONAL
CORPORATIONS THAT ARE BRINGING
FOREIGN DIVIDENDS BACK FROM,
FROM OTHER JURISDICTIONS IS,
BACK TO THEIR BACK TO THEIR MAIN
SUBSIDIARY. OKAY IS THERE
ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO ADD TO
THAT? ELIO NO, I DON'T I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD TO
THAT EXPLANATION. OKAY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. SENATOR
NOW GO TO SENATOR BARRASSO.
THANK YOU. I JUST WANT TO MAKE,
SHORT COMMENTS ON ON SEVERAL
ISSUES. ONE IS I AM GRATEFUL TO
THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY FOR
INCLUDING FUNDING, TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
HEALTH CARE MINIMUM WAGE. THE
WHEN IT WAS THE LAW WAS PASSED
LAST YEAR, WAS MEANT TO ADDRESS
THE HEALTH CARE SHORTAGE,
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE. THAT WAS THE
POINT OF IT. AND, IN ORDER TO DO
THAT, WE HAD TO RAISE WAGES FOR
ALMOST 500,000 WORKERS.
REMEMBER, 75% OF THESE PEOPLE
ARE WOMEN. AND PEOPLE OF COLOR,
AND I WANT TO THANK ALREADY
SEVERAL EMPLOYERS WHO HAVE
ALREADY RECOGNIZED THE VALUE OF
THE WORKFORCE AND THEY
IMPLEMENTED, WENT AHEAD AND
IMPLEMENTED THE WAGE INCREASE,
FOR CALIFORNIA'S COUNTING ON
THIS INCREASE, THEY TELL ME HOW
IT IS GIVING THEM HOPE THAT THEY
ARE NOT FORGOTTEN. SINCE WE GOT
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC, AND THAT
WHEN WE CALL THEM HEROES, WE
ACTUALLY MEAN IT. SO I WANT TO I
DON'T KNOW THAT THERE
NECESSARILY HAS TO BE A COMMENT
BACK, BUT I WANT TO MAKE THAT
POINT VERY CLEAR. SECOND IS ON
JOB QUALITY AND EQUITY, FOR THE
WORKFORCE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT, ITEMS THAT ARE IN
THIS BUDGET, WE NEED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT ADDRESSES JOB
QUALITY AND EQUITY. THIS WAS OUR
COMMITMENT WITH SB 150 SIGNED
LAST YEAR AS PART OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE, DESPITE
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S VERY
CLEAR GUIDANCE THAT THE FEDERAL
DOLLARS THAT WE ARE RECEIVING
ARE MEANT TO IMPACT JOBS, THE
ECONOMY AND POVERTY. AND DESPITE
THAT, MANY OF OUR PROGRAMS AND
INVESTMENTS ARE MISSING, THESE
STILL MISSING THESE ELEMENTS. SO
AGAIN, WE NEED JOB QUALITY
METRICS. AND WE NEED METRICS FOR
ECONOMIC EQUITY. MEANING
EVERYBODY WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY, AT GETTING A GOOD
JOB, THERE MUST ALSO BE A
MECHANISM FOR MONITORING AND
ENFORCING THESE STANDARDS, WE'VE
HAD MANY MEETINGS WITH SB 150
STAKEHOLDERS, MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD THEMSELVES HAVE PROVIDED
RECOMMENDATIONS ALONG THOSE
LINES, AND LAST YEAR I PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR THIS.
SO AS WE CONTINUE TO FACE THE
HIGHEST SUPPLEMENTAL POVERTY
RATE IN THE COUNTRY, IN THE
COUNTRY, I HAVE THAT LANGUAGE ON
HAND, AND, TO FINALLY IMPLEMENT,
PROVEN STANDARDS BEFORE IT'S TOO
LATE, WE FIND OURSELVES
INVESTING ON THE AFTER END OF
OUR CALIFORNIANS HELPING THEM
AFTER, THEY FACE THE POVERTY
AFTER THEY CAN'T PAY THE RENT
AFTERWARDS. THIS IS ABOUT
ADDRESSING THOSE ISSUES BEFORE
THEY FACE POVERTY, BEFORE THEY
FACE THE FACT THAT THEY CAN'T
PAY THE RENT AND PUT FOOD ON
THEIR TABLE, THE NEXT ISSUE IS
ABOUT BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT FOR
OUR FLEETS, CALIFORNIA'S
INVESTMENTS WITH OUR PUBLIC
DOLLARS SHOULD BE USED TO CREATE
THE MOST PUBLIC GOOD, NOT TO
REWARD BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
SHOWN TO VIOLATE LABOR
STANDARDS. WITH CONTRACTS PAID
BY OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS IN SUB
FIVE, WE ADOPTED REPORTING
LANGUAGE FOR THE FLEET
REPLACEMENT, BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL. WE NEED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT REQUIRES A BEST
VALUE PROCUREMENT FRAMEWORK FOR
FLEET PURCHASES, THIS METHOD HAS
BEEN USED ACROSS THE STATE ON
LARGE SCALE PROCUREMENTS FOR
MANY YEARS. AND IT WORKS, IN THE
COMING YEARS, WE CAN EXPECT
CITIES, COUNTIES, STATE
AGENCIES, OTHER PUBLIC ENTITIES
TO BE PROCURE ELECTRIC VEHICLES
IN BULK AS THEY ELECTRIFY THEIR
FLEETS. OUR CURRENT STATE AND
LOCAL POLICIES ARE NOT ENOUGH TO
ENSURE THAT THESE NEW FLEET
VEHICLES ARE MADE BY WORKERS WHO
RECEIVE FAIR WAGES AND BENEFITS.
WE'VE SEEN THAT MANY EVS ARE
MADE BY COMPANIES THAT VIOLATES
THE STANCE, THE VALUES THAT WE
STAND FOR HERE IN CALIFORNIA,
THE BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT IS
IMPORTANT FOR JOB CREATION, PAY
AND BENEFITS PRICE,
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES, QUALITY
PRODUCTS. ET CETERA. ET CETERA.
AND HAS BEEN USED TO INCENTIVIZE
LOCAL AND TARGETED HIRE, WITH
MAJOR FLEET PROCUREMENTS
HAPPENING NOW ACROSS THE STATE.
IT IS SO IMPORTANT THAT WE DO
NOT LET COMPANIES THAT IGNORE
CALIFORNIA'S VALUES RECEIVE
CALIFORNIA MONEY. WITH THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, SENATOR.
COLLEAGUES, ANY ADDITIONAL
SENATOR WAHAB? SENATOR. YEAH.
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR DAWLEY
SITTING AMONGST. SORRY IF I
MISSED YOU BEFORE, SENATOR. DO
YOU WANT TO SPEAK FIRST? NO. OF
COURSE. YOU GOT A BIG, LONG LIST
. OKAY, WELL, YOU KNOW, YOU'VE
BEEN OVER HERE DOING HER
HOMEWORK. YOU KNOW, SHE'S VERY,
VERY SENATOR IS VERY ORGANIZED,
SO. WELL, I APPRECIATE IT. I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK SOME QUESTIONS
REGARDING CDCR, AND, YOU KNOW,
AS CHAIR OF BUDGET SUB FIVE, I
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE
OF THINGS. SO I'LL ALLOW FOLKS
TO MAKE THEIR WAY.
SO I DO JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
AGAIN, AS WAS ECHOED ON THE
COMMITTEE HERE, GENUINELY THANK
ALL OF THE STAFF THAT HAS BEEN
WORKING, ON THE BUDGET. I KNOW
IT'S A LONG PROCESS AND
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE FACING A
DEFICIT, IT'S NOT AS FUN BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT FUNDING
MORE PROGRAMS AND PROJECTS AND
SO FORTH. BUT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT CUTS. AND THESE ARE DEEPLY
EFFECTIVE, AFFECTING PEOPLE'S
LIVES, BOTH IN A POSITIVE OR A
NEGATIVE WAY. SO I DO JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT. I ALSO WANT
TO JUST HIGHLIGHT BUDGET SUB
FIVE THIS PARTICULAR YEAR. I
WILL SAY HAS BEEN VERY MUCH
FOCUSED ON CUTTING BLOAT. NUMBER
ONE AND NUMBER TWO, REDONE
SERVICES, SERVICES THAT WHEN WE
HEAR THE TESTIMONY LARGELY WE
HEAR IT AND HAVE FAR MORE
QUESTIONS, SO I DO JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THINGS. DO
WE HAVE A POPULATION ESTIMATE IN
OUR DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS?
KIMBERLY HARBISON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS APPROXIMATELY 90,000.
BUT IF YOU GIVE ME A MOMENT, I
CAN LOOK IT UP. OKAY. IT'S FINE.
ROUGHLY 90,000 IS SOLID, AND I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT HOW MANY
PRISONS DO WE HAVE ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA? 30
CURRENTLY HAVE 32. OKAY. AND WE
ARE LOOKING TO REDUCE A NUMBER
OF BEDS. CORRECT? CORRECT AND
THE TREND PRIOR TO COVID, AS
WELL AS NOW HAS BEEN A, DECLINE
IN THE POPULATION IN PRISONS,
CORRECT? THAT IS CORRECT. OKAY.
AND MANY PEOPLE SAY THAT, YOU
KNOW, THE ARGUMENT IS THAT WE'RE
LETTING FOLKS OUT, BUT THAT IS
ALSO NOT NECESSARILY THE CASE
CONSIDERING THE REALIGNMENT
WHERE WE ARE HOUSING INDIVIDUALS
AT THEIR LOCAL COUNTIES IN
JAILS. CORRECT TRUE. OKAY. AND
TYPICALLY YOU KNOW, I WILL SAY
WHEN PEOPLE SAY BEHIND BARS, YOU
KNOW, MOST PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN COUNTY AND PRISON,
RIGHT? SO COUNTY JAILS VERSUS
PRISON. AND OFTENTIMES TIMES
HISTORICALLY, IF YOU WERE TO GO
TO PRISON, IT WAS BECAUSE YOU
WERE, 100% COMMITTED THE CRIME
AND YOU TRIED AND YOU YOU WERE
CONVICTED, CORRECT? YES. OKAY.
AND NOW CONVICTED INDIVIDUALS
CAN STAY IN COUNTY JAILS IN SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES. YES, YES. OKAY
AND I HIGHLIGHT THIS BECAUSE,
THERE'S A LOT OF TALK ABOUT PROP
47, A LOT OF TALK ABOUT THE
FUNDING CUTS AND MUCH MORE, AND
I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT ROUGHLY
HOW MUCH IS THE SPENDING FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR ROUGHLY
CDCR THIS YEAR AND THIS PAST
YEAR, AT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET,
IT WAS PROJECTED TO BE 14.1
BILLION. OKAY. SO ROUGHLY 14 AND
THEN SORRY, EXCUSE ME. AND IT
MAY REVISION IT WAS 13.9 BILLION
OKAY. SO ROUGHLY 14. AND I'VE
SEEN EVEN 14.5. IT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER TODAY, 14.5. SO ALMOST
ABOUT 15 BILLION DEPENDING ON
WHO YOU ASK. RIGHT AND SO $15
BILLION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET IS SERVING
ROUGHLY. I'M EVEN ROUND UP
100,000 INDIVIDUALS. RIGHT. AND
YET WE HAVE OF 27.3% OF THE
POPULATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA UNDER THE AGE OF 18,
AT ROUGHLY ABOUT 10 TO 11
MILLION PEOPLE, RIGHT. AND WE
HAVE IN REGARDS TO, THE PEOPLE
OVER THE AGE OF 65, IN
CALIFORNIA IS ROUGHLY ABOUT
10.7, WHICH EQUATES TO ABOUT 4.2
MILLION PEOPLE, RIGHT. THE
SERVICES THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
PRIORITIZE IN THE LEGISLATURE,
AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S VERY CLEAR, IS TO
ENSURE THAT WE PROTECT THOSE
SERVICES FOR THE MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE. AND THIS BUDGET IN
PARTICULAR, DOES THAT, IN BUDGET
SUB FIVE, I DO JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THINGS, WE
ARE NOT TOUCHING THE 2011
FUNDING STRUCTURE ON
REALIGNMENT. SO THERE'S NO
SIGNIFICANT CUTS IN THE STATE
SPENDING FOR, THE BOARD OF STATE
AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS. NO
SIGNIFICANT CUTS. CORRECT. WHICH
IS WHERE WE'RE SEEING MORE AND
MORE PEOPLE HOUSED AT THE LOCAL
COUNTY JAILS. RIGHT. SO THERE'S
GOING TO BE EXTENSIVE. OKAY I DO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT WE ARE ALSO AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE, TRYING TO
PROTECT THE JUDICIAL BRANCH. SO
FOR EXAMPLE, THIS BUDGET IS
PROTECTING TRIBAL COURTS,
INTERPRETERS, FAMILY LAW. AND
WE'RE EVEN BUILDING AND YOU
KNOW, THE NEW CRIMINAL
COURTHOUSE IN SANTA ROSA,
CORRECT. CAN YOU. PUBLICLY
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT DREW SODERBERG,
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE,
THAT'S CORRECT, DEFINITELY. AND
THEN FOR THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES, YOU KNOW, WE ARE
PRIORITIZING SEISMIC RETROFIT
KITS BECAUSE OF NATURAL
DISASTERS AND MUCH MORE. WE'RE
ALSO PROTECTING SURVIVORS OF
CRIME AND VICTIMS OF CRIME ACT,
THE FEDERAL FUNDING THAT WAS
REMOVED. CORRECT? THAT IS
CORRECT. OKAY. AND WE ARE ALSO
INVESTING IN CYBERSECURITY,
WHICH WE'RE SEEING A GROWING
CONCERN FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
THAT'S CORRECT. OKAY AND FOR THE
MOST PART, WE HAVE TRIED TO
PROTECT AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND MUCH
MORE. RIGHT? CORRECT. OKAY. AND
THEN FOR CDCR, FOR, YOU KNOW, WE
ARE TRYING TO TRIM AWAY AROUND
THE BLOATED FUNDS AND
DUPLICATIVE SERVICES THAT WE
HAVE SEEN, I WILL SAY AGAIN, I
THINK THAT IT WAS STATED IN, IN,
COMMITTEE HEARING IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT THERE'S
ROUGHLY 12, CONTRACTORS FOR
DIFFERENT SERVICES AND 700
SUBCONTRACTORS WITH A LITTLE BIT
OF A LACK OF OVERSIGHT, IN MY
PERSONAL OPINION. AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
DEFINITELY TARGET. MOVING
FORWARD. BUT WE ARE PROTECTING
JOBS FOR THE OFFICERS IN A LOT
OF THESE FACILITIES. CORRECT
THAT IS CORRECT. THERE ARE SOME,
POSITION REDUCTIONS, BUT THAT'S
CORRECT. OKAY AND THEN AS FAR AS
PROTECTING REHABILITATION AND
REENTRY PROGRAMS, THAT IS ALSO A
PRIORITY IN THIS BUDGET,
CORRECT? CORRECT. OKAY SO WE'RE
PROTECTING A LOT OF THE
OVERSIGHT PROGRAMS, SUCH AS
STAFF MISCONDUCT, EXPANSION, THE
SEXUAL ASSAULT BEHIND BARS
WORKING GROUP AND MUCH MORE.
CORRECT CORRECT. ALL RIGHT. AND
THEN AS FAR AS THE BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS,
YOU ALREADY STATED THAT WE'RE
PRETTY MUCH NOT, DOING ANYTHING
TO REALLY AFFECT THAT JUST YET
BECAUSE, SO I HIGHLIGHT ALL OF
THIS BECAUSE WHEN I SPEAK TO
COMMUNITY MEMBERS, JUST LARGELY
IN THE PUBLIC, THEIR FOCUS IS
LARGELY SOCIAL SERVICES
EDUCATION K THROUGH 12, AS WELL
AS HIGHER EDUCATION, HEALTH AND
HOUSING, WHICH WE FOR THE MOST
PART ARE TRYING TO PROTECT AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE. AND WHEN YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT DOLLAR PER DOLLAR
AND THE RATIO OF WHAT WE'RE
SPENDING BASED ON POPULATIONS
THAT WE'RE SERVING, IT IS
IMPORTANT TO CUT AS MUCH BLOAT
AS POSSIBLE, WHICH WE ARE DOING
IN AREAS THAT WE CAN. SO WITH
THAT SAID, I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT MY CONCERN LARGELY IN
REGARDS TO BUDGETS AND FUNDING
UTILIZED BY GOVERNMENTS, BOTH AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL, WHEN I SERVED
ON CITY COUNCIL AS WELL AS AT
THIS LEVEL, THERE IS A MENTALITY
IN GOVERNMENT WHERE THEY
IDENTIFY THIS, THE SAYING OF USE
IT OR LOSE IT, RIGHT? THEY ARE
TRYING TO SPEND AS MUCH MONEY TO
BE ABLE TO ASK FOR MORE OR
POTENTIALLY KEEP THEIR FUNDING.
I THINK THAT THIS IS A DEEP
CONCERN I HAVE IN REGARDS TO
BEING FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE, AND
FOR ME, THAT RESPONSIBILITY IS
THE LARGER PUBLIC IN AREAS THAT
THEY CARE ABOUT. THE MOST. I
PERSONALLY VERY MUCH SUPPORT
THIS BUDGET. I DO APPRECIATE A
LOT OF THE WORK THAT YOU GUYS
HAVE DONE, AND I CAN GENUINELY
SAY THAT IN OUR BUDGET SUB FIVE
COMMITTEE, WE HAVE BEEN PUTTING
A LOT OF EFFORT IN JUST DOING
THE RIGHT THING FOR THE MOST
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR, WILL HAVE
SENATOR DALLI, I MAY NOT HAVE
THE EXTENSIVE NOTES AS MY
COLLEAGUE DOES, BUT I GOT A LOT
RIGHT HERE THAT I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT FOR A SECOND. SO FIRST
OFF, I WANT TO SOMETHING WE
HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT AT ALL, AND
THIS IS A QUESTION THE CHAIR
STARTED TALKING ABOUT WHAT IT
WAS LIKE BEFORE, DURING THE TIME
THAT OUR VICE CHAIR WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND THEY WERE, YOU
KNOW, WORKING ALL NIGHT DURING A
REAL 2008 CRISIS, WE'RE JUST
MISSING OUT ON THAT FUND. SO
BECAUSE WE HAVE DONE SOME THINGS
IN CALIFORNIA A LOT DIFFERENT IN
THE SINCE THEN. WE DO HAVE A
RESERVE AND BUT BUT I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE OVERALL OVERALL.
I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS WHY WE'RE
HERE. THE STOCK MARKET IS
HITTING ALL TIME HIGHS. NASDAQ
BROKE THE RECORD JUST LAST WEEK.
17,000 I THINK IT WAS. SO THE
ECONOMY IN THE UNITED STATES IS
DOING WONDERFUL ACTUALLY. IT'S
DOING SO WELL. THERE'S SO MUCH
INFLATION THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
SLOW IT DOWN BY RAISING INTEREST
RATES. SO WHY IS CALIFORNIA IN A
BUDGET DEFICIT. WHERE HOW DID WE
GET FROM $100 BILLION IN EXTRA,
EXTRA MONEY, BASICALLY 100
BILLION TO Ã WHATEVER THE
NUMBER IS? WE'VE BEEN ARGUING
ABOUT THE NUMBER FOR SINCE
JANUARY, BUT THE NUMBER IS
SOMEWHERE AROUND 50, AT LEAST 50
TO $55 BILLION. SO HOW DID WE GO
FROM 100 BILLION. WHAT HAPPENED
IN OUR TAX STRUCTURE. WHAT DID
WE DO DIFFERENT. SO WE CAN START
LOOKING AT BECAUSE THIS THIS IS
LOOKING TO THE FUTURE. SO I WANT
TO HAVE THAT ANSWERED BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT HAVING THESE SAME
PROBLEMS IN NEVADA, TEXAS, IDAHO
AS WE ARE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. SO
SOMETHING'S HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA THAT TYPICALLY HASN'T
HAPPENED, AT LEAST IN THE RECENT
FUTURE. IN THE LAST 12 YEARS
THAT I'VE BEEN HERE. SO COULD
YOU ANSWER THAT, PLEASE? I WILL
ATTEMPT TO. ERIKA LEE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND, I
WILL SORT OF START WITH A GLOBAL
PICTURE. THINGS THAT WE'VE SAID
IN THE PAST, OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF BUDGETS AND THEN TURN
IT TO MY COLLEAGUE FOR PERHAPS
MORE DETAIL. BUT AS YOU KNOW,
YOU MENTIONED THE 100 BILLION IN
IN SURPLUS AND WE WERE LOOKING
AT 2020, 2021, REVENUES WERE
WERE MUCH HIGHER THAN WE
ANTICIPATED. IF YOU LOOK AT THE
TREND, WE HIT A SPIKE. AND I
WOULD SAY THAT CALIFORNIA WAS
NOT THE ONLY STATE IN THE NATION
TO DO THAT. A LOT OF THAT WAS,
AN AFTERMATH OF COVID AND,
INCREASED, DOLLARS FROM THE FEDS
COMING IN. BUT ALSO THE STOCK
MARKET WAS DOING WELL. AND AS WE
KNOW, IN CALIFORNIA, THE, THE
OUR REVENUES BENEFIT WHEN STOCK
MARKET DOES WELL, WE HAVE HIGH
INCOME EARNERS, CAPITAL
REALIZATIONS, CAPITAL GAINS
REALIZATIONS, INCREASED, BUT I
WOULD ALSO SAY THAT, AT THAT
POINT, WE FORECAST THE FORECAST
WAS BASED ON, BOTH LOOKING AT
THE PAST, BUT WE HAD THAT
HUMONGOUS SPIKE RIGHT IN 2020
AND 2021. AND AS WE'VE BEEN
MENTIONING IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
BUDGET HEARINGS, OUR, OUR TAX
RECEIPTS WERE DELAYED. AND AS A
RESULT, WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION THAT WAS NECESSARY
THAT WE NORMALLY HAVE AT LAST
YEAR'S MAY REVISION AND BUDGET
ACT. AND, AS WE WERE BUILDING,
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THIS YEAR,
THOSE, THOSE TAX RECEIPTS WERE
COMING IN LATE. SO A LOT OF THE
FORECAST WAS BASED ON
INFORMATION THAT WE GENERALLY
HAVE BUT DIDN'T HAVE. AND SO WE
WEREN'T SURE HOW QUICKLY
REVENUES, BECAUSE WHEN THEY GO
UP, THEY COME DOWN. WE WEREN'T
SURE HOW QUICKLY THEY WOULD COME
DOWN. WHEN THEY WOULD COME DOWN,
AND HOW MUCH THEY WOULD COME
DOWN. SO WE USED THE BEST
INFORMATION AT HAND, TO FORECAST
THAT. AND AS WE SAW, ACROSS THE
NATION AND AGAIN, CALIFORNIA WAS
NOT THE ONLY ONE, BUT OUR
REVENUES WERE BIG, BEGINNING TO
NORMALIZE. AND THAT'S THE WORD
THAT WE'VE BEEN USING IS IF YOU
LOOK AT THOSE TWO YEARS OF
SPIKES AND KIND OF CUT THEM OUT
OF THAT PICTURE, WE ARE BACK TO
THE NORMAL 5. ABOUT 5% GROWTH IN
REVENUES. AND SO I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT'S SORT OF THE
TRAJECTORY THAT WE'VE BEEN
FOLLOWING OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS, DOWN TO A NORMALIZATION.
AND OTHER STATES IN THE COUNTRY
HAVE EXPERIENCED THAT AS WELL.
THEY DID NOT HAVE THE HIGH HIGH,
SUCH A SIGNIFICANT HIGH INCREASE
IN REVENUES AS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SO THERE'S SOME
DIFFERENCE IN THAT. BUT WE ALSO
HAVE A VERY VOLATILE TAX
STRUCTURE. AND THAT IS, THE
RESULT OF THAT IS THAT WE WERE
SEEING VERY HIGH INCREASES IN
REVENUES. AND AGAIN, THE
FORECAST WAS BASED ON INCOMPLETE
INFORMATION. WE HAVE MORE
INFORMATION THAN WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO RIGHTSIZE AND NORMALIZE,
FORECAST GOING OUT. BUT I WILL
TURN TO MY COLLEAGUE COLBY FOR
ANY ADDITIONAL DETAILS. NO
FURTHER COMMENTS ON THAT. SO
SAFE TO SAY THEN THAT THE STOCK
MARKET IS STILL DOING WELL. SO
WE'RE STILL GOING TO HAVE
CAPITAL GAINS, PAYMENTS, BUT
WE'RE NOT REALIZING THOSE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW, COLBY
WHITE, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO
THE WAY THE STATE REALIZES
PAYMENTS FROM CAPITAL GAINS IS
IN IS IN DIFFERENT, DIFFERENT
WAYS. SO, ONE ONE WAY, IT'S NOT
ACTUALLY CAPITAL GAIN, BUT ONE
WAY, IF YOU LOOK AT THE PERSONAL
INCOME TAX WITHHOLDING RECEIPTS,
WE GET WHAT'S CALLED, PAYMENTS
FROM RESTRICTED RESTRICTED STOCK
UNIT COMPENSATION THAT A LOT OF
LARGE TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES PAY
THEIR EMPLOYEES. AND SO YOU SEE,
FOR THE FIRST FOUR MONTHS
THROUGH APRIL, FOR EXAMPLE, YOU
SEE, 9% YEAR OVER YEAR GROWTH,
WHICH IS ABOVE AVERAGE GROWTH.
SO THAT'S, THAT'S THAT'S
EVIDENCE OF HOW CALIFORNIA IS
BENEFITING CURRENTLY FROM THAT.
NOW, WITH REGARD TO CAPITAL
GAINS REALIZATIONS THEMSELVES,
THEY'RE VERY THEY'RE VERY LAGGED
. SO FOR TAX YEAR 2023 TAXPAYERS
WILL MAKE PAYMENTS THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR TO SOME DEGREE TO WHAT
THEY EXPECT. BUT A LOT OF THEIR
PAYMENTS WILL COME LATER IN
JANUARY AFTER THE YEAR IS OVER.
AND THEN IN APRIL, ONCE THEY'RE
CHEWING UP THEIR FINAL TAX
RETURNS. AND I THINK WHAT WE SAW
WITH REGARD TO 2023, EVEN THOUGH
THE MARKET RECOVERED FROM VERY
FROM THE DOWN DOWNTURN IN 2022,
YOU ALSO HAVE WHAT ARE CALLED
CAPITAL LOSS CARRYOVERS FROM
FROM THE PRIOR YEAR. SO THERE
CAN BE A NETTING OUT AND THERE
CAN BE SOME HANGOVERS FOR LACK
OF A BETTER WORD. RELATED TO
OLDER YEARS. SO WE KNOW OVER THE
OVER THE LONGER RUN THAT WHEN
THE STOCK MARKET DOES WELL, THE
CALIFORNIA WILL DO WELL. THE
CAPITAL GAINS REALIZATIONS WILL
COME IN. THAT'S WHAT YOU SAW IN
2021. YOU SAW 349 BILLION, OVER
11% OF PERSONAL INCOME, HIGHER
THAN ANY OTHER STATE, AND SO,
YOU KNOW, THE STOCK MARKET'S
DOING WELL RIGHT NOW. WE'RE IN
2024. YOU KNOW, THE AND OUR
FORECAST INCORPORATES, YOU KNOW,
A SOLID STOCK MARKET FORECAST.
SO THOSE PAYMENTS WILL START TO
COME IN. BUT BUT YOU MIGHT NOT
SEE THE TRUE UNTIL LIKE JANUARY
WHEN THEY'RE WHEN THE YEAR'S
OVER. AND THEN IN THE FOLLOWING
APRIL WHEN, WHEN THE TAX RETURNS
ARE, OR THE EXTENSIONS ARE BEING
FILED. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT. SO IS THERE ANY RISK OF
HIGH WAGE EARNERS LEAVING? WE
KNOW THAT SOME ARE LEAVING THE
STATE. WE'VE SEEN, YOU KNOW,
FOLKS MOVE THEIR HEADQUARTERS
OUT OF CALIFORNIA. DOES THAT
HAVE A FACTOR IN THE BUDGET
CYCLE AS WELL? HIGH, HIGH, HIGH
WAGE OR INCOME EARNERS LEAVING
THE STATE, I THINK YOU SEE CHURN
IN ALL ASPECTS. SO FOR EXAMPLE,
WHEN YOU LOOK AT, WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE TOP 30 TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES BY MARKET CAP,
CALIFORNIA HAS A MUCH
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF THOSE
COMPANIES. SO WE HAVE VERY SOME
VERY LARGE COMPANIES HERE. WE
HAVE, FOR MOST YEARS, CALIFORNIA
GETS A DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT
OF VENTURE CAPITAL FUNDING. SO A
LOT OF THE YOUNGER L®NG, YOUNGER
COMPANIES THAT ARE THAT ARE
INVESTING, YOU SEE CALIFORNIA
GET ITS SHARE. IT VARIES FROM
YEAR TO YEAR. SOME YEARS ARE NOT
GOOD, SOME YEARS ARE GOOD. BUT
ON AVERAGE, CALIF GETS MORE THAN
ITS SHARE. SO THERE'S ALWAYS
THIS CHURN WHERE PEOPLE ARE
LEAVING AND PEOPLE ARE GOING,
AND THERE CAN BE A LOT OF
HEADLINES TO THAT EFFECT. SO,
YOU KNOW, BUT, IN THE AGGREGATE
AND OVER THE LONGER RUN
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY HAS REMAINED
VERY RESILIENT. AS NOTED HERE IN
VÌ. I APPRECIATE THAT. JUST ONE.
SO LIKE WHEN ELON MUSK LEAVES
CALIFORNIA, IT'S NOT THAT BIG A
DEAL. IT SEEMS LIKE IT WOULD BE
TO ME, THE RICHEST PERSON IN THE
WORLD WHEN A LOT OF HIS, ONE OF
OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID, GET
THE F OUT OF HERE, WAS ON A
TWITTER POST LIKE WE DIDN'T NEED
HIM. BUT IS THAT DOES THAT
IMPACT CALIFORNIA? CERTAINLY TO
SOME EXTENT. A TESLA AND ELON
HAVE A LOT OF BUSINESS ACTIVITY
STILL IN CALIFORNIA. A LOT OF
INCOME STILL GETS SOURCED TO
CALIFORNIA, IF IT'S, BUT WE'RE
NOT PRIVY TO HIS TAX RETURNS, SO
I CAN'T COMMENT. ALL RIGHT.
WELL, NOW ON TO THE SECOND PART.
I WANT TO JUST ALSO SAY THAT,
YOU KNOW, THIS IS A TWO PARTY
AGREEMENT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE, AND IT TAKES A THREE PARTY
AGREEMENT TO GET THINGS DONE. IT
USED TO BE A FOUR PARTY
AGREEMENT, BUT THE REPUBLICANS
ARE LEFT OUT OF THAT. NOW SO, SO
I KNOW THIS IS JUST A TWO PART.
SO I DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT, I HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT THE DIABLO CANYON
LOAN, $400 MILLION, THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO GO AND I KNOW IT'S
NOT IN THE BUDGET, TO THAT WAS A
PROMISE MADE TO PGE THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO. THEY'RE NOT ALONE
YET. LOAN. IS THE 1.1 BILLION
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON
THE ON THE IS THAT IT? IS IT, IS
IT IN JEOPARDY BECAUSE OF THE
$400 MILLION THAT THE CALIFORNIA
IS NOT, LIVING UP TO THEIR END
OF THE AGREEMENT? YEAH. THIRD
REGULAR DEPARTMENT FINANCE. SO
THE TWO PARTY AGREEMENT DOES NOT
INCLUDE THAT ADDITIONAL $400
MILLION THAT THE, ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSED, WHICH WAS PART OF THE
AGREEMENT WITH SBA 46. AND THAT
DOES PUT AT JEOPARDY THE
EXTENSION OF DIABLO CANYON. AND
IN TERMS OF THE 1.1 BILLION,
WHICH WAS THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT
THAT WAS IDENTIFIED IN THAT
FEDERAL AWARD. SO TO THE EXTENT
THE EXTENSION DOES NOT GO
THROUGH, THEN PG AND E WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO OBTAIN THOSE DOLLARS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT,
WHICH PUTS THAT JEOPARDY BEING
ABLE TO REPAY BACK THE $1
BILLION THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
LOANED FROM THE STATE TO PG AND
E AS PART OF THE AGREEMENT, AND
SBA 46. OKAY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR, IF I MAY. YES, RACHEL,
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE, JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THERE'S A LOT THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT LACK OF CLARITY
AROUND THIS ISSUE AND THE
AGREEMENT THAT PG AND E HAS MADE
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WHAT THE WHAT THE TERMS ARE, HOW
THE FUNDS WILL BE REPAID, HOW
THE FUNDS ARE BEING USED. SO, I
THINK WE DON'T HAVE A DEFINITIVE
ANSWER FOR YOU ON THIS QUESTION,
BUT I THINK WE WOULD PROBABLY BE
LESS DEFINITIVE THAN THE
ADMINISTRATION IN TERMS OF THE
WHAT WHAT LEVEL OF JEOPARDY,
THIS DECISION IS AROUND, IN PART
BECAUSE WE'VE STRUGGLED TO GET
SOME OF THE INFORMATION THAT
WE'VE ASKED FOR FROM, FROM THE
DEPARTMENT AND PG AND E. WELL,
THANK YOU FOR THAT. FIRST, I
WANT TO SAY I SHOULD HAVE
STARTED OUT SAYING, I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD WORK.
I'VE BEEN ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND SINCE I'VE BEEN IN
THE SENATE, AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL, ALL OF YOU FOLKS
WORKING HARD TO GIVE US THIS
INFORMATION. I THINK THE
FRUSTRATING PART FOR ME IS THAT,
WE'RE ASKED TO VOTE ON THINGS. I
MEAN, THIS IS A TWO PARTY
BUDGET. WE HAVEN'T BEEN PART OF
IT. SO WE GET THIS AS OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO POINT OUT SOME
THINGS THAT ARE REAL, I THINK
PROBLEMS. I MEAN, AT THE END OF
THE DAY IS THE $1.1 BILLION AT
JEOPARDY, SOUNDS LIKE IT IS. AND
THERE'S GOING TO BE A
NEGOTIATION THAT'S GOING TO TAKE
PLACE BETWEEN, I THINK, THE
CHAIR OF THE PRO TEM, THE
SPEAKER, AND THE BUDGET CHAIRS.
AND I THINK THAT'S UNFORTUNATE
FOR CALIFORNIANS WHEN WE'RE
TRYING TO DO, YOU KNOW, GOOD
BUDGETING HERE. AND WE HAVE, YOU
KNOW, A LOT OF MONEY THAT'S NOT
THERE THAT WE'VE HAD IN THE
PAST. IT'S A LOT SIMPLER WHEN
THERE'S MONEY AROUND. BUT THIS
YEAR IT'S GOING TO BE A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT. SO I APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK YOU FOR IDENTIFYING
THAT. THAT IS AT RISK IF WE
DON'T DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
THE OTHER QUESTION I HAD IS FOR
THE LÀ OFFICES ON THE ON ON AB
167 ON THE APPORTIONMENT, SOME
CORPORATIONS DO DON'T DO IT ON A
YEARLY JANUARY 1ST IS NOT WHEN
THEY FINISH THEIR DO THEIR
TAXES, THEY DO IT ON A FISCAL OR
A JUNE OR A DIFFERENT TIME FRAME
. SO THE CLAWBACK, THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT ON THE
APPORTIONMENT IS THAT IS THERE
SOME LEGAL WOULD THE STATE BE ON
THE HOOK FOR, LEGALLY FOR THOSE
CORPORATIONS THAT, MAY HAVE
THOSE LOSSES THAT COULD GO BACK
TO YOU'RE GOING TO RETROACTIVELY
GO BACK TO JANUARY? SO AS IT
STANDS RIGHT NOW, THERE AREN'T
ANY ADDITIONAL TAXPAYERS. OUR
UNDERSTANDING, IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL TAXPAYERS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ENTITLED TO RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL REFUNDS? GOODNESS.
SORRY, HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT?
BECAUSE SO THE OTA DECISION
APPLIES JUST TO MICROSOFT AT
THIS POINT IT HASN'T BEEN MADE
PRECEDENTIAL. I'M I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE CLAWBACK. SO YOUR NET
NET NET OPERATING LOSS OKAY. I'M
SORRY. I THOUGHT YOU WERE I'M
SORRY I SAID APPORTIONMENT, BUT
I MEANT NET OPERATING LOSS.
SORRY. SO CORPORATE ACTIONS THAT
DO THEIR TAXES NOT ON A FISCAL
YEAR BUT ON A BUDGET YEAR, THEY
ARE GOING TO BE REQUIRED TO CLAW
BACK, GO BACK AND DO CHANGE
THEIR TAXES FROM RIGHT NOW TO
JANUARY. SO IS THERE IS THE
STATE LEGALLY THERE'S THERE
COULD BE CHALLENGES TO THAT.
RIGHT NOW. THE LAW ALLOWS THEM
TO DO A NET OPERATING LOSS OVER
THREE YEAR PERIOD. SO IT WOULD
BE OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE
AREN'T ANY THERE HAVEN'T BEEN
ANY PAYMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
FOR ANY CORPORATIONS WITH
RESPECT TO TAX YEAR 24. YET
PAYMENT. WELL, THEY GET TO THEY
GET TO BALANCE IT OUT. IF THEY
HAVE A YEAR THEY PAY A LOT OF
TAXES AND THE YEAR THEY HAVE A
LOSS, THEY GET TO REACH BACK.
AND SO IF YOU STOP THAT, YOU'RE
STOP. THEY'RE SAYING THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT ABILITY TO REACH BACK.
BUT IT. RIGHT. SO, SO AN
IMPORTANT THING TO KEEP IN MIND
WITH THE EFFECTIVE DATE OF THE
NET OPERATING LOSS SUSPENSION IS
THAT IT APPLIES TO THE
TAXPAYER'S ABILITY TO CLAIM
THOSE NET OPERATING LOSSES ON
THEIR TAX RETURN AND REDUCE
THEIR TAX PAYMENTS THAT WILL BE
MADE SOMETIME IN 2025. IT
DOESN'T CHANGE ANYTHING ABOUT
THEIR ABILITY TO ACCRUE NET
OPERATING LOSSES FOR ACTIVITIES
THAT ARE OCCURRING IN TAX YEAR
24 RIGHT NOW. SO IF A BUSINESS
INCURS A LOSS DURING ITS CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR THAT IT'S IN, IT
RECEIVES, IT GETS TO ACCRUE THAT
NET OPERATING LOSS AND CARRY IT
FORWARD ON ITS, ON ITS BOOKS. SO
THERE'S ANYTHING ABOUT THE
SUSPENSION THAT THAT ELIMINATES
OR LIMITS THE BUSINESSES ABILITY
TO, TO, TO EARN IN A SENSE,
THOSE NET OPERATING LOSSES FOR
THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR. FOR
THOSE BUSINESSES, IT'S JUST
ABOUT THEIR ABILITY TO USE PRIOR
OR ACCRUED NET OPERATING LOSSES
ON THEIR TAX RETURNS FOR THE
NEXT THREE YEARS. OKAY THANK
YOU. AND THEN THE LAST THING I
HAVE IS JUST A COMMENT ON THE
MEDI-CAL MEDICAID, MCO TAX. I
THINK IT'S INTERESTING TO THINK
THAT HEALTH PLANS, WHICH IS
WHERE THE MCO TAX COMES FROM, IS
PEOPLE THAT PAY THE HEALTH PLANS
ARE SUBSIDIZING, OUR GENERAL
FUND, AND IT'S NOT REALLY GOING
TO HEALTH, IT EXCEPT FOR WHAT
COMES OUT OF THE GENERAL FUND,
WHICH IS BASICALLY MAINLY
FOCUSED ON, UNDOCKS AND THOSE
FOLKS THAT WILL BE RECEIVING
THAT. THAT'S JUST A COMMENT THAT
I HAVE. SO THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, OKAY, THE
VICE CHAIR, OVER TO YOU. THANK
YOU. MR. CHAIR, I GUESS UNDER
THE HEADING OF I TOLD YOU SO I
WASN'T GOING TO BRING THIS UP,
BUT FOR, SENATOR DOLLY'S
QUESTIONING, IF WE HAD PASSED
THE INITIATIVE THAT, WE
NEGOTIATED AS PART OF THE 2009.
YES. I'M GOING BACK INTO ANCIENT
HISTORY. THE INITIATIVE THAT WAS
NEGOTIATED AS PART OF THAT
BUDGET PACKAGE TO LIMIT THE
GROWTH OF SPENDING. WHEN THERE
IS A SPIKE IN SPENDING FOR THAT
2 OR 3 YEAR PERIOD WHERE WE
EXPERIENCE THAT UNSUSTAINABLE
SPIKE, THE ALL OF THAT MONEY
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BE
SPENT. WE WOULD HAVE A
SIGNIFICANTLY GREATER RESERVE
NOW, AND WE WOULD BE IN NOWHERE
NEAR THE TROUBLE WE ARE NOW. BUT
THAT'S JUST SO MUCH, HISTORY AT
THIS POINT, I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS, FIRST OF
ALL, WITH REGARD TO THE
UNALLOCATED STARTED, EXPENDITURE
REDUCTIONS THAT'S BEING REQUIRED
OF, ALL OF THE AGENCIES, WHICH
WAS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
REVISE. AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS
AS PART OF THIS BUDGET ALSO AND,
THIS HAS HAPPENED BEFORE, MY
RECOLLECTION, PASSION AND
EXPERIENCE WITH THIS IS THAT
WHEN AN UNALLOCATED, REQUEST OR
EVEN DEMAND IS MADE AS PART OF
THE BUDGET, IT NEVER TURNS OUT
EXACTLY AS, HOPED. THAT IS TO
SAY, THE FULL 8% IS UNLIKELY TO
BE, REALIZED, FOR FROM THE LORD.
I LÀ I APPRECIATE YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS, GIVEN THE
SUCCESS OR LACK OF SUCCESS OF
SUCH A BUDGET, PROVISION
RESULTING IN THE ACTUAL,
EXPECTED SAVINGS. WELL, IN OUR,
SENATOR, IN OUR REVIEW OF THE
MAY REVISION, IT WAS A CAVEAT OR
CONCERN THAT WE DID RAISE THAT,
THAT THERE COULD BE SOME, RISK
THAT NOT ALL OF THE SAVINGS
ASSUMED IN THAT PROVISION WOULD
BE WOULD MATERIALIZE. AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT THEY DON'T, IT WOULD
THEN CONTRIBUTE TO WHATEVER. IF
WE HAVE A PROBLEM NEXT YEAR IN
THE BUDGET, IT WOULD ROLL INTO
THAT YEAR'S BUDGET. BUT I DON'T
KNOW IF MY COLLEAGUE THAT COVERS
THIS AREA, JENNY BELLA, WOULD
LIKE TO ADD ANYTHING. THANK YOU.
JENNY. BELLA WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE,
THE ONLY THING I WOULD ADD IS
THAT THE PACKAGE BEFORE YOU DOES
INCLUDE SOME LANGUAGE TO SORT OF
GET AT THAT, THAT ISSUE, SOME
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
LANGUAGE SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A
BETTER SENSE OF KEEPING TRACK OF
WHERE WE ARE AT ACHIEVING THOSE
SAVINGS LEVELS. SO IT DOES ADOPT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL, BUT
THEN ADD THAT OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY LANGUAGE
ACCOUNTABILITY, JUST TO SEE HOW
SUCCESSFUL OR UNSUCCESSFUL WE
ARE FROM AN EXPERIENTIAL STAND
POINT, AN HISTORICAL BASIS, THIS
HAS BEEN DONE BEFORE WITH NOT
LESS THAN TOTALLY SATISFACTORY
RESULTS. DO YOU HAVE INFORMATION
ON THAT, NOT. NOT BEFORE ME
RIGHT NOW. BUT I CAN GO BACK AND
CHECK ON SORT OF THE HISTORICAL
AS YOU'RE AS YOU'RE SPEAKING TO
AND WHETHER WE HAVE ANY
INFORMATION WE CAN SHARE ON
THAT. THAT WOULD BE GOOD TO
KNOW. AS THE THREE PARTIES WORK
TOWARD THEIR FINAL BUDGET,
DISCUSSIONS, I WILL NOT BE PART
OF. BUT AS AN ADMONISHMENT WOULD
BE A GOOD FOR THE BUDGET WRITERS
TO KNOW. SO, WITH REGARD TO THE
MCO TAX NOW, THIS IS A MANEUVER
THAT HAS, SENATOR LAIRD POINTED
OUT ON THE FLOOR A SOME TIME
AGO, THIS WAS DONE BACK IN 2009,
AND IT'S BEEN DONE AT OTHER
TIMES. IT'S BEEN DONE ENOUGH
TIMES THAT THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY
HAS GROWN LEERY OF IT. AND SO
THEY HAVE QUALIFIED AN
INITIATIVE ON THE BALLOT THAT IF
PASSED, MY UNDERSTANDING IS,
WOULD, DRAW ABOUT $2.7 BILLION
IN 2025. NOW, THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD STRADDLE TWO DIFFERENT
BUDGET YEARS. BUT NONETHELESS,
IT IS, SERIOUS MONEY. AND WE
REALLY DON'T HAVE ANY ALLOWANCE.
I REALIZE IT'S A CONTINGENCY. I
HAVE TO THINK THAT THAT
INITIATIVE, PROBABLY STANDS A
REASONABLE CHANCE OF SUCCESS.
AND WOULD IT NOT MAKE SENSE TO
HAVE SOME CONTINGENCY IN THIS
BUDGET RELATIVE TO THAT
POSSIBILITY? EITHER LÀ OR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND I
WANT TO I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
BEFORE WE, BEFORE WE RESPOND
WITH THE MCO, ONE OF THE THINGS
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED, USING,
BOTH YEARS OF MCO TAX TO SWEEP
INTO THE GENERAL FUND, WE HAVE,
SCALED THAT BACK. SO IT'S THE
FIRST YEAR WILL GO BACK INTO THE
GENERAL FUND. THE SECOND YEAR,
WOULD NOT. SO IN TERMS OF, OF
ANY, POTENTIAL RISK, WE'VE
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED THAT IN
TERMS OF OUR PROPOSAL. AND
OBVIOUSLY IT'S AN OPEN
CONVERSATION WITH THE GOVERNOR
TO RESOLVE THAT. BUT I'M SORRY.
GO AHEAD. CAROLYN TIÂU
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE,
YES. THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR,
YOU ARE BOTH CORRECT IN THAT,
RELATIVE TO THE MAYOR REVISION,
GIVEN THAT THE LEGISLATURE'S
PLAN, ENACTS THE RATE INCREASES
IN 2026, THERE IS LESS THERE IS
SOMEWHAT OF A MITIGATED GENERAL
FUND RISK. GENERALLY SPEAKING,
WHAT I MIGHT OFFER IS THAT THIS
PARTICULAR SOLUTION, GIVEN, THE
MEASURE THAT IS TO GO TO THE
VOTERS IN NOVEMBER, DOES CREATE
SOME, SOME FISCAL RISK IN TERMS
OF WHAT THE STATE'S ULTIMATE
POSITION WILL BE, AND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE, IF THE MEASURE WERE
TO PASS, WOULD NEED TO IDENTIFY
ADDITIONAL SOLUTIONS TO BALANCE
THE BUDGET IN THE FUTURE. THANK
YOU, LAST TWO POINTS ARE REALLY
COMMENTS ON MY PART SINCE I
WON'T BE PART OF THE BUDGET
DISCUSSIONS, BUT I'D BE GLAD TO
JOIN YOU GUYS. I'M HAPPY TO TALK
TO YOU WHENEVER YOU WANT TO
TALK. THEN FIRST OF ALL, WITH
REGARD TO THE TAX ISSUES, JUST
TO HAVE MY HORSE TO BEAT IT A
LITTLE BIT, ON THE APPORTIONMENT
ISSUE, MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THE MICROSOFT CASE, INVOLVED A,
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD,
REQUIRING THAT MICROSOFT INCLUDE
FOREIGN DIVIDENDS IN THEIR
TAXABLE INCOME, WHICH THEY
APPEALED TO THE OFFICE OF TAX
APPEALS AND RULED AGAINST FTB ON
THAT, I THINK MAYBE TWICE. AND
SO THEREFORE, MICROSOFT DID NOT
HAVE TO INCLUDE THAT IN THEIR,
TAXABLE INCOME. BUT WHAT THE
BUDGET DOES IS CLARIFY, GUYS,
THAT IN FACT, THE FTB'S POSITION
ON THAT IS THE CORRECT POSITION.
SO THAT WE WILL HAVE IN CODE AS
A RESULT OF THE BUDGET, A
CLARIFICATION OF THE HANDLING OF
SUCH, TAXABLE INCOME, CONTRARY
TO WHAT OHTA HAD DECIDED. DO I
UNDERSTAND THAT CORRECTLY? LAO
YES, SENATOR NEAL, I THINK
THAT'S THE CORRECT FACTUAL
DESCRIPTION OF IT. YEAH, YEAH.
SO WE'LL WAIT FOR, YOUR
COLLEAGUE TO CLEAR HIS THROAT
AND WHICH I HAVE TO DO FOR THE
FOR THE RECORD, THAT HAPPENS TO
ME ALL THE TIME. SO. YEAH. I
MIGHT ALSO DEFER TO THE
ADMINISTRATION A LITTLE ON THIS,
BUT I THINK OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
IT'S MAYBE A LITTLE BIT MORE
COMPLICATED THAN WHAT YOU
DESCRIBED IN TERMS OF IT. IT
ISN'T. I LIKE TO SIMPLIFY. IT
ISN'T, SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE
TREATMENT FOR THE TAXATION OF,
OF REPATRIATED DIVIDENDS. IT'S
ACTUALLY ABOUT HOW THEY ARE
TREATED FOR THE CALCULATION OF
THE TAXPAYER AS APPORTIONMENT
FACTOR, AND SO THE FTB IS SORT
OF I GUESS LONG STANDING
POSITION HAS BEEN THAT IF,
INCOME OF A TAXPAYER IS NOT
TAXABLE, THEN IT SHOULD NOT BE
CONSIDERED AS PART OF THE
CALCULATION OF THEIR
APPORTIONMENT FACTOR, WHICH IS
AGAIN MEANT TO TRY TO REPRESENT
WHAT SHARE OF THEIR TAXABLE
BUSINESS ACTIVITY IS OCCURRING
WITHIN THE STATE, AND SO THE
QUESTION BEFORE OTA WAS WHETHER
OR NOT, THE REPATRIATED
DIVIDENDS, WHICH ARE, DEDUCTIBLE
AGAINST INCOME AND THEREFORE NOT
TAXABLE INCOME SHOULD BE
INCLUDED, IN THE APPORTIONMENT
CALCULATION OR NOT. AND SO FTB'S
POSITION AGAIN, DATING BACK TO A
LEGAL RULING FROM, FROM 2006 IS
THAT THOSE SHOULD NOT BE
INCLUDED. SAID THAT THE STATUTES
DON'T ESSENTIALLY DON'T GIVE
THEM THE AUTHORITY TO MAKE THAT
LEGAL RULING. AND SO THE
PROPOSAL HERE IS TO, ALIGN THE
STATUTES WITH FTB'S, LEGAL,
LEGAL POSITION ON THAT ISSUE.
AND THE RESULT IS THAT IF THE
MICROSOFT CAME UP AFTER AFTER
THIS BUDGET PASSED WITH THAT
LANGUAGE, THEY WOULD BE PAYING
MORE TAX THAT THAT'S CORRECT.
YEAH. SO THE POINT I'M MAKING IS
THIS IS A TAX INCREASE. NOW THE
OTHER, TAX ISSUES ARE DEFERRALS
AND WOULDN'T QUALIFY AS AN
ACTUAL TAX INCREASE. BUT THIS IS
AN ACTUAL TAX INCREASE. NOW IT
REQUIRES A TWO THIRDS MAJORITY
OF THE BUDGET, WILL LIKELY BE
PASSED THAT WAY. IN ANY CASE, SO
THAT THAT REQUIREMENT IS
ACADEMIC. I JUST WANT TO MAKE
THE CASE CLEAR. THIS IS AN
ABSOLUTE TAX INCREASE. SO MOVING
ON TO A COUPLE OF THE OTHERS. I
ALL OF THESE TAX MOVES, WHEN THE
GOVERNOR SAID HE WASN'T GOING TO
INCREASE TAXES, NONETHELESS, IN
MY OPINION, AND I THINK THE LÀ Þ
IN SOME CASES HAS CONCURRED WITH
THIS, THAT THAT THESE ARE JUST
NOT FROM A STRATEGIC STANDPOINT,
NOT WISE MOVES. THE TAX CREDITS,
PARTICULARLY THE R&D CREDIT. IS
A WAY OF PROVIDING A POSITIVE
ENVIRONMENT FOR BUSINESSES,
PARTICULARLY, TECH COMPANIES AND
GROWTH BUSINESSES TO EXIST IN
CALIFORNIA. CREDITS LIKE THIS
EXIST IN OTHER STATES. IT WOULD
JUST BE JUST ANOTHER REASON FOR
COMPANIES TO MIGRATE WITH REGARD
TO THE NET OPERATING LOSS,
THERE'S TWO THINGS ABOUT THIS
THAT IS TROUBLING. ONE IS I AKIN
THIS TO KICKING COMPANIES WHILE
THEY'RE DOWN. THAT IS TO SAY,
THEY ARE THEY THEY COME OUT OF A
LOST YEAR AND THEY START, WHICH
IS A DEPLETION OF THEIR CAPITAL,
AND THEN THEY START MAKING SOME
MONEY, WHICH IS A RECOVERY OF A
DEPLETED CAPITAL. AND THE
PURPOSE OF THE NET OPERATING
LOSS CARRY OVER IS TO PROVIDE
THE COMPANY THAT TIME TO RECOVER
PARTICULARLY SMALL AND
DEVELOPING COMPANIES. AND THIS
ELIMINATES THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
A FEW YEARS. AND THE INTERESTING
POINT THERE IS THIS IS PASSING
ALONG A KNOWN DEFICIT ONTO A
FUTURE ADMINISTRATOR WHEN WE
WILL HAVE A DIFFERENT
ADMINISTRATION, WHEN THIS BILL
COMES DUE FOR THE STATE TO ALLOW
THE NET OPERATING LOSS TO BE,
CLAIMED BY BUSINESSES, THAT FOR
WHOM IT QUALIFIES AND, FOR THE
REASONS OF BEING FAIR TO
COMPANIES THAT LOSE MONEY AND
ARE COMING OUT OF IT AND TO BE
FAIR TO, FUTURE ADMINISTRATIONS
AND NOT PASSING KNOWN DEFICITS
ON IT'S BAD POLICY, SO THOSE ARE
MY COMMENTS ON THE TAXES. I HAVE
ONE OTHER COMMENT. I THINK. WERE
YOU PUTTING YOUR FINGER UP?
WELL, JUST SLIGHTLY, SENATOR
NILA, WE, JUST TO CLARIFY, JUST
SLIGHTLY WHAT YOU SAID THAT WE
DID, INDICATE THAT IN OUR
ANALYSIS OF THESE THAT THE TAX
CREDITS THEMSELVES, SHOULD IT IS
APPROPRIATE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO THINK ABOUT THEM AS A WAY.
IT'S SORT OF THE SAME WAY YOU
THINK ABOUT SPENDING DECISIONS,
ONLY IT'S JUST GOING THROUGH THE
TAX CODE. NOW, WHEN IT COMES TO
THE NET OPERATING LOSSES. AND SO
WITH THOSE, THERE COULD BE SOME,
YOU KNOW, WHETHER OR NOT YOUR
THE LEGISLATURE IS GENERATING
THE BENEFITS FOR THE STATE THAT
IT WANTS FROM THOSE IS SOMETIMES
NOT TOTALLY CLEAR, NOW, WHEN IT
COMES TO THE NET OPERATING
LOSSES, WE DO HAVE, WE HAVE
REGISTERED THE CAVEATS THAT YOU
MENTIONED ABOUT THE CYCLICALITY
AND HOW SOME FIRMS THAT
PARTICIPATE IN CYCLICAL AND UP
AND DOWN INDUSTRIES ARE
DISADVANTAGE RELATIVE TO THE
ONES THAT ARE IN MORE STABLE
SECTORS. AND SO, SO, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS A THING THAT WE HAVE
DONE, IN BASICALLY HALF OF THE
YEARS NOW SINCE 2008, IF YOU
LOOK AHEAD TO 2027. AND SO HOW
MUCH CAN THEY DEPEND ON THE FACT
THAT THIS PROVISION WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO THEM IS A QUESTION
THAT, YOU KNOW, IS VALID, YOU
KNOW, VALID CAVEAT. SO AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. I, I,
UNFORTUNATELY LED TO THE
IMPLICATION THAT YOU HAD OPINED
NEGATIVELY ON ALL OF THESE. I
DIDN'T MEAN THAT IT WAS
SPECIFICALLY ON THE NET
OPERATING LOSS, AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE WORK THAT YOU
DO NOW. AS I SAID BEFORE AT THE
OPENING, THIS BUDGET IS BALANCED
NOMINALLY, THE CHALLENGE IS IT
IS NOT SUSTAINABLE. LET ME JUST
SUMMARIZE A FEW THINGS RELATIVE
TO WHAT'S IN THIS BUDGET AND
WHAT'S NOT IN THIS BUDGET. THE
HEALTH CARE MINIMUM WAGE, AS WE
DISCUSSED IT, CURRENTLY, THE
COST OF THAT IS NOT INCLUDED IN
THIS BUDGET. AND SOMEHOW NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED WHEN THE OTHER
TWO PARTIES GET TOGETHER AND,
AND HAMMER THAT OUT. THAT'S
ABOUT $2 BILLION. THE MCO
INITIATIVE THROUGH THE FULL YEAR
OF 2025, WHICH, AS I SAID,
STRADDLES BUDGET YEARS. AND I
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE CHAIR SAID
ON THAT. BUT THE TOTAL EXPOSURE
THERE IS ABOUT $2.7 BILLION.
ALSO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET MAY
REVISE ESTIMATES $7 BILLION IN
REVENUE IN EXCESS OF WHAT THE
LAO ESTIMATES NOW, I HAVE STATED
REPEATEDLY THAT I'M ALWAYS, MORE
WILLING TO GIVE DEFERENCE TO
THE, ESTIMATES OF THE BUDGET
ADVICE HERE AS OPPOSED TO THE
BUDGET WRITER. THERE ARE
DIFFERENT PRESSURES INVOLVED IN
COMING UP WITH THE FINISHED
PROJECT PRODUCT, AND I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET IS $7
BILLION HIGHER IN REVENUE, AND
THE LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET IS
ANOTHER $4 BILLION HIGHER THAN
THAT. SO THIS BUDGET HAS IN IT
$11 BILLION IN ADDITIONAL
REVENUE ASSUMED. BY THE WAY,
PARENTHETICALLY, I'VE ALSO
ALWAYS SAID ONE OF THE EASIEST
WAYS TO BALANCE A PUBLIC SECTOR
BUDGET IS JUST TO ASSUME MORE
REVENUE. AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THAT UNTIL THE YEAR'S
OVER OR CLOSE TO OVER. SO WE
HAVE $11 BILLION IN ADDITIONAL
REVENUE BEYOND THE ADVICE OF OUR
BUDGET ADVISOR. THEN WE HAVE THE
PROPOSITION 98 MAINTENANCE
FACTOR OF THE MANEUVER. WITH
REGARD TO THE 2324 YEAR, WE HAVE
ALSO THE, OBLIGATION ATION AS A
RESULT OF THE GOVERNOR'S, 2223
MANEUVER WITH REGARD TO
EDUCATION FUNDING, AND THEN WE
HAVE THE, DOUBTFUL, REALIZATION
OF THE 8% ACROSS THE BOARD
UNALLOCATED CUTS. I DON'T KNOW
HOW MUCH THOSE AMOUNTS ARE, BUT
THE ONES THAT I STATED
PREVIOUSLY ARE ANYWHERE FROM 12
TO $16 BILLION. THOSE ARE VERY
LIKELY DEFICITS THAT WILL HAVE
TO BE DEALT WITH IN THE JANUARY
25TH PROPOSAL. IN ADDITION TO
THE DEFICIT THAT WE ALREADY KNOW
EXISTS IN THE SUBSEQUENT BUDGET
YEAR, IT WAS 30 BILLION. NOW
IT'S ONLY TEN OAN. BUT WITH
THAT CONTINGENCY, IT'S BACK UP
TO 30. SO AS I SAID, THE BUDGET
IS BALANCED NOMINALLY, BUT IT IS
NOT SUSTAINABLE. SO WITH THAT,
MR. CHAIR, I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE MY COMMENTS,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR. VICE
CHAIR, BEFORE WE GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT, I JUST WANT TO SAY A
FEW THINGS BECAUSE A NUMBER OF
STATEMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE TODAY,
FIRST OF ALL, I'M REALLY PROUD
OF THIS BUDGET. AND EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO
SOME WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ACHIEVE THAT
THREE PARTY DEAL, THIS IS NOT
JUST THIS IS NOT A QUOTE
UNQUOTE, NOMINALLY BALANCED
BUDGET. IT'S AN ACTUALLY
BALANCED BUDGET. AND IT'S A
BUDGET, THAT I THINK WE CAN ALL
BE PROUD OF. IT'S A BUDGET THAT
DEEPLY PROTECTS, OUR INVESTMENT
IN K THROUGH 12 PUBLIC
EDUCATION. WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE THERE, FOR THE
CHILDREN OF CALIFORNIA WHO
DESERVE A GOOD EDUCATION. THIS
BUDGET PROTECTS INVESTMENT IN
HOUSING, WHICH IS ONE OF THE
GREATEST CRISES FACING OUR STATE
AS WELL AS HOMELESSNESS, IT
PROTECTS FUNDING FOR, PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION, FOR HEALTH CARE,
AND SO ON. AND SO FORTH. I'M
PROUD OF THIS BUDGET, THERE WERE
SOME COMMENTS MADE ABOUT OUR
PRISON BUDGET. I WANT TO BE
CLEAR, THE PROPOSED BUDGET, FOR
CDCR, IN THIS BUDGET ACT THAT
WE'RE ACTING ON TODAY IS $14
BILLION FOR OUR PRISON SYSTEM,
$14 BILLION, $14 BILLION, NEARLY
10% OF THE GENERAL FUND, THAT IS
NOT A DEFUNDING OF PRISONS OR OR
OR SHUTTING DOWN THE ENTIRE
PRISON SYSTEM. IT'S $14 BILLION.
THAT IS HIGHER THAN WHAT WE
SPENT ON PRISONS WHEN OUR PRISON
POPULATION WAS 50% HIGHER THAN
IT IS TODAY, OUR PRISON SYSTEM
IS LONG OVERDUE FOR A DEEP
RESTRUCTURING. IT IS ABSOLUTELY
ABSURD THAT WE HAVE REDUCED OUR
PRISON POPULATION BY 50. AND YET
WE'RE SPENDING MORE ON PRISONS.
THAT IS A HUGE RED FLAG, I ALSO,
YOU KNOW, WE CAN WE CAN HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR COMMITTING
CRIMES WITHOUT GOING BACK TO
MASS INCARCERATION AND PACKING
OUR PRISON FULL OF PEOPLE,
PARTICULARLY PEOPLE WHO ARE
ADDICTED TO DRUGS, WHICH IS WHAT
WE USED TO DO. AND SO THE TWO
ARE NOT MUTUALLY INCONSISTENT. I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE, YES, WE'RE
PROTECTING REHABILITATION AND
REENTRY FUNDING OF CDCR'S $14
BILLION BUDGET 4% GOES TO
REHABILITATION 4. AND SO YEAH WE
ARE PROTECTING THAT. THAT NUMBER
NEEDS TO BE HIGHER NOT LOWER. I
ALSO JUST WANT TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
AROUND THE KNOLL AND THE TAX
CREDIT, DEFERRALS. AND BY THE
WAY, AS, AS INDICATED,
CORPORATIONS WILL BE ABLE TO
RECOUP THOSE CREDITS IN THE
FUTURE, SO I THINK WE NEED TO BE
VERY CLEAR ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE, BUT I ALSO THINK WE
NEED TO RECOGNIZE IN TERMS OF
THIS WHOLE NARRATIVE AROUND
CORPORATE TAXATION, THAT IN
2017, CORPORATIONS IN THIS
COUNTRY RECEIVED A 40% TAX CUT
IN THE TRUMP TAX CUTS. IT WENT
THE FEDERAL CORPORATE TAX RATE
WENT FROM 35% TO 21% IN ONE FELL
SWOOP. A 40% TAX CUT. WE KNOW
THAT A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
FORTUNE 100 COMPANIES ARE PAYING
EITHER NO FEDERAL TAXES OR VERY
LITTLE IN FEDERAL TAXES. SOME OF
THE LARGEST CORPORATIONS IN THIS
COUNTRY ESSENTIALLY VÆ OR
ACTUALLY DON'T PAY ANY FEDERAL
TAXES. AND SO THE NOTION THAT
THAT THIS, PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE
WITH, WITH THE NOL AND TAX
CREDITS, THAT THAT BECAUSE THEY
WON'T BE ABLE TO TAKE IT NOW,
BUT THEY'LL BE ABLE TO RECOUP IT
IN THE FUTURE THAT, THAT SOMEHOW
GOING TO DESTROY CORPORATIONS,
THAT'S JUST, TO BE HONEST,
ABSURD. THEY HAVE RECEIVED HUGE
TAX CUTS IN RECENT YEARS. AND WE
KNOW FROM THE STOCK MARKET,
THESE THESE CORPORATIONS ARE
DOING QUITE WELL, AND SO THIS IS
A VERY, VERY REASONABLE
PROPOSAL. AND IN THE END, IF I
HAVE A CHOICE BETWEEN HAVING
CORPORATIONS TAKE THEIR TAX
CREDITS OVER TIME IN THE FUTURE
INSTEAD OF RIGHT NOW, IF I HAVE
A CHOICE BETWEEN THAT AND HAVING
LESS, FEWER SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
LIVING WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES OR FEWER FOR
IN-HOME HEALTH SUPPORT SERVICES
FOR OUR SENIORS, OR OR TAKING
TAKING AWAY HEALTH CARE, TAKING
AWAY THE ABILITY TO GET LIKE
DENTURES FOR FARM WORKERS WHO
ARE ACTUALLY CULTIVATING THE
FOOD THAT WE EAT. I'M GOING TO
GO WITH THE PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THE SENIORS WHO NEED IN-HOME
SUPPORT, AND THE FARM WORKERS
WHO DESERVE BASIC HEALTH CARE
AND BASIC HUMAN DIGNITY EVERY
DAY OF THE WEEK, SO THAT OUR OUR
TAX PROPOSAL IS COMPLETELY
REASONABLE. AND I STAND FIRMLY
BEHIND IT, SO WITH THAT, I WANT
TO OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT, WE'LL ASK PUBLIC
COMMENTERS, TO KEEP YOUR COMMENT
WITHIN A MINUTE. AND SO WE
APPRECIATE IT. LET'S GO AHEAD
AND MOVE, MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS,
CHRIS MCCAULEY, ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE, TWO ITEMS IN REGARDING
THE, TAX TRAILER BILL, THE FIRST
IS WE'RE THE HOME OF INDUSTRIES
LIKE TECH, BIOTECH, AEROSPACE.
YET THE KNOLL SUSPENSION AND R&D
IN PARTICULAR. BUT THE TAX
CREDIT LIMITATION PARTICULARLY
ADVERSELY IMPACTS THOSE
INDUSTRIES. TO MAKE THE PROBLEM
WORSE, WE JUST DID THAT IN 20
AND 21. AND SO AS THOSE CREDITS
AND KNOLLS ARE BECOMING
AVAILABLE, WE ARE TAKING THEM
ONCE AGAIN. THE OTHER POINT IS,
IS THAT IT IS BEING DONE ALMOST
MIDWAY THROUGH THE TAX YEAR
BECAUSE AS OPPOSED TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL, WHICH
IS PROSPECTIVE, THIS IS
RETROACTIVE TO THE FIRST OF THE
YEAR. THE SECOND ITEM ON THE
APPORTIONMENT FORMULA, I THINK
THE LANGUAGE IN SECTION 41 IS
QUITE CLEAR. IT HAS RETROACTIVE
IMPACT. IT APPLIES TO PAST
YEARS. WE RESPECTFULLY THINK
THAT IT WILL EFFECTIVELY
OVERTURN THE OTA DECISION. AND
THAT'S WHY THAT $1.3 BILLION IN
REFUND CLAIMS IS BEING PUT IN
JEOPARDY. AND WILL BE PRECLUDED
UNDER THE LANGUAGE OF THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU. I, TIFFANY
MARK, ON BEHALF OF CFT, A UNION
OF EDUCATORS AND CLASSIFIED
PROFESSIONALS. THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR ALL THEIR
TIME, HARD WORK AND PARTICULARLY
ALSO TO THE STAFF. WE WANTED TO
JUST STAND TO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSITION 98, WORK THAT HAS
BEEN DONE TO ADDRESS THE
DEFICIT, THE REMOVAL OF THE
LABOR CENTER, CUTS FROM THIS
BUDGET, èC FUNDING OF THE
COMPACT. AND WE ADVOCATE FOR THE
INCLUSION OF PART TIME OFFICE
HOURS FOR FACULTY TO HELP ALL
OUR STUDENTS SUCCEED. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. GOOD MORNING. I'M
DOCTOR JUNE BOND, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY. WE'RE A
NONPROFIT CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATION WITH ABOUT 13,000
MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE. I'M
HERE TO OPPOSE THE REVERSION OF
$45 MILLION FROM THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND. THANK YOU,
SENATORS BLAKE FERRER AND LAIRD,
FOR RAISING THIS CONCERN, THIS
BUDGET ACTION IS IN DIRECT
CONTRAVENTION OF PROPOSITION
117, WHICH WAS ENACTED BY VOTERS
IN 1990. THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND HAS BEEN
HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL, PROTECTING
MORE THAN 1 MILLION ACRES OF
LAND SINCE. SINCE ITS INCEPTION.
THIS FUND IS ONE OF THE FEW
RELIABLE AND ONGOING FUND
SOURCES FOR THE STATE'S CLIMATE
CHANGE PLAN AND ITS 30 BY 30
INITIATIVE. I WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT JUST TWO OF THE
HUNDREDS OF HCF FUNDED
CONSERVATION PROJECTS FROM THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD OVER
THE YEARS THROUGH $2.2 MILLION
IN FUNDING TO THE MOUNTAINS
RECREATION AND CONSERVATION
AUTHORITY, THE CHATSWORTH
RESERVOIR CONNECTOR PROJECT IS
PROTECTING IMPORTANT WETLAND AND
RIPARIAN HABITAT IN NORTHERN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. NEARLY $2
MILLION IN FUNDING TO THE NATIVE
AMERICAN LAND CONSERVANCY HAS
SUPPORTED AN IMPORTANT ANCESTRAL
LAND RETURN PROJECT THAT
PROTECTS LAND AND BIG MORONGO
CANYON IN SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
WITH CULTURAL, HISTORIC, AND
HABITAT VALUE. WE STRONGLY URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO RESCIND THIS
REVERSION IN THE FINAL BUDGET
DEAL. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR, AND VICE CHAIR. THERE YOU
ARE, LORI KAMMERER WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS, CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER. AND WE, ON BEHALF OF
THE 1.4 MILLION WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS, MANY OF WHOM ARE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS, WE WOULD WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR, FUNDING, THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR
THE SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS AT 100. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON, SENATORS,
MY NAME IS PAT NYE. I REPRESENT
THE LOS ANGELES REGIONAL SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT CENTER
NETWORK, AS WELL AS THE VETERANS
BUSINESS OUTREACH CENTER
NETWORK. I AM ALSO A VETERAN AND
A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER. I JUST
WANTED TO THANK THE COMMITTEE,
THE STAFF, FOR SUPPORTING 100%
FUNDING FOR THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM, WITH SPECIAL
THANKS TO SENATORS PADILLA
NIELLO AND SMALLWOOD CERVANTES.
THANK YOU. YEAH, I JUST GOT
MARRIED. GOOD MORNING, DAVID
NELSON WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION. NATIONAL SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCACY COUNCIL AND
ECHOING YOU'LL HEAR MORE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ATTENTION AND SUPPORT OF FULL
FUNDING FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM, A
SPECIAL THANKS TO SENATE SUB
FOUR CHAIR PADILLA, SENATOR
NILO, SENATOR SMALLWOOD FOR
BEING SO ATTENTIVE AND LISTENING
TO THE CONCERN. WE ALL AGREE AND
WE'RE WE'RE THANKFUL TO SEE THAT
THE TWO HOUSE AGREEMENT AGREES
THAT THE BUDGET SHOULDN'T BE
BALANCED ON CUTTING SERVICES,
CORE SERVICES TO SMALL
BUSINESSES. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT, ESPECIALLY TO TIMOTHY
GRIFFITHS, WHO WAS VERY
ATTENTIVE TO ABSORBING AND
ASKING THOSE VERY CRITICAL
QUESTIONS TO FULLY UNDERSTAND
HOW THIS PROGRAM HAS DELIVERED
FOR THE STATE. LAST YEAR ALONE,
2.3 BILLION IN TAXABLE REVENUE.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I REPRESENT
THE SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS. I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
SONOMA SBDC. HOPE I DON'T GET
EMOTIONAL, HE SAID IT. WE HELPED
TWO POINT CREATE $2.3 BILLION
WORTH OF, TAXABLE REVENUE JUST
LAST YEAR. THAT'S JUST LAST
YEAR. AND AS I WAS LISTENING AND
SO IMPRESSED BY HOW YOU ALL
APPROACHED YOUR DIFFERENT,
PERSPECTIVES, WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO ALL OF
US, WE CAN REALLY GET BEHIND THE
FACT THAT WE ALL LIKE OUR JOBS.
WE LIKE HAVING PLACES TO GO SHOP
AND EAT AND DO THINGS. AND WHAT
YOU MIGHT NOT KNOW IS THAT 2.3
BILLION CAME FROM JUST 145,000,
NOT JUST EXCUSE ME, 145,000
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT WE HELPED.
THAT NUMBER OF 2.3 BILLION IS
REPRESENTATIVE OF ONLY A 5%
RESPONSE TO OUR SURVEYS. SO
IMAGINE HOW MUCH MORE TAXABLE
REVENUE THAT THE SBDCS ARE
PROVIDING TO YOUR COMMUNITY. AND
THE COMMUNITIES WE SERVE, ALL
THE WAY FROM SAN DIEGO TO THE
OREGON BORDER. AND ON BEHALF OF
ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO HAVE A
DREAM AND A DESIRE TO BE AND DO
SOMETHING BIGGER THAN
THEMSELVES, THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. PREET AHLUWALIA WITH NORCAL
SBDC. WE APPLAUD AND THANK YOU
TO THE SENATE LEADERSHIP AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
FOR RESTORING THE TARP FUNDING.
SBDCS ARE THE BACKBONE OF OUR
STATE'S ENTREPRENEURIAL
ECOSYSTEM. WE PROVIDE CRITICAL
SERVICES TO HELP SMALL
BUSINESSES NAVIGATE CHALLENGES,
DRIVE INNOVATION, AND CREATE
JOBS. THESE FUNDS WILL CONTINUE
TO ASSIST, HELP US TO SERVICE
THE RURAL AND UNDERSERVED SMALL
BUSINESSES. WE URGE YOU TO
MAINTAIN THIS FULL FUNDING FOR
TAP INTO FINAL NEGOTIATED LOANS
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
STAND WITH THE SMALL BUSINESSES
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR, VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. JOHNNY
FOSTER DOWNS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASIAN CHAMBER. ON BEHALF OF OUR
MEMBERS AND AAPI BUSINESSES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE, AND AS
WELL AS OUR MINORITY BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS, WE LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
MAINTAINING THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FUNDING WITH
A SPECIAL ACKNOWLEDGMENT AND
THANKS TO THE LEADERSHIP OF
SENATOR NILO, SENATORS PADILLA,
PADILLA AND SMALLWOOD CUEVAS FOR
HEARING OUR CONCERNS AND FOR
PROTECTING THIS THIS VERY
ESSENTIAL FUNDING AND KEEPING IT
WHOLE AND PROTECTING THE CORE
SERVICES AND ESSENTIAL SERVICES
FOR OUR SMALL AND DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESSES. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
JENNIFER FEARING, ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL WILDLIFE FEDERATION
AND THE PROJECT WILDLIFE PART OF
SAN DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY, I'LL
JUST ECHO THE REMARKS AROUND THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND MADE
BY SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR, SENATOR
LAIRD AND MY COLLEAGUE WITH
CNPS, AND ALSO EXTEND GRATITUDE
TO CHAIR BECKER, SENATOR ALLEN
AND SENATOR DALI, WHO RAISED
SIMILAR CONCERNS DURING THE SUB
TWO DISCUSSION OF THIS ITEM. WE
DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S REJECTION OF THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND
TRAILER BILL, BUT BELIEVE
STRONGLY THAT THE REVERSION
THAT'S IN AB 107 OF $45 MILLION
VIOLATES THE LANGUAGE OF
PROPOSITION 117. AND WE URGE YOU
TO CORRECT THAT IN THE FINAL
BUDGET. THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION, REPRESENTING 220
MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS NATIONWIDE
AND 85 TRANSIT AND RURAL
AGENCIES HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, I JUST WANT TO SHOW
MY THANKS AND SUPPORT TO YOU ALL
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE FOR
MAINTAINING, IN THIS TWO PARTY
AGREEMENT, THE $5.1 BILLION
APPROVED LAST YEAR FOR PUBLIC
TRANSIT SERVICES AND MAJOR
CAPITAL PROJECTS LAST YEAR, YOU
HEARD OUR CALLS FOR SUPPORT IN
ENSURING THAT WE COULD CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE BASIC CORE PUBLIC
TRANSIT SERVICES WHILE ALSO
BUILDING FOR THE FUTURE. AND AS
YOU ENTER INTO THOSE THREE PARTY
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE GOVERNOR,
OF COURSE, GOVERNORS MAY REVISE
HAS PROPOSED TO MAINTAIN THAT
FUNDING. ALSO SO WE JUST ASK
THAT THERE NOT BE ANY
BACKSLIDING AND THAT THAT
FUNDING MAINTAIN, BE MAINTAINED
IN THE FINAL BUDGET AGREEMENT,
THAT MONIES HAVE ALREADY BEEN
REQUESTED BY THE REGIONAL
ENTITIES, THE TRANSIT AGENCIES
IN THE STATE. WE'RE NOW JUST
EXPECTING THE RELEASE OF THOSE
FUNDS. SO THOSE MONIES CAN BE
PUT TO WORK. THANK YOU. ALCHEMY.
GRAHAM, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CITY TRANSPORTATION
INITIATIVE, WITH COMMENTS ON AB
107, WE'D LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
SINCERE THANKS AND SUPPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE FOR REJECTING
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO CUT
$600 MILLION FROM THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM AND FOR
PROPOSING ADDITIONAL SUPPORTIVE
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. THIS PROGRAM QUITE
LITERALLY SAVES LIVES, AND WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL TO SEE IT MAINTAIN
ITS FUNDING. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. WE WANT TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAFF'S WORK TO
PROTECT KEY SAFETY NET PROGRAMS,
INCLUDING CALWORKS, FOSTER CARE
PROGRAMS, NUTRITION BENEFIT, AND
MAINTAINING IHSS FOR
UNDOCUMENTED PARTY AGREEMENT,
MAINTAIN THESE PROTECTIONS. IN
ADDITION, WE APPRECIATE A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THE MCO TAX
REVENUE IS AUTHORIZED FOR
MEDI-CAL INVESTMENT AND URGE A
PORTION OF THIS GO TO SHARE OF
COST REFORM IMPLEMENTATION SO
THAT SENIOR AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES ARE NOT FORCED TO
LIVE OFF $600 A MONTH TO ACCESS
MEDI-CAL. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. VICE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MALIK
BYNUM WITH THE UAW ASKED ME
LOCAL 3930 REPRESENTING OVER
171,000 HOME CARE AND CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE ON
BEHALF OF CCPA, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S COMMITMENT TO THE
11,000 SLOTS THAT WE WERE
ALLOTTED IN SPRING 2024. AND
WHILE WE'RE LOOKING AT A NEW
TIMELINE OF 2028, WE WOULD URGE
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO EXPLORE HOW WE
CAN FULFILL THESE SLOTS EVEN
EARLIER AND WHILE RETAINING OUR
PROGRESS TOWARDS A TRUE COST OF
CARE RATE REFORM AS IT RELATES
TO HOME CARE. WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
THE LEGISLATIVE LEGISLATURE'S
SUPPORT AND REJECTING THE CUTS
TO IHSS, SPECIFICALLY THE
EXPANSION TO UNDOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUALS AND THE PROPOSED
ELIMINATION OF THE PROVIDER BACK
UP SYSTEM. WE DO, HOWEVER,
CONTINUE TO URGE THE SENATE TO
ADOPT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
RELATING TO THE STATE
PARTICIPATION CAP IN SAN DIEGO
AND RIVERSIDE BECAUSE WITHOUT
THIS LAND, WITHOUT THIS
LANGUAGE, HOME CARE PROVIDERS IN
THESE COUNTIES WILL NOT RECEIVE
THEIR PAY INCREASE ON JANUARY
1ST OF 2025. AND THIS WILL BE
DEVASTATING FOR THEM. SO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TODAY.
APPRECIATE YOUR WORDS, MR. CHAIR
AND SENATOR SKINNER, AS IT
RELATES TO OUR WORKERS AND WOULD
URGE YOU ALL TO CONTINUE TO
STAND WITH HOME CARE AND CHILD
CARE THROUGHOUT THE FINAL
BUDGET. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. TRACY RYAN, RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE ELIMINATION OF THE
BROADBAND LOAN LOSS RESERVE
PROGRAM. THIS WAS ORIGINALLY A
$750 MILLION PROGRAM, IT HAS NOW
BEEN ELIMINATED IN AB 107. WE
HAVE $433 MILLION WORTH OF
AWARDS WAITING AT THE CPUC FOR
THIS PROGRAM TO HAVE PROJECTS
DEPLOYED IN 37 LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE, WE
UNDERSTAND THIS IS VERY HARD
BUDGET TIMES. WE ARE NOT ASKING
FOR FULL RESTORATION THÀNH WE
ARE SIMPLY ASKING FOR A $50
MILLION RESTORATION FOR A PILOT
PROJECT SO THAT WE CAN DO SOME
OF THOSE 37 PROJECTS IN THESE
UNDERSERVED AREAS. THANK YOU. HI
THERE. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
BIANCA BLOMQUIST. I'M CALIFORNIA
DIRECTOR FOR SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY. I WANT TO THANK, I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
VICE CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR THEIR SUPPORT
AND THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM PROVISIONS. THESE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
ARE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT FOR THE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS THAT WE
REPRESENT. WE ALSO ENCOURAGE
YOU, IN THE THIRD PARTY
AGREEMENT TO CONTINUE WORKING TO
SPEND ON THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY RESERVE FUND, AS
HEALTH CARE IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS, AND WE'RE VERY GLAD THAT
WE'RE MAINTAINING THOSE CHILD
CARE SLOTS. BUT WE WOULD ASK YOU
TO CONTINUE TO WORK IN THE THIRD
PARTY AGREEMENT TO REACH THE
TRUE COST OF CARE FOR CHILD CARE
AND SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'M DOMINIQUE DANNY, ON
BEHALF OF EDVOICE AND 20 OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS, WE WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR PRIORITIZING
CHILDREN FROM LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES BY REJECTING
PROPOSED FUNDING CUTS TO THE
GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM, AND WE ASK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND MAINTAIN THE
PROGRAM AS IS PROPOSED. CHANGES
EXCUSE ME TO THE PROGRAM.
DISINCENTIVIZE TEACHERS TO TEACH
IN PRIORITY SCHOOLS. THE PROGRAM
IS WORKING AS IS AND IN A BUDGET
SHORTFALL. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE STABILITY
IN THE LIVES OF CHILDREN FROM
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AS THEY
MAY BE EXPERIENCING INSTABILITY
ELSEWHERE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M ERIC LARA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. FIRST,
CSAC IS GRATEFUL TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR NUMEROUS BUDGET
ACTIONS THAT PRESERVE THE SAFETY
NET AND CORE SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS THAT CAN DELIVER TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS, THIS INCLUDES
REJECTION OF CUTS TO THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE, CALWORKS
CHILD WELFARE AND APS PROVIDING
1 BILLION IN FUNDING FOR ROUND
SIX OF THE HAP PROGRAM,
RESTORING REAP 2.0 FUNDING, AND
APPROPRIATING 500 MILLION FOR,
THE LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDITS. WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
BACKFILLING OF 100 MILLION TO
THE VICTIMS OF CRIME ACT AND
REJECTING CUTS TO THE PUBLIC
DEFENSE PILOT PROGRAM. AND
FINALLY, I APPRECIATE THE
ACTIONS ON THE TWO ERAF ITEMS
THAT PRESERVE REVENUES FOR CORE
SERVICES FOR IMPACTED COUNTIES,
FINALLY, CSAC IS REVIEWING THE
IMPACT THAT THE PROPOSAL TO
SHIFT THE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM TO THE STATE HIGHWAY
ACCOUNT COULD HAVE FOR COUNTIES.
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
JULIET TERRY. I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CHILD CARE RESOURCE
CENTER. WE ARE PROUD MEMBERS OF
THE COALITION. I FIRST WANT TO
START BY EXPRESSING OUR
GRATITUDE TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
IN PARTICULAR, THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS FOR THEIR FIRM
COMMITMENT TO SEEING THROUGH THE
PROMISE OF 200,000 CHILD CARE
SLOTS AND REMOVING THAT
INDEFINITE PAUSE ON THOSE
SPACES, AS WELL AS THE
COMMITMENT TO NOT DRAW BACK ANY
FUNDING THAT WAS ALREADY AWARDED
FOR GENERAL CHILD CARE. 11,000
SPACES, WE'RE REALLY ENCOURAGING
THE LEGISLATURE AS YOU WORK ON
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR
THE ADOPTION OF THE ALTERNATIVE
METHODOLOGY FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDER RATES, THAT IT INCLUDES
A VERY CLEAR TIMELINE FOR THE
FULL IMPLEMENTATION RATE. SO
THAT THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO
CHANCE FOR A DROP IN RATES THAT
WERE EFFECTIVELY REDUCE PROVIDER
RATES BY 25 TO 30% AND PUSH THEM
TO RATES THAT ARE BASED ON A
DECADE OLD MARKET RATE SURVEY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HELLO.
BUENAS TARDES, MARIA ROMO WITH
CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER. I
WANT TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUE
JULIET'S SENTIMENTS, BUT I ALSO
WANT TO EXPRESS AN ENTHUSIASTIC
THANK YOU FOR, REVERTING THE
34.8 MILLION UNSPENT EMERGENCY
CHILD CARE BRIDGE FUNDING AND
REAPPROPRIATING THE LAST YEAR'S
30 MILLION UNSPENT FUNDING, AND
ROLLING IT OVER TO THIS FISCAL
YEAR, THE EMERGENCY CHILD CARE
BRIDGE PROGRAM IS ONE OF THE
STATE'S MOST CRITICALLY NEEDED
PROGRAMS. THAT CLOSES A TIMING
AND SERVICES GAP FOR FOSTER
YOUTH AND THEIR FAMILIES. LAST
YEAR ALONE, THE BRIDGE PROGRAM
WAS ABLE TO PROVIDE HELP FOR
2934 FAMILIES, AND THEY
REPRESENTED AND BROUGHT WITH
THEM 3936 CHILDREN. THIS IS IN
ADDITION TO THE OVER 9000
CHILDREN THAT THIS PROGRAM
ALREADY SERVICES. WE WANT TO
THANK YOU VERY KINDLY FOR
PROTECTING THE BRIDGE PROGRAM
AND FOR YOUR COMMITTED SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MY NAME IS KIM
DELFINO, AND I'M REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA AUDUBON DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE, CALIFORNIA TROUT,
TROUT UNLIMITED, MOJAVE DESERT
LAND TRUST, SONOMA LAND TRUST,
AND THE POWER OF NATURE
COALITION. THAT IS, 300
ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE STATE
DEDICATED TO THE 30 BY 30
EFFORT. I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR AND
SENATOR LAIRD FOR FLAGGING THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND. ALSO,
SENATOR DOLLY IN SUB TWO. YOUR
COMMENTS WERE WELL NOTED, ON A
PERSONAL NOTE, 34 YEARS AGO, I
STARTED MY, CONSERVATION CAREER
GATHERING SIGNATURES FOR
PROPOSITION 117 AS AN INTERN FOR
THE MOUNTAIN LION FOUNDATION.
AND OVER THE 30 YEARS I'VE
WATCHED THE HABITAT CONSERVATION
FUND, PROTECT THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF ACRES, WETLANDS IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY, LANDS UP IN
THE SIERRA NEVADA, COASTAL
PROJECTS, THE DESERT. THERE'S NO
PART OF THIS STATE THAT HAS NOT
BEEN TOUCHED BY THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND. THROUGH THOSE
30 YEARS, THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND HAS PROVIDED
STEADY, DEDICATED AND RELIABLE
FUNDING FOR NATURAL RESOURCE
PROJECTS THROUGH UP TIMES IN THE
ECONOMY AND DOWN TIMES. IT IS
UNPRECEDENTED TO BE PULLING $45
MILLION OF GENERAL FUND OUT OF
THE HCF, AND IT IS INCONSISTENT
WITH THE TERMS OF PROPOSITION
117. AND SO WE URGE YOU, WE
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A TOUGH
BUDGET YEAR, BUT WE DO BELIEVE
THIS ACTION IS INCONSISTENT WITH
117 AND DEPRIVES THE STATE FROM
A CRITICAL FUNDING SOURCE. AND
WE WOULD URGE IN THE FINAL
BUDGET THAT YOU RESCIND THIS
ACTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHRISTINE SMITH
WITH HEALTH ACCESS, CALIFORNIA
HEALTH ACCESS APPRECIATES THE
LEGISLATURE'S REJECTION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S UNJUST
ELIMINATION OF IHSS BENEFITS
TARGETED AT UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS, CONTINUING THE
GOAL FOR ALL TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THIS ESSENTIAL CARE. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE'S
CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO PROTECT
THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE PENALTY
FUNDS COLLECTED FROM THE
UNINSURED. WE SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATURE'S REJECTION OF THE
ONGOING SWEEPING OF 109 MILLION
ANNUALLY IN FAVOR OF A ONE TIME
LOAN, FUNDS COLLECTED FROM THOSE
WHO ARE UNINSURED SHOULD BE
PRESERVED TO MAKE COVERAGE MORE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE FOR
ALL, INCLUDING THE OVER HALF A
MILLION UNINSURED UNDOCUMENTED
WHO ARE EXCLUDED FROM THE
COVERED CALIFORNIA MARKETPLACE.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, TASHA
NEWMAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF LAND
TRUSTS, REPRESENTING LAND TRUSTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA, WE ARE
HERE TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
PROPOSED CUT OF $45 MILLION TO
THE HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND,
WHICH WE BELIEVE REQUIRES A 4/5
VOTE PURSUANT TO PROP 117, WHICH
WAS PASSED BY VOTERS IN 1990,
THIS FUNDING IS CRITICAL, AS
MANY PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY SPOKEN
TO BEFORE ME. THIS FUNDING IS
CRITICAL FOR LAND TRUST WORK
ACROSS THE STATE. IT'S CRITICAL
FOR ACHIEVING 30 BY 30 AND OUR
CLIMATE RESILIENCE GOALS. SO WE
WOULD REALLY STRONGLY LIKE TO
PUSH BACK ON THE REVERSION AND
HOPE THAT THIS FUNDING CAN BE
PROTECTED IN THE FINAL BUDGET.
THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR AND
SENATORS TERRY BRENNAN, ON
BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA, THE
CHAIRMAN DID A REALLY GOOD JOB
OF EXPLAINING THE BALANCE,
TRYING TO BE STRUCK WITH THIS
BUDGET OF TEMPORARY
INCONVENIENCE FOR SOME OF THE
WEALTHIEST CORPORATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA IN ORDER TO PROTECT
THE MOST VULNERABLE. AND WE
APPLAUD THOSE EFFORTS AND
ENCOURAGE YOU TO STAY STRONG IN
YOUR NEGOTIATIONS TO COME. AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. IT INCLUDES PROTECTING THE
$25 AN HOUR FOR THE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS THAT YOU ADOPTED A YEAR
AGO, PROTECTING HOME CARE
WORKERS, PROTECTING THE
CONTRACTS WITH THE CHILD CARE
WORKERS AND YOUR PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND FOR THAT, WE THANK YOU. MR.
CHAIR, MEMBERS TIM MADDEN,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS. WE'RE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S ACTIONS AROUND THE
MCO TAX LOOKING SPECIFICALLY AT
THE REMAINING ACTIONS AROUND THE
2425 YEAR, WHICH IS THE $200
MILLION. WE WOULD REQUEST THAT
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS BE INCLUDED
IN THAT $200 MILLION. WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE NOT ONLY THE DELAYS
AND THE MCO TAX, BUT ALSO SOME
OTHER CUTS IN THE HEALTH CARE
SPACE, WE'RE WORRIED THAT THE
THERE WILL BE AN INCREASED
TRAFFIC COMING INTO THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT. AND AS A
REMINDER, EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS
SEE ALL PATIENTS COMING INTO THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT, REGARDLESS
OF THEIR ABILITY TO PAY OR THEIR
INSURANCE STATUS. AND IT ALSO
IMPACTS ALL CALIFORNIANS, THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. HI. KATIE
HARDIMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. JUST WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
LISTENING TO THE CONCERNS AROUND
PROPOSITION 98, WE SUPPORT A
PACKAGE THAT PROTECTS THE
INTEGRITY OF PROP 98 AND
PREVENTS CUTS TO THE CLASSROOM
AND LONG TERM FUNDING FOR PROP
98. SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK.
GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR MEMBERS
ELMER LOZADA HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION. WE
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
WORK ON THE BUDGET PROPOSAL THIS
YEAR, ESPECIALLY WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A FEW KEY ITEMS THAT
ARE OF HIGH IMPORT TO US, WE
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
INCLUSION OF BUDGET LANGUAGE,
FOR HEALTH CARE, FOR STRIKING
WORKERS, AS WELL AS LANGUAGE ON
THE EXPEDITED HIRING AT THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE TO
ENSURE ADEQUATE LABOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT. WE ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE RESTORATION OF
FUNDS FOR UC LABOR CENTERS, AS
WELL AS THE UCLA LATINO POLITICS
AND POLICY INSTITUTE. WE WANT TO
THANK YOU AS WELL FOR THE
RESTORING OF THE PROPOSED CUTS
TO HIGH ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS, WHICH ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT, AND
FINALLY, WE WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR WORKING TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH, OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE. AND FIGHTING AGAINST
THE CUTS THAT WERE PROPOSED
THERE. SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK THERE. AND WE, THANK YOU
FOR VALUING WORKER VOICES AS YOU
CONTINUE YOUR NEGOTIATIONS.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MICHELLE UNDERWOOD, ON BEHALF OF
THE COALITION FOR ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION,
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND MORE THAN 40
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION WHO ARE AWAITING
RECEIPT OF THIS YEAR'S INCLUSIVE
EARLY EDUCATION EXPANSION
PROGRAM, THOSE GRANTS ARE BEING
PROPOSED TO BE CLAWED BACK TO
BACKFILL THE RAINY DAY FUND, AS
A SMALL EXAMPLE OF SOME OF THE
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY OFFICES
THAT ARE AWAITING THESE FUNDS,
COUNTY OFFICES SUCH AS ALAMEDA,
MONTEREY, ORANGE, SAN DIEGO, SAN
FRANCISCO, SAN LUIS OBISPO, SAN
MATEO, SANTA CLARA, SANTA CRUZ,
STANISLAUS, AND SOME OF THE
LARGER DISTRICTS LIKE WEST
COVINA AND STOCKTON UNIFIED FOR
LESS THAN $200 MILLION. THESE
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY OFFICES AND
THESE GRANTEES WILL BE ABLE TO
CREATE INCLUSIVE PRESCHOOL
ENVIRONMENTS SO PRESCHOOLERS
WITH DISABILITIES CAN LEARN AND
PLAY AND GROW ALONGSIDE THEIR
TYPICAL PEERS. THESE ARE
INCLUSIVE SETTINGS. THESE GRANTS
ARE AWAITING AWARDEES, SO WE
WANT TO AS THE STATE SUSPENDS
PROPOSITION 98 AND HAS THE
VARIOUS MANEUVERS TO KEEP CUTS
AWAY FROM THE CLASSROOM, WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
INCLUSIVE PRESCHOOL SETTINGS ARE
ALSO MAINTAINED AND THESE
PRESCHOOLERS WITH DISABILITIES
ARE NOT HARMED. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MISTER CHAIR. VICE
CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS OSCAR GARCIA, VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
HISPANIC CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE.
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO, TO THANK
YOU ON BEHALF OF THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF SMALL BUSINESSES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. AS YOU
KNOW, THIS TAP ASSISTANCE, THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
THROUGH THE SBDC NETWORK,
ASSISTS THE SMALL BUSINESSES TO
THRIVE, TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES, TO CREATE JOBS, TO
BRING REVENUE TO THE STATES, TO
THE MUNICIPALITIES AND THE
COMMUNITIES. THESE BUSINESSES
REALLY NEED THIS HELP. AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU AND I WILL PLEAD
WITH YOU THAT TO CONTINUE THE
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM, THIS
PROGRAM IS ESSENTIAL. THE SMALL
BUSINESSES IS THE SMALL ENGINE
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
OUR COMMUNITY AND FOR OUR
ECONOMY. SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ON BEHALF OF THOSE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF BUSINESSES, IN
CALIFORNIA, THANK YOU. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, I'M JORDAN LINDSAY WITH
THE ARC OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
ARC UNITED, UNITED CEREBRAL
PALSY CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION
AND THE LANTERMAN COALITION. AND
WE JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
AND EXTEND OUR GRATITUDE TO THE
WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE AND WHAT
IS IN THIS AGREEMENT. AND
PROTECTING INVESTMENTS FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
AND THEIR WORKFORCE. WE HAVE
FELT UNWAVERING SUPPORT. THIS
COMMUNITY HAS FELT UNWAVERING
SUPPORT OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
FROM THE LEGISLATURE. BOTH
HOUSES, BOTH SIDES AND WE WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU FOR THAT,
SENATOR SKINNER, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
COMMUNITY, SENATOR MENGIBAR,
THANK YOU FOR THE INCREDIBLE
WORK AND MEMBERS OF THAT
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR THE INCREDIBLE
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR, MR. VICE
CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
JIM FRAZIER, THE ARC OF
CALIFORNIA AND UNITED CEREBRAL
PALSY COLLABORATIVE, OUTSTANDING
WORK. THANK YOU. I CAN'T THANK
YOU ENOUGH FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THIS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR A
POPULATION IS SO DEPENDENT ON
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT. YOU CANNOT
BELIEVE AFTER YEARS OF RATE
FREEZES, CUTS. SENATOR SKINNER
HAD MENTIONED THE DETRIMENT THAT
HAS DONE TO MANY PEOPLE. WE LOST
OVER 7000 PROVIDERS FROM 2012 TO
2019. TÍNH 7000 PROVIDERS. WE
LOST DSPS, THE DIRECT SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS WHO PROVIDE THE
DAY TO DAY SERVICES THAT OUR
PEOPLE ARE SO DEPENDENT ON. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I ASK, AND
AGAIN, I THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
FOR REJECTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL, BUT THAT WE WORK
TOWARDS A SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
MECHANISM SO WE DON'T HAVE THIS
CONTINUAL ROLLER COASTER,
SOMEWHAT LIKE WHAT WE DID WITH
SB ONE, THE ONLY ONE THAT REALLY
DIDN'T LIKE SB ONE WAS MR.
NEWMAN. HE AND I'M NOT TRYING TO
BE FLIP, BUT WE NEED TO HAVE A
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING MECHANISM IN
PLACE TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS
POPULATION ON A REGULAR BASIS
AND BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROVIDE THE SERVICES. THE
LANTERMAN ACT WAS ENACTED IN
1969 AND WAS GUARANTEEING THE
CARE OF THESE INDIVIDUALS. WE
JUST DIDN'T SAY HOW. WELL, LET'S
IMPROVE ON THAT. THANK YOU. I'M
SHORT. GOOD AFTERNOON, VICE
CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. MY GOOD FRIEND,
SENATOR EGGMAN. THANK YOU FOR
ALL THAT YOU DO TO SUPPORT THIS
GREAT STATE OF OURS. MY NAME IS
LES FONG. I'M DIRECTOR OF THE
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTER FOR SAN JOAQUIN, AMADOR,
CALAVERAS AND ALPINE COUNTIES,
VERY RURAL COUNTIES. AND I
WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR KEEPING
THAT TAP BUDGET IN PLACE,
BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING TO FIND
THAT IT'S A TREMENDOUS RETURN ON
YOUR INVESTMENT. PRIME EXAMPLE
IS ONE OF OUR SMALL PROGRAMS
THAT WE DID, WE ACTUALLY
CERTIFIED 71 SMALL BUSINESSES AS
EITHER MINORITY, DISADVANTAGED,
WOMEN OWNED VETERAN OWNED,
BUSINESSES. AND THIS IS IN A
FOUR MONTH PERIOD UTILIZING OUR
ADVISING NUTS. TWO OF THEM ARE
ACTUALLY EIGHT OF THEM ACTUALLY
GOT THE SBA EIGHT A
CERTIFICATION, WHICH IS THE HOLY
GRAIL OF CERTIFICATIONS, ONE OF
THEM GOT A CONTRACT WITH THE
PORT OF STOCKTON. ANOTHER ONE
WITH THE SACRAMENTO AIRPORT. AND
AGAIN, IT'S BECAUSE OF PROGRAMS
LIKE THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM THAT WE'RE ABLE TO HELP
SMALL BUSINESSES ACTUALLY
ACHIEVE THEIR DREAMS. AND OF
THESE 70 ODD COMPANIES IN THIS,
LAST FOUR MONTHS, 51 ARE BRAND
NEW STARTUPS. SO ANYWAY, THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THE STATE. AND WE
APPRECIATE ALL THAT YOU DO. GOOD
AFTERNOON SIR. YEE LEE ALEX,
DIRECTOR OF SACRAMENTO VALLEY
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTER SBDC. MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SAID IT ALL. TECH PROGRAM WORKS
FOR EVERY DOLLAR OF TAP.
SUCCESSFUL BUSINESSES PUT BACK 2
TO 10 TIMES THE AMOUNT OF
DOLLARS INTO THE STATE'S
ECONOMY. THIS ISN'T A BUDGET
ITEM. TAP FUNDING IS A WAY TO
BUILD EQUITABLE ECONOMY. TAP
FUNDING ALSO ALLOWS US TO EXPAND
OUR ABILITY TO CREATE PATHWAYS
FOR EQUITABLE, EQUITABLE
OPPORTUNITY AND WEALTH CREATION
THROUGH ENTREPRENEURSHIP FOR THE
VERY UNSEEN POPULATION. AND BY
THAT I MEAN THE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED, THE REFUGEES AND
THE NON-CITIZENS. BECAUSE OF TAP
FUNDING, WE'RE ABLE TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU TO SENATE LEADERSHIP
AND THE MEMBERS OF BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR THEIR SUPPORT
TO RESTORE FULL FUNDING OF THE
TAP PROGRAM. A SPECIAL THANKS
GOES OUT TO SENATOR PADILLA,
SENATOR NHIÀU, AND SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS FOR BELIEVING
IN THIS PROGRAM. THANK YOU. HI,
I'M DARREN OTTO WITH CAMEO
NETWORK, A NETWORK MADE UP OF
400 MISSION DRIVEN BUSINESS
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
PROVIDE VERY SMALL BUSINESSES
WITH LOANS AND BUSINESS
COACHING. THANKS TO THE ENTIRE
LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR INVESTMENT
IN THE SMALL BUSINESS ECOSYSTEM
THAT MAKES UP CAMEO'S
MEMBERSHIP. THE $23 MILLION FOR
OFFICE OF THE BUSINESS ADVOCATES
TAP PROGRAM IS USED TO HELP
BUSINESSES START AND GROW. THE
INVESTMENTS RESULT IN JOBS AND
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY, AND HELPS
FAMILIES BUILD WEALTH. THIS, IN
TURN CREATES SALES TAX AND
PERSONAL INCOME TAX REVENUE FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE TAP
PROGRAM IS A NET POSITIVE IN
CALIFORNIA'S BOTTOM LINE. THANK
YOU ALL FOR TAKING THE ACTION TO
SUPPORT SMALL BUSINESSES. HI,
I'M CLAUDIA VIDAK: AND I
REPRESENT THE NOW 21 WOMEN'S
BUSINESS CENTERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO THANK THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEES. SENATOR
WIENER AND I PARTICULARLY WANT
TO THANK SENATOR NANCY SKINNER
AND ALL OF THE WOMEN IN THE
WOMEN'S LEDGE CAUCUS THAT HAVE
SUPPORTED THE RESTORATION OF OUR
TAP FUNDING. SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR REALIZING THAT WOMEN
ARE LEADING THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY OF CALIFORNIA, AND THAT
THE TAP FUNDS, AS SMALL AS THEY
WERE, ONLY 13 MILLION FOR ALL OF
THE SMALL BUSINESS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS THAT YOU'VE HEARD FROM
EARLIER HAVE REALLY MADE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE. ONE OF THOSE
DIFFERENCES HAS BEEN IN CREATING
MORE CHILDCARE BUSINESSES, AND
YOU'RE GOING TO BE HEARING FROM
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES VERY
SHORTLY ON THAT. THANK YOU AGAIN
. GOOD AFTERNOON, EVERYONE.
THANK YOU, CHAIR, AND TO THE
COMMITTEES OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HERE. MY NAME IS
SOPHIA CANNON, AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR FOR THE WOMEN'S
BUSINESS CENTER HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. AND I'M JUST COMING
HERE TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
YOUR 100% SUPPORT FOR TAP
FUNDING. I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
CRUCIAL IT IS TO SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS, ESPECIALLY WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESS OWNERS. THE TAP FUNDING
ALLOWS US TO NOT ONLY MAINTAIN
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS,
BUT IT ALSO ALLOWS US TO
MAINTAIN SPECIALIZED PROGRAMS
SUCH AS CHILD CHILDCARE,
ENTREPRENEURSHIP PROGRAMS, WHICH
MANY. WE HAVE GRADUATED OVER 40
STUDENTS AND WE HAVE OPENED UP
OVER 300 CHILD CARE SLOTS IN THE
PAST YEAR. AND SO AGAIN, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
TAP FUNDING. AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO SHOWING YOU ALL THE GREAT
THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING WITH IT.
GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR. VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS AND STAFF. MY NAME
IS DANIELLE MARSHALL. I'M A
CONSULTANT WITH THE WOMEN'S
BUSINESS CENTER AND A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER MYSELF. JUST
ASKED HERE TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
MAINTAINING THOSE TAP FUNDS.
JUST A LITTLE BIT ABOUT SOME OF
THE PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO SUSTAIN AND HOPEFULLY
WILL MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS
FUNDING, BEING MAINTAINED. WE
HAVE ASSISTED ACTUALLY WITH OVER
350 FAMILIES WITH HAVING
ADEQUATE QUALITY LICENSED CHILD
CARE. SO OVER 350 FAMILIES WHO
ARE ABLE TO GO TO WORK AND
SCHOOL AS NECESSARY. WE HAVE
ASSISTED WITH CREATING OVER 70
SMALL AND MICRO BUSINESSES WHO
HAVE EITHER STARTED FROM SCRATCH
OR EXPANDED THEIR OPERATIONS.
WE'VE CREATED SUSTAINABLE JOBS,
AND EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES AND URBAN,
RURAL AND SUBURBAN COMMUNITIES.
AND LAST BUT CERTAINLY NOT
LEAST, AS AN AIR FORCE VETERAN
MYSELF, WE HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT IN THE MILITARY
MICROCOSMS AND ASSISTING SPOUSES
AND VETERAN WOMEN WITH STARTING
THEIR OWN CHILD CARE
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL, TO
PROVIDE QUALITY CARE FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE SERVED OR ARE CURRENTLY
SERVING, AND THOSE WHO ARE,
SUBJECT TO GO INTO THE THEATER
AT ANY GIVEN TIME. SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. AND BEFORE
WE GET TO THE NEXT SPEAKER, I
JUST WANT TO NOTE WE HAVE 13 OUT
OF OUR 19 MEMBERS ARE HERE FOR
ALL STAFF IN THE BUILDING. IF
YOU COULD, START, IDENTIFYING
WHERE YOUR MEMBERS ARE AND
ASSISTING THEM AND COMING DOWN,
TO THE HEARING ROOM TO VOTE, I
SUSPECT WILL BE VOTING WITHIN 10
OR 15 MINUTES. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK SCOTT WIENER FOR ALWAYS
BEING SUPPORTIVE OF CHILD CARE,
MY NAME IS JUNEBUG AND I AM A
PARENT LEADER WITH PARENT VOICES
SAN FRANCISCO CHAPTER. I'M ALSO
A MEMBER OF OUR EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION COALITION, AND WE JUST
REALLY ARE GRATEFUL TO HAVE A
BUDGET THAT WILL MINIMIZE CUTS
TO OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
PROVIDERS, I'M A PARENT WHO
RELIES ON CHILD CARE. WITHOUT
CHILD CARE, I WOULDN'T EVEN BE
HERE TODAY, I HAVE A CHILD WITH
CEREBRAL PALSY WHO ALSO NOT ONLY
DEPENDS ON CHILD CARE, BUT ALSO
DEPENDS ON IHSS. IF WITHOUT
CHILD CARE, I WOULD NOT BE HERE
TODAY, I'M GOING TO SAY THAT
AGAIN. I WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO BE
HERE TODAY TO ADVOCATE FOR OTHER
CHILDREN. I WOULD NOT BE HERE
TODAY TO ASK THAT YOU KEEP THE
PROMISE OF THE 200,000 SPACES. I
WOULDN'T BE HERE TODAY TO SAY
THAT WE NEED TO SUPPORT OUR
PROVIDERS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE NOT JUST A LIVING WAGE, BUT
A WAGE WHERE THEY CAN THRIVE AND
HAVE AN ECONOMIC STABILITY IN
THEIR LIFE. WHEN I WAS A
PROVIDER, I ENDED UP HOMELESS
BECAUSE I COULDN'T MAKE ENOUGH
MONEY AS A PARENT WITHOUT CHILD
CARE, I WANT TO BE ABLE TO WORK
AS A COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER IN
THE IN THE FIELD THAT I DO,
WHERE I'M HELPING TRY TO PREVENT
OVERDOSES AND HELP PEOPLE WITH
HOUSING, AND HELP PEOPLE WITH
HARM REDUCTION. THIS 200,000
SPACES COULD PROVIDE THAT CHILD
WHO'S HOMELESS THAT I HAVE TO
SEE IN THE STROLLER WHERE THEIR
PARENT IS ASKING FOR HARM
REDUCTION SUPPLIES. SO I THINK
OF THAT CHILD. I THINK OF THE
CHILD WHO HAS SPECIAL NEEDS, WHO
REALLY NEEDS THIS CHILD CARE. I
THINK OF ALL THE CHILDREN THAT
ARE FALLING THROUGH THE CRACKS
BECAUSE THEY'RE WAITING FOR
CHILD CARE. WE REALLY CAN'T WAIT
ANY MORE. IN THE FIELD I WORK
IN, I SEE CHILDREN WHO ARE GOING
WITHOUT THE BASIC NEEDS. THEY
NEED TO HAVE A FOUNDATION SO
THEY CAN SUCCEED. CHILD CARE IS
AN INVESTMENT IN OUR SOCIETY. WE
NEED THESE FUNDS. WE NEED THESE
SPACES. OUR CHILDREN CANNOT WAIT
ANYMORE. OUR CHILD CARE KEEPS
CALIFORNIA WORKING. CHILD CARE
KEEPS OUR CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
SAFE. THANK YOU. OKAY. HELLO,
ALL THE SENATE COMMITTEE, MY
NAME IS ELIA FERNANDEZ, AND I'M
A MOTHER AND A GRANDMOTHER OF
SIX GRANDKIDS. AND ONE OF THEM
IS AUTISTIC, AND HE JUST
RECEIVED A DIÆN FOR THE ENTIRE
YEAR. AND AWARD FOR EXCELLENCE
IN ACADEMIC. AND, IN HIS
GRADUATION. AND, ALSO, PLEASE,
IF YOU COULD KEEP THE PROMISE OF
THE $200,000 FOR ALL FOR THE EEC
AND, TO KEEP LIKE THE, LIKE TWO
JUNEBUG SAID EARLIER TO KEEP
THEM ALL SAFE AND WITH CHILD
CARE. THANK YOU. HI, MY NAME IS
NORA SHAHEED FROM PARENT VOICE
OF SAN FRANCISCO. AND PLEASE
KEEP YOUR PROMISE OF THE 200,000
SLOTS FOR CHILD CARE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS MOHAMMED
SHAHEED. I AM A PARENT. VOICES
LEADER OF PARENT VOICES
CALIFORNIA, I'M ALSO HERE TO
SUPPORT THAT. WE ASK THAT YOU
REJECT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
INDEFINITE PAUSE AND INSTEAD
ENACT A TWO YEAR PAUSE WITH THE
TRAILER BILL SPECIFYING THE PLAN
TO REACH OVER 200,000 NEW
SUBSIDIZED SLOTS BY 2028. THANK
YOU. GREAT CALL. JUST GO. DON'T
TOUCH IT. HI. MY NAME IS RJ
SHAHEED FROM PARENT VOICE IN SAN
FRANCISCO, C . PLEASE KEEP YOUR
PROMISE. HI, MY NAME IS APRIL
AND I'M FROM PARENT VOICES SAN
FRANCISCO. I JUST WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY, ESPECIALLY NANCY
SKINNER AND SCOTT WIENER, FOR
ALWAYS MAKING CHILD CARE YOUR
TOP PRIORITY. I KNOW SKINNER,
YOU WERE THERE YESTERDAY WITH US
ON THOSE STEPS AT NIGHT WHEN IT
WAS REALLY HOT. BUT YOU ALWAYS
SUPPORT US. YOU'RE ALWAYS ON OUR
SIDE. AND PLEASE, JUST, KEEP THE
PROMISE FOR THE 200,000 SLOTS
FOR CHILD CARE. THANK YOU. I'M
GONNA PUT IT DOWN. YOU CAN PUSH
IT DOWN THERE YOU GO. HELLO. I
AM FROM SAN FRANCISCO,
CALIFORNIA. PARENT VOICES.
PLEASE KEEP YOUR PROMISE OF WHAT
? WHAT'S YOUR NAME? YOU'RE DOING
GREAT. I'M JOHNNY MCKINLEY, AND
FOR 200,000 SLOTS AND THANK YOU,
NANCY SKINNER AND SCOTT WIENER.
THANK YOU. AND GO, GIANTS! GO,
GIANTS! GIANTS HI. MY NAME IS
EDUARDO DE. I'M WITH PARENT
VOICES SAN FRANCISCO, SO PLEASE
KEEP YOUR PROMISE. THANK YOU.
HI. MY NAME IS JORGE CORONA. I'M
AN ENGINEER AND A MEMBER OF
PARENT VOICES, AND I'M HERE TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT PLEASE KEEP
YOUR PROMISE AND CHILD CARE.
REALLY HAS HELPED ME AND MY
FAMILY BE ABLE TO NOT BEING A
FINANCIAL BURDEN. AND I THINK IT
HELPS OTHER FAMILIES NOT BE IN A
SITUATION WHERE YOU HAVE TO
DECIDE FOR YOUR FAMILY OR NOT TO
HAVE YOUR KID IN CHILD CARE. SO
PLEASE KEEP YOUR PROMISE. HI.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MY NAME IS MARIA
ANDRES. JORGE AND EDUARDO JORGE
IS MY PARTNER AND EDUARDO IS MY
SON. I AM A BUSINESS OWNER
THANKS TO CHILD CARE BECAUSE I
WAS ABLE TO GET TO HIGHER
EDUCATION. I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF
PARENT VOICES SAN FRANCISCO. WE
THANK YOU SENATORS WIENER FOR
ALL YOUR SUPPORT AND FOR ALSO
REPRESENTING US IN SAN
FRANCISCO. MISS NANCY SKINNER,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TALKING
YESTERDAY WITH US. SPEAKING
REGARDING CHILD CARE IS NOT ONLY
, NECESSARY, BUT IT'S ESSENTIAL.
ESSENTIAL FOR PARENTS LIKE ME
THAT ARE NOW WERE ABLE TO GIVE
BACK TO OUR COMMUNITY. BUT ALSO
TO BRING AND UPLIFT THE ECONOMY
OF THIS COUNTRY. WE NEED TO STOP
THE NARRATIVE REGARDING FAMILIES
AND WE NEED TO PROVIDE
PROVIDERS. I HAD AMAZING
PROVIDERS LIVING AND ACCEPTING
MY SUBSIDY BECAUSE THEY WANTED
ME TO SUCCEED. WE SHOULD NOT BE
PUT IN THIS BUDGET UNDER THE. WE
SHOULD NOT BE ACCEPTING MORE
CUTS FOR THESE, CHILD CARE IS
ESSENTIAL FOR US. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR. MY
NAME IS ELVIA MCKINLEY, AND I AM
A PARENT LEADER, I HAVE TWO JOBS
TO PROVIDE FOR MY FAMILY, I LIVE
IN SAN FRANCISCO, AND ONE OF THE
JOBS I STARTED AT 4 A.M. SO,
CHILD CARE IS ESSENTIAL FOR ME
AND MY FAMILY TO SURVIVE, I WANT
TO ASK, CAN YOU PLEASE KEEP THE
PROMISE OF 200,000 SPACES,
ENSURE PROVIDERS ARE PAID FOR
THE ACTUAL COST OF CARE, IMPROVE
ACCESS TO Â NOW, AND ENSURE
FUNDS BUDGETED FOR Â S¼ STAY IN
Â. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
COMMITTEE AND ESPECIALLY THE
CHAIR OF THE BUDGET, SENATOR
SCOTT WIENER, AND THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS, AND
ALSO, SENATOR MENGIBAR, WHO'S
HEARD ALL OF US BEFORE, WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU MINIMIZING
THE IMPACT OF THIS BUDGET
DEFICIT TO FAMILIES. AND TRYING
TO MAKE IT WORK AND ESPECIALLY
PROTECT THE MOST, IN NEED AND
LIKE THE CHILDREN SAID, WE
REALLY APPRECIATE KEEPING THE
PROMISE. AND WE HOPE THAT WHEN
YOU NEGOTIATE WITH WITH THE
GOVERNOR, THAT THE BUDGET THAT
YOU WORK SO HARD ON, WILL BE THE
ONE THAT WE WILL SEE, CHILD CARE
KEEPS CALIFORNIA WORKING. IT'S
REALLY VALUABLE. EVEN. I'VE BEEN
AN ORGANIZER OF VOICES FOR THE
LAST 28 YEARS, AND WE'VE SEEN
THE DIFFERENT FIGHTS, AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU DO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. KIM ROTHSCHILD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES FOR IN-HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES, GRATEFUL
FOR THE REJECTION OF THE
ELIMINATION OF THE IHSS SERVICES
FOR THE UNDOCUMENTED FOLKS AND
VERY APPRECIATIVE FOR THE
RESTORATION OF THE BACKUP
PROVIDER PROGRAM. THIS IS A LIFE
SAVING, PROGRAM IN PLACE FOR
MANY OF THOSE WHO ARE,
CAREGIVERS, DO NOT SHOW UP OR
ARE LEAVING A HOSPITAL AND NEED
SOME SHORT TERM CARE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX
TORRES HERE ON BEHALF OF THE NEW
CALIFORNIA COALITION, WHICH
COUNTS OVER 700 ETHNIC LOCAL
REGIONAL CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
AS PARTNER ORGS, ALSO ON BEHALF
OF THE BAY AREA COUNCIL, QUICKLY
WANT TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY ON THE NET
NET OPERATING LOSS PROVISIONS,
BUT LOOK FORWARD TO THE
ENGAGEMENT ON THE BUSINESS TAX
CREDITS LANGUAGE. ALSO WANT TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE TAP
PROVISIONS AS WELL FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES, ALSO WANT TO CALL
ATTENTION TO SENATOR WIENER. YOU
NOTED THE RESPONSIBLE BUDGETING
DONE TO MITIGATE THE SCOPE AND
QUANTITY OF THE TOUGH DECISIONS
IN THIS BUDGET. SO WANT TO MAKE
SURE I EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
RAISING OF THE CAP ON THE RAINY
DAY FUNDS FROM 10% TO 20, AND
THE EXCLUSION OF DEPOSITS INTO
THE RAINY DAY FUND FROM THE
STATE APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT SO
THAT THE STATE IS NOT
CONSTITUTIONALLY DISINCENTIVIZED
FROM INCREASING ITS RESERVES TO
PROTECT AGAINST FUTURE
DOWNTURNS. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND AMEN TO THAT. MR. CHAIR,
VICE CHAIR OF TONY SIMONS. I'M
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN INDIAN
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, AN
ORGANIZATION THAT'S DEDICATED TO
SERVING TRIBES, TRIBAL
ENTERPRISES AND ENTREPRENEURS OF
AMERICAN INDIAN, ALASKA NATIVE
AND HAWAIIAN NATIVE, WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FIRST FOR REJECTING
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO CUT
THE SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. IT'S A
PROGRAM THAT WE USE IN ORDER FOR
OUR APEX ACCELERATOR. IT'S THE
ONLY AMERICAN INDIAN FOCUSED
ACCELERATOR HELPING SMALL
BUSINESSES ACCESS GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTING. WE WOULD ALSO ASK,
HOWEVER, AS YOU LOOK AT TRAILER
BILLS AND YOU CONSIDER HOW YOU
WOULD BE LOOKING AT THE FUNDING
FOR THE CALIFORNIA JOBS FIRST,
WE RECOGNIZE IT'S A VERY TOUGH
BUDGET YEAR. WE WANT TO RAISE
THE ISSUE THAT TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN WAITING
FOR THEIR SHARE OF THE
CALIFORNIA JOBS FIRST FUNDING.
THERE'S BEEN THREE PRIOR FUNDING
ROUNDS FOR FUNDING THAT HAS GONE
STATEWIDE A PILOT, A PLANNING
GRANT, AND AN IMPLEMENTATION
FUND FOR PRE-DEVELOPMENT. BUT
NONE OF THOSE FUNDS HAVE BEEN
DEDICATED FOR TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES. TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN TOLD TO GET READY, GET
READY TO APPLY AND WE ASK THAT
YOU CONSIDER THAT AND THAT AS WE
LOOK AT HOW WE IMPLEMENT THE
CUTS THAT ARE NECESSARY, WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT YOU DON'T
TAKE THEM FROM ONE OF THE MOST,
MOST DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU. MONICA KIRKLAND,
STATE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR SENIOR
SERVICES COALITION OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY, WE JUST WANTED TO THANK
ON BEHALF OF THE 39
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE 89,000
OLDER ADULTS THAT WE SERVICE, WE
WANT TO THANK SENATOR WIENER AND
THE ENTIRE BUDGET, STAFF AND
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR HARD WORK AND
JUST SPECIFICALLY FOR YOUR
REJECTIONS AND THE CUTS TO HOME
SAFE AND TO ALSO APS, IHS CUTS
FOR UNDOCUMENTED AND ALSO FOR
THE, CAREER PATHWAYS PROGRAM, AS
WELL AS FOR THE OLDER CALIFORNIA
ACT MODERNIZATION FOR AS IT
RELATES TO NUTRITION. SO WE JUST
WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
AND I ALSO WANTED TO THANK
SENATOR MENGIBAR AND THE SUB
THREE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
ATTENTION TO DETAIL. YOUR CARE
AND JUST PROTECTING THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME
IS AARON WOOLLEY. I'M HERE
DESIGNING SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA, I WANT TO FIRST
THANK THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND OF SUB TWO FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUPPORT OF THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND. WE
ARE REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
REVERSION OF $45 MILLION THAT'S
IN THIS BUDGET FROM THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND, WHICH IS
PROVIDED A RELIABLE SOURCE OF
FUNDING OVER THE PAST 30 YEARS
TO DO CONSERVATION ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. MAINTAINING THIS
FUNDING NOW AND IN THE FUTURE IS
IMPORTANT TO MEETING OUR CLIMATE
RESILIENCY AND 30 BY 30 GOALS
AND THE COMMITMENTS THAT THE
STATE HAS MADE TO BIODIVERSITY,
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED THAT THIS
REVERSION IS A CONTRARY TO THE
LANGUAGE IN PROP 117. SO WE URGE
YOU TO REJECT THIS IN THE FINAL
BUDGET. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
CAMERON DIMITRI WITH CAPITAL
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION. JUST APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE AND
THE STAFF THAT HAVE DONE TO PUT
TOGETHER THIS BUDGET, FROM THE
RETAILERS PERSPECTIVE, WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THE ELIMINATION OF
THE BAD DEBT DEDUCTION. WE
BELIEVE THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
IN AB 167 ACTUALLY GO BACK AND
MAKE IT MORE CHALLENGING THAN
THE INITIALLY PROPOSED WORK IN
THE ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET. WE
THINK THAT DUE TO THE CHANGES,
ESPECIALLY RELATED TO THE
EFFECTS WOULD GO INTO THE LAW IN
2028. THAT ACTUALLY DOESN'T
REFLECT THE WAY THAT RETAILERS
DO THEIR FINANCING CONTRACTS.
AND SO WE ASKED FOR THIS
ELIMINATION TO BE, TO BE
REINSTATED AND APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, RICO
MASTRODONATO AT THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND, AND I WANT TO ALIGN
MY COMMENTS WITH MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE ALREADY
SPOKEN ABOUT THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND, AND I WON'T
REPEAT ANYTHING THAT THEY SAID.
I DO WANT TO THANK SENATOR BLAKE
SPEAR AND LAIRD AND SENATOR DALI
AND SUBCOMMITTEE FOR THEIR
SUPPORT AND ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS PROGRAM.
WE USED TO THINK THIS WAS A
BUDGET PROOF PROGRAM, AND WE
HOPED THAT IT STILL IS. IT
REALLY HAS BEEN THERE THROUGH
THICK AND THIN, AND IT WOULD BE
A REAL BLOW TO BIODIVERSITY IN
THE STATE TO SEE THIS MONEY
DISAPPEAR. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
MEMBERS NICHOLAS HACKETT ON
BEHALF OF SOCIAL COMPASSION IN
LEGISLATION AND COURTESY FOR
ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE FUND TODAY,
AS WELL, I JUST WANT TO ECHO
EVERYONE'S COMMENTS ON THE,
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND,
REVERSION, PLEASE, YOU KNOW,
OPPOSE THAT, AGAIN, ALSO WANT TO
THANK SENATOR BLAKE SPARE
SENATOR DALI, SENATOR LAIRD FOR
STANDING UP FOR THIS, REVERSION
AGAINST THIS REVERSION. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT, GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR MEMBERS JANICE O'MALLEY
WITH AFSCME CALIFORNIA. I
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
COMMITTEE, ON TRYING TO FIND
SOLUTIONS FOR A BAD BUDGET YEAR.
JUST WANT TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS
MADE BY OUR AFSCME AFFILIATE, UW
LOCAL 3930, ON IHSS AND
CHILDCARE, THANK YOU. SUB THREE.
AND SENATOR MENGIBAR FOR YOUR
WORK ON SUPPORTING THE
WORKFORCE. AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND CAL WORKS, APPRECIATE THE
PRESERVATION OF THE èC LABOR
FUNDING AND THANK YOU, SENATOR
WAHAB, FOR YOUR BOLD APPROACH ON
CDCR AND LISTENING TO FRONTLINE
WORKERS IN THE AGENCY PROVIDING
MEDICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH CARE
AND REHABILITATIVE SERVICES BY
REJECTING CONTINUED
PRIVATIZATION OF JOBS, WHILE
ALSO BALANCING THE PRESERVATION
OF REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMING. WE
DO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
ELIMINATION OF STATE VACANT
POSITIONS AND WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE DECISIONS ARE MADE IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE EXCLUSIVE
BARGAINING REPRESENTATIVES, WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE
REJECTING THE TELEWORK STIPEND.
TBL AND RESPECTING THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS.
LASTLY WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE RESPECTED THE
NEGOTIATED AGREEMENT ON THE MCO
TAX AND IN PARTICULAR THE
FUNDING TOWARDS GROUND EMERGENCY
TRANSPORTATION, GOD SPEED ON
NEGOTIATIONS. AND WE HOPE THAT,
THAT THESE, THESE ITEMS THAT YOU
HAD WORKED SO HARD AND TRYING TO
PRESERVE, STAY PUT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR, VICE
CHAIR AND SENATORS, THANK YOU
FOR STAYING HERE AND LISTENING
TO ALL OF US. WE DO APPRECIATE
IT. MY NAME IS KELLY MCMILLAN.
I'M WITH POLITICAL SOLUTIONS AND
I'M REPRESENTING THE MATERNAL
AND CHILD HEALTH ACCESS AND I'M
HERE TO TALK ABOUT ITEM 118 AND
AB 107, WHICH IS THE CUT TO THE
$18 MILLION CUT TO SUPPORT THE
COMMUNITY BASED, HEALTH
ENROLLMENT NAVIGATORS. THE
PROGRAM HAS BEEN AROUND SINCE
2019. IT'S IN 44 COUNTIES, AND
IT PROVIDES MEDI-CAL,
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES, VITAL
HEALTH ACCESS AND COVERAGE AND
ACCESS TO SERVICES. AND IN FACT,
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS, IT'S
PROVIDED OVER 300,000 SERVICES.
THE PROGRAM ALSO HAS A FEDERAL
MATCH OF 50. SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
A $36 MILLION HIT TO THE PROGRAM
, WHICH WILL RESULT IN THOUSANDS
OF LAYOFFS OF THESE HEALTH
NAVIGATORS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SO WE URGE YOU TO RESTORE THE 18
MILLION TO SUPPORT THE HEALTH
NAVIGATORS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
. SHOWS HOLLY FROM ANY DIOCESE
WITH LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA,
EXPRESSING EXTREME
DISAPPOINTMENT, IN THE COMPLETE
ELIMINATION AND ZEROING OUT OF
THE FUNDING FOR THE CAL HOME
PROGRAM, IT WAS THIS HOUSE, TWO
YEARS AGO THAT, GAVE FUNDING FOR
THE FIRST TIME EVER, GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS TOWARD THE TOWARDS
THE ONE AND ONLY PROGRAM IN THE
WHOLE STATE THAT PRODUCES A NEW
UNIT FOR AFFORDABLE HOME
OWNERSHIP. AND THAT'S CAL HOME
$350 MILLION. TWO YEARS AGO, IT
WAS ELIMINATED BY HALF LAST
YEAR. AND IN THIS BUDGET
UNFORTUNATELY $152 MILLION HAS
BEEN COMPLETELY ELIMINATED. SO
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT MAYBE THESE
FINAL DAYS OR WEEKS THAT EVEN A
MILLION, ANY AMOUNT COULD BE
RESTORED TO THAT PROGRAM AND NOT
COMPLETELY ELIMINATED. WE'RE
HOPEFUL. AND TO JUST UNDERSTAND
THE IMPACT THE NEXT NOFA WAS DUE
IN JUNE. IT'S ON HOLD. IT'S ON
HOLD INDEFINITELY. SO IF THE
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS ARE NOT
RESTORED, PLEASE WORK WITH HCD
TO ENSURE THAT THE REMAINING
PROP ONE DOLLARS THAT ARE
REFERENCED IN ALL YOUR ANALYZES
THAT ARE LEFT OVER FROM A
PREVIOUS BOND, PLEASE ENSURE
THAT WHATEVER IS REMAINING DOES
GET OUT AND THAT THIS PROGRAM IS
NOT ON HOLD INDEFINITELY. WE
HOPE WE CAN MAYBE WORK ON SOME
TRAILER LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THAT
THE EXISTING DOLLARS THAT ARE
DESIGNATED FOR CAL HOME DO NOT
GET SWEPT AND MOVED TO ANOTHER
PROGRAM. THERE'S NO GUARANTEE.
SO PLEASE HELP US ENSURE THAT
THAT NOFA GETS OUT THIS YEAR IN
2024 ON BEHALF OF UNITED WAY
GREATER LOS ANGELES, AND WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT IN THE INCOMING
YEARS THAT WE'LL SEE SOME
FUNDING AND GAP FUNDING FOR LA
CASA, THE REGIONAL HOUSING
PROGRAM THAT HAS A WE HAVE A
VOTE GOING TO THE VOTERS IN
NOVEMBER, BUT WE HAVE PROJECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED IN THE
PIPELINE THAT NEED FUNDING. NOW.
WE'RE HOPING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL CONSIDER SOME
GAP FUNDING, AS THEY HAVE FOR
OTHER REGIONAL AGENCIES, TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN GET SOME OF
THOSE PROJECTS FUNDED WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR THAT
INITIATIVE TO PASS. AND LAST BUT
NOT LEAST, ON BEHALF OF FULWELL,
I'M A PILOT PROGRAM FOR
CALFRESH, THE SUPPLEMENTAL FRESH
FRUIT AND VEGETABLE PROGRAM THAT
MANY OF YOU HAVE PILOT PROGRAMS
IN YOUR DISTRICTS THAT WERE SHUT
OFF ON APRIL THE 14TH BECAUSE IT
RAN OUT OF MONEY. WE'RE HOPING
THAT IN THIS BUDGET YEAR, A
FUTURE BUDGET YEARS FOR SURE,
THAT THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM THAT CAN BE TURNED BACK
ON WITH ANY AMOUNT OF MONEY. SO
AGAIN, HOPEFULLY SOME MONEY FOR
THAT CALFRESH PROGRAM WILL BE
RESTORED AS WELL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT,
SEEING NONE, WE'LL CLOSE. PUBLIC
COMMENT. I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE WHO TOOK THE TIME TO
COME OUT TODAY TO SPEAK, AND
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE, WE'VE HAD AMPLE
DISCUSSION BEFORE. IF THERE ARE
ANY FINAL COMMENTS, WE'LL DO
ONE. WE'RE GOING TO DO ONE AT A
TIME. SO, YES, SENATOR CORTEZ,
MR. CHAIR, JUST A SINGLE ITEM.
AND I WAS INVOLVED WITH TWO
OTHER COMMITTEES EARLIER, SO I
COULDN'T MAKE THE COMMENT
EARLIER. AND I'LL BE CONCISE, I
JUST WANT TO NOTE, THAT WHILE I
KNOW UNDER HOUSING, OUR BUDGET,
THIS BUDGET UNDER ITEM 228, GOES
BACK AND DEALS WITH RECENTLY
ENACTED LEGISLATION FUNDING. AND
I APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH, AS
YOU KNOW, MR. CHAIR, THE YEAR
BEFORE THAT, SB 791, WHICH WOULD
, CREATE A CALIFORNIA SURPLUS
LAND UNIT TO FACILITATE
AGREEMENTS BETWEEN LOCAL
AGENCIES AND DEVELOPERS ON
SURPLUS PROPERTIES, WAS ENACTED,
AND THAT'S BEEN DEFUNDED,
ACCORDING TO PAGE 93 OF THE
JOINT BUDGET PLAN. SO, I'LL BE,
YOU KNOW, SUBMITTING A REQUEST
TO RESTORE THAT ASAP WHENEVER
ASAP IS, BUT BUT CLEARLY, IN MY
MIND, WITH THE HOUSING CRISIS,
THE RESTORATION OR THE INCREASE
IN IN TAX CREDITS, MUCH OF WHICH
WOULD BE USED BY EXACTLY THOSE
SURPLUS LAND ENTITIES, LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND SMALL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, IT SEEMS TO BE A
REAL NON-SEQUITUR TO SORT OF
BEEF UP THE TAX CREDITS, WHICH I
ASSUME HCD AND CAL FHA HAVE
SOMETHING TO DO WITH AND AT THE
SAME TIME DECREASE 12 FTE. THAT
WOULD HELP GET THOSE TAX CREDITS
OUT TO THOSE TO THOSE SAME
GOVERNMENTS, SO I JUST WANTED TO
PUT THAT ON THE RECORD.
OBVIOUSLY, I'M SUPPORTING THE
BUDGET OVERALL, BUT THAT WAS
JUST THE ONE ISSUE I HAD ISSUE
WITH. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
THANK YOU, SENATOR, AND WE ARE
LOOKING INTO THAT. SO THANK YOU
FOR RAISING IT WITH US. OKAY.
SEEING NO OTHER SENATOR
BARRASSO. YES JUST VERY QUICKLY,
I WANT TO APPLAUD THE
RESTORATION OF TPS AND CSU
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES, AND
THE IHS, SS, IHS FOR
UNDOCUMENTED. BUT I WANT TO URGE
RESTORING IMMIGRANT CHILDREN,
REPRESENT NATION FUNDING, WE
NEED STABILITY. THERE ARE
ENORMOUS THREATS THAT ARE COMING
DOWN THE LINE, AND THIS IS A
LATINO CAUCUS. PRIORITIES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR. SENATOR
PADILLA, THANK YOU. MR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIRMAN. I
DID INTENTIONALLY RESERVE
COMMENT TO TAKE AFTER WE TOOK
PUBLIC TESTIMONY. AND SO I'LL
JUST TAKE A MINUTE. I WOULD
FIRST ECHO THE PRIORITIES
ARTICULATED BY MY ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES WITH
REGARD TO THE LATINO CAUCUS
PRIORITIES. AND I JUST WANT TO
QUICKLY EXTEND THANKS TO YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP, CERTAINLY,
AGAIN, TO OUR AMAZING BUDGET
STAFF, WITH RESPECT TO THE
OVERALL GENERAL FRAMEWORK OF TWO
PARTY AND WHERE WE'RE AT NOW, I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO JUST
REMEMBER, GENERALLY SPEAKING,
THAT WE WORK DILIGENTLY TO
ADDRESS THE SHIFTING AND UNIQUE
REVENUE DYNAMICS THAT WE DO IN
THIS STATE, WHICH ARE, SHALL WE
SAY, UNIQUE, THAT GREATLY OVER
IMPACT OUR BUDGET, WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME TRYING TO SEEK A MORE
STRATEGIC APPROACH TO HOW WE
ORDER EXPENDITURES IN A WAY THAT
REFLECTS A GOOD RETURN ON
INVESTMENT, WHERE THAT WITH THE
GREATEST IMPACT
PROGRAMMATICALLY, OFTEN THAT
AFFECTS SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE AND UNDERINVESTED
COMMUNITIES AND LEAST EMPOWERED
COMMUNITIES. AND I THINK IT'S
QUITE AN IMPROVEMENT, FRANKLY,
AS AS RESULT OF THE PROCESS. SO
BETTER ALIGNING THOSE
PRIORITIES, STILL FINDING A WAY
TO MAINTAIN A HEALTHY RESERVE,
TO IMPLEMENT SAVINGS AND
REDUCTIONS IN WAYS THAT ARE LESS
IMPACTFUL IN THE WAYS I
DESCRIBED. WANT TO REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK I THINK WE
DID IN MY SUB, PARTICULARLY WITH
PULLING BACK 260 MILLION IN CUTS
TO UNEXPENDED PRIOR ROUNDS OF
HAP TO BE ABLE TO GUARANTEE
AROUND SIX AT A SUBSTANTIALLY
HEALTHY LEVEL, AND NOT TO BE
FORGOTTEN WITH STRINGS THAT WILL
SUBSTANTIALLY STRENGTHEN
OVERSIGHT AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND APPRECIATIVE OF
THE FACT THAT WE WERE ABLE TO,
REJECT AND RESTORE 325 MILLION
IN MULTIFAMILY HOUSING, AGAIN, A
PROGRAM THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY
HAS AN IMPACT STRATEGICALLY ON
FOLKS WHO ARE THE LEAST OFF THE
SAME FOR 250 MILLION AND REAP
2.0 GRANTS AVAILABLE TO AVOID
INTERRUPTING PROJECTS UNDERWAY.
AGAIN, OFTEN IN COMMUNITIES THAT
DON'T HAVE THE INVESTMENT THAT
THEY SHOULD GET. AND TO ECHO
FROM A LOT OF THE TESTIMONY WE
HEARD, CERTAINLY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM TAP, BEING
ABLE TO REJECT THAT REDUCTION
AND HOLD THAT BACK AGAIN. SMALL
BUSINESS OFTEN IN COMMUNITIES
THAT DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO THEM. SO
HAPPY WITH THE DIRECTION, HAPPY
WITH THE WORK AGAIN OF THE
LEADERSHIP AND OF THE STAFF, AND
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
COMMENT. SENATOR MENGIBAR. I WAS
ON THE FENCE, BUT I'M GOING TO
DO IT, I DEFINITELY WANT TO
THANK THE STAFF AND THIS
LEADERSHIP, BECAUSE WE REALLY,
IN THIS TWO PARTY DEAL, CLAWED
BACK A MAJORITY K¾T OF THE CORE
PROGRAMS THAT WERE PROPOSED FOR
CUTS. MY ASK HERE, AND I'VE, YOU
KNOW, TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND ADMINISTRATION IS THAT WE
SHOULD NEVER, EVER HAVE
ADVOCATES CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
THEIR BASIC RIGHTS WHEN WE'RE
DEALING WITH DEFICITS BECAUSE
WHAT WE HAD WERE PEOPLE, TRAVEL
FROM ALL ACROSS THE STATE TO
LITERALLY BEG US TO NOT CUT FOR
THINGS RELATED TO FOSTER CARE,
CHILD CARE, LIKE WE'RE MAKING
OUR MOST VULNERABLE HAVE TO COME
TO US AND BEG US TO NOT CUT
THOSE ISSUES, I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD EVER SEE THAT MOVING
FORWARD. I THINK THE RICH OF THE
RICH SHOULD BE UP HERE BEGGING
FOR US NOT TO CUT THINGS FOR
THEM, AND NOT THE OPPOSITE.
THANK MY COMMITTEE STAFF MEMBERS
FOR THIS, AND REALLY THE
LEADERSHIP FOR REALLY DOUBLING
DOWN AGAINST A LOT OF THESE
CUTS. I'M SO PROUD OF THIS TWO
PARTY DEAL. I'M REALLY PROUD OF
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE'S PLAN HAS
MOVED FORWARD WITH, AND I'M
REALLY HOPEFUL THAT THAT STAYS
AS CLOSE AS POSSIBLE, AS CLOSE
TO IT AS POSSIBLE. AND NEXT
WEEK, MY ONLY CAVEAT TO WHAT I'M
HOPING AND ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
WILL LOOK LIKE WITH Ó COR IS TO
REALLY ENSURE THAT THAT DATA IS
COLLECTED, NOT JUST ONCE SHOULD
HAVE A MORE THAN ONE SO WE CAN
MAKE TWEAKS. WE'RE HAVING DATA
COME TO US SUCH LAST MINUTE THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO FIX THINGS THAT
HAPPENED A YEAR AGO, AND NOW NEW
PROBLEMS ARE ARE ARISING. THAT
WOULD BE MY ONLY THING. AND I
KNOW THAT THOSE CONVERSATIONS
ARE STILL HAPPENING, BUT REALLY
PROUD OF WHAT WE WERE ABLE TO
PRESERVE IN THIS BUDGET. THANK
YOU, SENATOR WAHAB. THANK YOU. I
WANT TO ECHO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS MY COLLEAGUES MADE.
NUMBER ONE, I DO WANT TO THANK
LEADERSHIP ON EVERY SINGLE
BUDGET SUB AS WELL AS OUR CHAIR
AND STAFF WHO HAS BEEN WORKING
ON THIS. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE LÀ LEO'S OFFICE AS WELL AS
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I
KNOW MANY OF YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN
WORKING VERY, VERY HARD INTO THE
NIGHT ABOUT THIS BUDGET, BUT I
DO WANT TO PRIORITIZE A COUPLE
OF THINGS FOR ME WHEN I TAKE A
LOOK AT THE BUDGET. OVERALL, I
AM DEEPLY CONCERNED WITH
EFFICIENCY, AND I THINK THAT
WHEN WE TOUT THAT WE ARE THE
FOURTH OR THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD, AND YET I
CONSTANTLY SEE, ESPECIALLY
REPRESENTING SILICON VALLEY,
INEFFICIENT PROCESSES ACROSS THE
BOARD, ACROSS DEPARTMENTS. THAT
IS A CONCERN FOR ME. RIGHT
RIGHT. WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
APPLICATIONS, WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TECHNOLOGY IMPLEMENTATION,
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ANY OF
THESE THINGS TO MAKE THE JOB
FASTER AND BETTER AND MORE
EFFICIENT TO, AGAIN, THE END
USER, WHICH ARE THE RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA VÀ I KEEP SEEING
PROBLEMS, DELAYS, NUMBER ONE,
OVERSPENDING AND SYSTEMS THAT
DON'T, TO BE HONEST, AREN'T USER
FRIENDLY, RIGHT? WE SEE UMBRELLA
PROGRAMS WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HOUSING, WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT REENTRY, WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT, WHETHER IT'S SOCIAL
SERVICES OR ANYTHING ELSE,
THERE'S SO MANY PROGRAMS AND
IT'S NOT CLEAR HOW THEY EVEN
TALK TO EACH OTHER. RIGHT. AND
MAYBE AND I'M A BIG FAN OF
CONSOLIDATION, I THINK SOME
THINGS NEED TO BE CONSOLIDATED.
WEBSITES NEED TO BE UPDATED. AND
A HUGE EFFORT WHEN WE'RE
SPENDING BILLIONS AND BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS, WE SHOULD ALSO BE
PRIORITIZING THESE THINGS RIGHT,
SO I'M A BIG ADVOCATE OF THAT. I
WILL ALSO SAY, A HUGE PRIORITY
FOR ME. AND IT'S OUTSIDE OF MY
BUDGET. SUB FIVE IS AGAIN THE
SOCIAL SERVICES FOR THE MOST
NEEDY AND VULNERABLE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THAT HAS TO BE THE
PRIORITY WHEN WE ARE MAKING A
BUDGET. THAT HAS TO BE FIRST.
HOW DO WE MAKE THESE INDIVIDUALS
WHOLE? AND THEN EVERYTHING ELSE
CAN BE NEGOTIATED, WITH THAT
SAID, I ALSO THINK HOUSING, AS
MUCH AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, WE'VE SPENT THIS MUCH
MONEY, WE HAVEN'T SEEN A RESULT
HERE. WE'VE JUST STARTED
SPENDING MONEY ON HOUSING.
REDEVELOPMENT HAS BEEN CUT FOR
CITIES. THERE'S A LOT OF SHOVEL
READY PROJECTS THAT ARE IN LIMBO
JUST BECAUSE OF ONGOING FUNDING
AND POTENTIAL IMPACTS. THERE I
THINK THAT THAT IS A DISSERVICE
TO THE LARGER COMMUNITY WHEN WE
ARE PROVIDING GOVERNMENT FUNDS
FOR A LOT OF THESE PROGRAMS,
WHETHER IT'S HOUSING OR
OTHERWISE. I ALSO BELIEVE THAT
WE NEED TO PUT MORE
QUALIFICATIONS AND RESTRICTIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE, AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SHOULD BE DEED RESTRICTED
REGARDLESS OF OWNERSHIP, RIGHT?
IT SHOULD BE CONTINUOUSLY AND
PERPETUALLY BE AFFORDABLE TO
RESIDENTS MOVING FORWARD. WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SHELTER
FUNDS FOR EXAMPLE, IN ONE OF MY
COUNTIES, IT'S ROUGHLY $34 A
NIGHT. IT HAS NOT CHANGED FOR
DECADES. WE SHOULD BE TRYING TO
PRIORITIZE THAT. ADDING COLA
INCREASES. AND YOU KNOW, WHAT
DOES IT REALLY TAKE TO PROVIDE
THESE TYPES OF SERVICES? SO I
REALLY WANT TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF
THOSE THINGS. OBVIOUSLY IT'S A
LONGER DISCUSSION, AND FAR MORE
INTO THE DETAILS, BUT THAT IS
VERY, VERY IMPORTANT TO ME. SO I
DO JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT.
I ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
FACT THAT WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT
UNDOCUMENTED RESIDENTS AS A
BURDEN TO OUR SYSTEM. AND YET WE
DON'T REALIZE AND MANY PEOPLE
WHO TALK ABOUT THIS DON'T
REALIZE THAT THEY ARE A PART OF
OUR COMMUNITY. FIRST AND
FOREMOST, AND WE NEED TO START
ENSURING THAT WE AGAIN, MAKE
EVERY RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
FEEL WHOLE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
THEY DO WORK AND CONTRIBUTE TO
OUR SOCIETY, AND WE, OF COURSE,
NEED TO BE PLANNING FOR OUR
ENTIRE STATE MOVING FORWARD. SO
I JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
I, AGAIN APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
YOU GUYS DO AND I THANK YOU.
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS, AGAIN THANK YOU
EVERYONE, AND WE WILL NOW
PROCEED TO MOTIONS AND VOTING.
SO WE'LL START WITH AB 107, THE
BUDGET ACT OF 2024. DO I HAVE A
MOTION MOTION BY SENATOR LAIRD,
AND WE WILL CALL THE ROLL. AND
THIS IS A MOTION, DO PASS TO THE
FLOOR. AB 107. THE MOTION IS DO
PASS. SENATORS WIENER I WIENER I
NILO NÓ NILO NÓ. BECKER. BECKER
I BLAKE. SPEER. BLAKE. SPEER I
CORTEZ. CORTEZ I. DOLLY. NO.
DOLLY NO. DURAZZO. DURAZZO I,
EGGMAN, I, EGGMAN, I GROVE.
GROVE NO. LAIRD I, LAIRD I
MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I NEWMAN
NAY, NEWMAN I PADILLA I PADILLA
I ROTH I ROTH I SATO NO. SATO,
NO. SKINNER I SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS, WAHAB I WAHAB
I WILK. NO. WILK, NO. 13 FIVE
OKAY. THE VOTE IS 13 TO 5 AND
THAT MOTION PASSES. WE'LL NEXT
GO TO AB 154, WHICH IS RELATING
TO THE, PROP 98 SUSPENSION MOVED
BY SENATOR LAIRD. AND WE WILL
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS ALSO DUE
PASS TO THE FLOOR. AB 154. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED. SENATORS
WIENER I WIENER I NILO NØ. NILO
NÓ. BECKER. BECKER I BLAKE.
SPEER I BLAKE. SPEER I CORTEZ.
CORTEZ I. DOLLY NO. DOLLY, NO.
DURAZZO. DURAZZO. I EGGMAN,
EGGMAN I, EGGMAN, I. GROVE.
GROVE, NO. LAIRD I, LAIRD I
MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I NEWMAN
NEWMAN I, PADILLA I PADILLA I
ROTH A ROTH I CIERTO CIERTO. NO.
SKINNER. SKINNER I SMILED.
CUEVAS, WAHAB I WAHAB I WILK.
NO. WILK. NO THAT WAS A POWERFUL
BEGIN. WE HAVE. THANK YOU. 35.
THE VOTE IS 13 TO 5 AND THAT
MOTION PASSES. AND THEN FINALLY
WE'LL MOVE TO AB 167, RELATING
TO TAXATION. DO I HAVE A MOTION?
MOTION BY BY SENATOR LAIRD. AND
THAT MOTION IS TO. IS Dð PASSED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AB 167. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS. SENATORS WIENER I
WIENER I NILO NØ. NILO NÓ.
BECKER A BECKER I BLAKE. SPEER.
HI BLAKE. SPEER I CORTEZ. CORTEZ
I DOLLY. DOLLY. NØ. DURAZZO
DURAZZO I EGGMAN. EGGMAN I GROVE
. GROVE. NÓ. LAIRD I LAIRD I
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR I NEWMAN
NEWMAN I PADILLA. PADILLA I ROTH
I ROTH I SATO. SATO NØ. SKINNER
I, SKINNER I SMALLWOOD, CUEVAS.
WAHAB I WAHAB I WILK. NØ. WILK.
NÓ 13 TO 5. OKAY, THAT VOTE IS
13 TO 5. THE MOTION PASSES,
WE'VE NOW COMPLETED ALL BUSINESS
. COMPLETED ALL BUSINESS. I WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE FOR TODAY. AND
WITH THAT, WE ARE ADJOURNED.